GENTLEMEN OF COMMITTEE. WE
WELCOME ALL WERE WATCHING
ONLINE AND HERE IN THE CHAMBERS
THIS I THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE LAYS IN GERMAN BEFORE
WE GET INTO TODAY'S HEARING WE
LIKE TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM. MR
CONSULTANT CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL SENATOR MCGUIRE HERE
REQUIRE PRESIDENT SENATOR
NIELSEN NILSSON PRESIDENT
SENATOR ALSO. SENATOR HERTZBERG
YEAH PARTS BERG PRESIDENT
SENATOR WIENER. WIENER
PRESIDENT YOU HAVE A WHOLE
PLACING. OF CORN HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED FOR GRATEFUL THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER GRINNELL.
CENTER DERIVES THOUGH HE'S
CURRENTLY RUNNING A BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE SHE WILL BE COMING
INTO GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
AFTER HER SUBCOMMITTEE. HAS
COMPLETED ITS WORK SHE IS
CHAIRING THAT SUBCOMMITTEE.
LAYS IN GERMAN WHAT I'D LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO DO TODAY IS TO FOCUS
ON THE FLOW OF TODAY'S HEARING
THEN WOULD LIKE TO TALK ABOUT
HOW. WE'RE GONNA BE ADVANCING
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION AND WE'RE
LOOKING FORWARD TO HEARING FROM
EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU WHO
ARE ON THE LINE THANK YOU SO
MUCH. FOR YOUR PATIENCE HERE
TODAY AS A COMMITTEE GOT
STARTED. LATE IN GERMAN I LIKE
TO FIRST FOCUS ON ONE BILL MAKE
SOME COMMENTS THEN AND LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO GO THROUGH THE FLOW
FOR TODAY'S HEARING. THAT BILL
IS. SENATE BILL TWO SEVENTY ONE
AND I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
SENATOR WIENER NOT FOR BRINGING
SENATE BILL TWO SEVENTY ONE
FORWARD. THAT BILL IS FOCUSED
ON COUNTY SHERIFFS AND
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS FOR
CANDIDATESRUNNING FOR THE
OFFICE OF SHERIFF. CENTER WE'RE
AND I WORK ON A VARIETY OF
POLICY ISSUES TOGETHER. NOT
MANY ARE COMPLICATED BOLD AND
RIGHTFULLY AMBITIOUS. AND
SENATE BILL TWO SEVENTY ONE IS
NO DIFFERENT. AT CENTER WINNER
AND I AGREE THAT THIS ISSUE
SHOULD AND MUST MOVE FORWARD.
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY ON. AND THEN
MINCE RELATED TO THE BILL- BUT
TO YOU CAN. OF THE LEGISLATE
COUNT. WE WON'T HEARING THE
BILL TO DO. BUT WE ARE GONNA
CONTINUE. TO WORK ON THE BILL.
IN THE COMING WEEKS IN MY- THIS
COMMITTEE WILL HAVE A TWO YEAR
DEAL HEARING. IN THE MONTH OF
JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO
FOR THIS LEGISLATION AMONG
OTHER BILLS WOULD BE ELIGIBLE.
IF IT WORKS FOR THE COMMITTEE I
NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO CENTER
WINNER HE SAFE YOU COMMENTS IN
CENTER WINNER. AGAIN WHETHER
IT'S ISSUES OF HOUSING. ALL
ISSUES OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT IN
SPECIFICALLY ON THIS BILL ONE
TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU
WE HAVE PARTNERED ON A LOT OVER
THE YEARS I'M VERY GRATEFUL FOR
THAT. I TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO
YOU FOR OPENING COMMENTS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU. FOR THOSE COMMENTS- AND
CLOSE CONCERT. WITH THE CHAIR.
AND WITH OUR GRASSROOTS
PROGRESSIVECOALITION WE
DECIDED TO MAKE. SP TWO SEVENTY
WIND THE SHERIFF DEMOCRACY AND
DIVERSITY OCT. BUT TO YOUR BELT
MEANING THAT AS THE CHURCH'S
INDICATED IT WILL BE ELIGIBLE
FOR A COMMITTEE HEARING. NEXT
JANUARY- WE YOU ARE WE'RE NOT
ABLE TO AGREE TO THE AMENDMENT
OUTLINED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS. UNFORTUNATELY WE WERE
WORKING IN EARNEST TO- WORK
THROUGH THE- THE ISSUES ON THE
COME UP WITH THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WE COULD ALL AGREE TO. AND
WE SIMPLY RAN OUT OF TIME- IN
OUR EFFORTS TO REACH ABOUT
AGREEMENTS. I AM. UNWAVERING
AND MY COMMITMENT TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA SHERIFF'S. MORE
ACCOUNTABLE TO VOTERS. AND TO
STRENGTHEN OUR DEMOCRACY AND
CONTINUE WITH OUR PUSH TOWARDS
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM AND.
CHANGING POLICING IN CALIFORNIA.
THE STATUS QUO. YOUR LAWN. HAS
EFFECTIVELY CORNERED THE MARKET
ON THIS POWERFUL OFFICE BY
LITERALLY BANNING. EVERYONE
ELSE FROM RUNNING IS SIMPLY
UNACCEPTABLE IT LEADS TO A
PROFOUND LACK OF ACCOUNTABILITY
AND CREATES MAJOR PROBLEMS IN
VARIOUS COUNTY JAILS. THAT'S
WHY FOR THE FIRST TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTY NINE YEARS OF OUR
STATE SIX. CAL ALLOWED ANY TO
RUN FOR SURE. AND THAT'S WHY.
THIRTY FOR OTHER STATES DO NOT
HAVE THE TRICK. AND IN DEMO
RESTRICTION ON WHO CAN RUN FOR
SHERIFF. WE ARE CONTINUALLY
REMINDED OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT ACCOUNTABILITY
WHEN IT COMES TO THE ROLE OF
SHERIFF'S. SHERIFF'S CARRY OUT
PUBLIC HEALTH ORDERS OR
SOMETIMES DON'T CARRY THEM OUT.
THEY RUN OUR COUNTY JAILS THEY
RUN MAJOR HEALTHCARE SYSTEMS
AND THEY HAVE AN OUTSIZED
IMPACT ON HEALTH CALIFORNIA'S
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
OPERATES. BY MAKING SPEECH TO
SEVENTY WANTED TO YOUR BILL THE
CHAIR A GRASSROOTS COALITION
AND I HAVE AGREED THAT WE WILL
WORK COLLABORATIVELY TOGETHER
TO CHART A PATH. TO MOVE THIS
BILL FORWARD IN JANUARY. GERMAN
CHOIR AND I HAVE A VERY LONG
HISTORY OF WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY TOGETHER TO
FIND THE PATH FOR DIFFICULT
LEGISLATION. AND THE CHAIR IS
AN ARDENT SUPPORTER OF CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM AND POLICE
REFORM AND I'M OPTIMISTIC WE'LL
BE ABLE TO FIND A PATH FORWARD.
FOR NEXT JANUARY AGAIN THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN THANK YOU SO
MUCH AT CENTER WINNER VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THAT SO LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THAT WE WERE GOING TO
CONTINUE THAT COLLABORATIVE
DISCUSSION HERE IN THE WEEKS
AND MONTHSTO COME. AGAIN SEND
A WINNER THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THIS. SIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF COMMITTEE WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE TWENTY BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA NINETEEN WITH AUTHORS
PRESENTING- IN ONE PROPOSE FOR
CONSENT OUR CURRENT CAN THE
CONSENT CALENDAR CONSISTS OF
ITEM NUMBER. THERE IS THERE A
MOTION TO APPROVE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
VICE CHAIR IN NIELSEN A MOTION
BY VICE CHAIR NIELSEN. MR CANAL
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO ADOPT THE
CONSENT CALENDAR SENATOR
MCGUIRE I REQUIRE- A SENATOR
NIELSEN. NIELSEN HI SENATOR
ALSO. SENATOR HERTZBERG.
SENATOR WIENER HI WINNER HI THE
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE ZERO
THREE ZERO ON THE CONSENT
CALENDARWE'RE GONNA KEEP THE
ROLL OPEN AND ALLOW CENTER
DRAWS SO IN MAJORITY LEADER
HERTZBERG TO BE ABLE TO ADD ON
PLACING GENOMMEN AUTHORS WILL
BE PRESENTING HERE IN THE
SENATE CHAMBER TODAY EXCEPT FOR
SENATOR THE MON SHE'S GONNA BE
PRESENTING REMOTELY ON HURT TO
BILL ITEMS ITEM NUMBER FOUR IS
WELL IS ITEM NUMBER TEN SP FIVE
FOUR TWO NSP FIVE FIVE THREE.
WE DO HAVE A FEW ITEMS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA THEY'RE GONNA
GENERATE WELL QUITE A BIT OF
DISCUSSION DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS IN CLEANING
PROTOCOLS WE'RE GONNA HEAR IT
ONE OF THOSE ITEMS FIRST AND
THAT'S SENATE BILL THREE FORTY
TWO BUT MISS GONZALEZ ALSO
BECAUSE OF THE CONSTRAINTS THAT
I JUST MENTIONED ON THE LINKS
AT TODAY'S HEARING INTO LEAVE
ENOUGH TIME FOR MEMBERS TO BE
AT A DEBATE AND DISCUSS THE
BILLS WE WILL HAVE A LIMIT ON
TESTIMONY FOCUSED ON SENATE
BILL THREE FORTY TWO. AND OTHER
BILLS IF NECESSARY WITH THAT
SAID THESE LIMITS THESE LIMITS
ARE GOING TO BE EQUALLY APPLIED
TO BOTH SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
AS WE ALWAYS DO HEARING
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE ONE MORE
TIME EQUAL OPPORTUNITY EQUAL
TIME FOR BOTH SIDES THE TIME
LIMIT FOR EACH SIDE OF SP THREE
FORTY TWO WILL BE TWENTY
MINUTES WHICH STARTS ONCE EACH
SENATOR HAD IT WILL BE TWENTY
MINUTES- WHICH STARTS WHEN
CENTER GONZALEZ HAS FINISHED
HER PRESENTATION. ALSO THE
COMMITTEE WILL BE MOVING ITEM
FOURTEEN THE COMMITTEE WILL BE
MOVING ITEM FOURTEEN SP SIX TEN
SENATOR GROVE TO THE THIRD ITEM
HEARD TODAY I WOULD NOW LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO OUTLINE THE FIRST
THREE BILLS THAT GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE WILL BE HEARING. IN
TODAY'S AGENDA. SP THREE FOR
TWO. S. THREE THIRTY. AND S. P.
SIXTEEN AGAIN THE FIRST THREE
BILLS HEARD IN TODAY SIR WILL
BE S. THREE FOUR TWO SP
THIRTEEN N. S. V. SIX TEN.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN- IN
RESPONSE TO THE COPA NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATE TORS EMPLOYEES
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND
ADHERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AS
WELL AS FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THESE ORDERS TO SENATORS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO.
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUE
TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS IF YOU'RE
INTERESTED IN CALLING IN TODAY
WE LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING FROM
YOU- PLEASE CALLING TOLL FREE
TO OUR TELECONFERENCE LINE. OUR
PHONE NUMBER TODAY IS.
877-226-8152 THE CODE. ONE ONE
SEVEN FORTY SEVEN SEVENTY ONE.
THE PHONE NUMBER TO CALL IN
TOLL FREE RIGHT NOW IS ON YOUR
SCREEN AGAIN WE LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING FROM YOU. WHEN WE MOVED
TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'RE GONNA
BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO
DIAL. ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY TODAY AND TO BE ABLE TO
AVOID THAT ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK
THAT WE'VE ALL COME TO LOVE.
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO PLEASE
MUTE YOUR DEVICE THAT YOU'RE
WATCHING ON. A PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IN
THE UNLIKELY EVENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN AN INDIVIDUAL BECOMES
UNRULY EITHER ON THE PHONE OR
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM. THAT
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE
PROCEEDINGS WHETHER IT'S THE
REMOTE MEETING OR- THEY'LL HAVE
THEIR CONNECTION MUTED OR HERE
IN OUR CHAMBERS. IN OUR
OVERFLOW ROOM. ALL RIGHT. THEY
SEEM GENUINE SO WE HAVE MOVED
ON OUR CONSENT CALENDAR WE HAVE
A QUORUM ESTABLISHED WE WALK
THROUGH HOW WE'RE GOING TO BE
WORKING WITH EACH OTHER. I
PROMISE YOU THAT WE'RE GONNA
TAKE IT SLOW AND STEADY WE ALL
HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF PATIENCE
WE'RE GONNA GET THROUGH TODAY
WE GOT A LENGTHY HEARING IN
FRONT OF US. SO LET'S GET RIGHT
INTO IT PLACE IN GENERAL NOW
GOING TO GO TO OUR FIRST BILL
TODAY THAT'S ITEM- SP THREE
FORTY TWO CENTER GONZALEZ.
CENTERING THE DIALYSIS HERE WE
APPRECIATE THE WORK CENTER IN
SOUTH THE FLOOR IS YOURS. ON SP
THREE FOUR TWO. THANK YOU MR.
GOOD MORNING- I AM TODAY TO
PRESENT SP THREE FORTY TWO AND
FIRST MISTER CHAIRMAN TO SAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
WORKING- WITH ME AS WELL AS
YOUR- CONSULTANTS FOR THE
WONDERFUL ANALYSIS. SO SP THREE
FORTY TWO WHICH WILL FACILITATE
COMMUNITY INVOLVEMENT AND
PROMOTE EQUITY BY ADDING TO
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
REPRESENTATIVES. TO THE SOUTH
COAST AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT GOVERNING BOARD.
DESPITE SIGNIFICANT AIR QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL DECADES THE SOUTH COAST
AIR BASIN HAS BECOME. AND IS
ONE OF THE WORST AIR QUALITY-
AREAS IN THE NATION.
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES HAVE
HISTORICALLY BEEN OVERBURDENED
WITH THE IMPACTS OF AIR
POLLUTION AND CONTAMINATION IN
THE SOUTH COAST BASIN WITH
HIGHER RATES OF PREMATURE
DEATHS. ASTHMA HOSPITALIZATIONS
AND EMERGENCY ROOM VISITS ONLY
EXACERBATED BY KOBE NINETEEN.
THESE COMMUNITIES LIKE THOSE IN
MY DISTRICT IN SOUTHEAST LOS
ANGELES AND ALONG THE WEST SIDE
OF LONG BEACH. AND THE I.
SEVENTEEN CORRIDOR PAY THE
HIGHEST COST WITH THEIR LIFE
AND HEALTH. APPOINTING MEMBERS
OF A COMMITTEE BOARD THAT
REPRESENT AND WORK DIRECTLY
WITH COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY BURDENED. BY
HIGH LEVELS OF POLLUTION WILL
BRING VALUABLE EXPERTISE.
CONCERNING THE ENVIRONMENTAL
BURDENS THAT ARE UNDERMINING
THE REGION'S ABILITY TO MEET
AIR QUALITY STANDARDS. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THIS
BILL DOES NOT UNDERMINE LOCAL
CONTROL I WANT TO BE VERY
CLEAR. TWO THIRDS OF THE IT CAN
D. BOARD. WOULD STILL BE
APPOINTED BY LOCAL CITIES AND
COUNTIES. AS B. THREE FORTY TWO
WILL SIMPLY BEGIN CORRECTING
INJUSTICES STEMMING FROM
DECADES OF DISCRIMINATORY LAND
USE AND POLICY DECISIONS. WE
MUST ACT NOW TO DELIBERATELY
INCLUDE INVOICES AND ESTABLISH
ACTIVE LONG TERM COMMUNITY
REPRESENTATION AS WE STRUGGLE
TO MEET FEDERAL AIR QUALITY
STANDARDS. TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT TODAY I HAVE FAMILY
WE'RE- ON BEHALF OF THE-
SUPERVISOR NATHAN FLETCHER SAN
DIEGO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. WHO ALSO SERVES AS
A CARB BOARD MEMBER. AS WELL AS
CHRIS TRAVIS DEPUTY POLICY
DIRECTOR WITH THE COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR. AND AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME MISTER CHAIR I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE ON
SB THREE FORTY TWO. SENATORS US
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR GRATEFUL
YOU'RE HERE TODAY THIS IS WHERE
OUR TWENTY MINUTES WILL START
ON EACH SIDE THIS IS GOING TO
BE TWENTY MINUTES STARTING FOR
THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT. EMILY
WE'RE WILL KICK US OFF ON
BEHALF OF CHEER MR FLETCHER
FROM THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS AND WE'RE GONNA
TURN IT OVER TO MR CHAVEZ FOR
THE COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR.
MISS WE'RE WE WELCOME YOU TO
COMMITTEE YOU HAVE A STRICT
THREE MINUTES I WILL GIVE YOU A
THIRTY SECOND PROMPT THE FLOOR
IS NOW YOURS WELCOME TO
COMMITTEE. GOOD MORNING CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YOU'RE COMING IN LOUD
AND CLEAR PLEASE PROCEED. A
GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH AGAIN
MY NAME IS EMILY WE ARE AND I'M
READING TESTIMONY INTO THE
RECORD FOR YOU CAN PUT YOUR
CHAIR AND THE FANDANGO COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS A MEMBER
OF THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD AND ALSO THIRD ON OUR
LOCAL AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT. L. BEGAN THE MORNING
TERM ACQUIRE MEMBERS THE SENATE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE IT IS MY DISTINCT
PLEASURE TO ADDRESS YOU TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE FORTY
TWO FROM SENATOR LENA GONZALEZ.
IT IS VITALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
ADDRESS OUR AIR QUALITY
CHALLENGES THIS ROLE IS ONE I
TAKE SERIOUSLY EIGHT IN MY ROLE
ON THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD AS WELL AS LOCALLY AS A
MEMBER OF THE SAN DIEGO AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT
BOARD. BOTH OF THESE BOARDS
HAVE PJ REPRESENTATION AND WE
ARE MORE AFFECTED BODIES
BECAUSE OF IT. I SERVE ON THE
BOARD BECAUSE I BELIEVE THAT
ADDRESSING OUR AIR QUALITY
ISSUES IT'S AN ABSOLUTE
IMPERATIVE SH MANY REGIONS OF
THE STATE ARE IN SEVERE NON
ATTAINMENT WITH FEDERAL CLEAN
AIR ACT STANDARDS SH WE HAVE
CHILDREN THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING IN MY SUPERVISORY ALL
DISTRICT. WHO ARE MORE LIKELY
TO HAVE ASTHMA. BECAUSE OF THE
ZIP CODE THEY LIVE IN. SH
ENVIRONMENT JUSTICE FOR. HELP
BATTERED OUR ERIC CHALLENGE
PLAY OUR STATE SCHMIDT WITH THE
ADDITION OF BJ REPRESENT. BOTH
AT R. EIGHTY C. D. AND F. CARD
THESE AGENCIES ARE BORED ARE
MUCH MORE. AND ARE INCLUSIVE
AND DIVERSE PUSHBACK. WE ARE
OUR- THE- THAT COMMUNITY MOST
IMPACTED BY AIR QUALITY. I THE
THREE FORTY TWO APART SUPPORT
AND FOLLOW GRAY LOCAL CONTROL
OF JUSTICE MAKING. AT THE
COUNTY. I AND OF LOCAL CONTROL
HELLO ELECTED OFFICIAL WERE
LIKE THE GOVERNOR. BUT I A FIRM.
OF FOUR TO FROM A FAMILY MEMBER
TOGGLE IN NINE. BECAUSE IT IS.
OUR PCT FOR AND WAY THAT
DIRECTLY EXPANDED LOCAL. THIS
CELL JUST LIKE A REPORT YOUR
EMPOWERS WILL CONTROL IT
DOESN'T TAKE IT AWAY. EMPOWERS
LOCAL COMMUNITIES TO HAVE A
SEAT AT THE TABLE WITHOUT
TAKING AWAY REPRESENTATION FROM
ANY OTHER INDUSTRY OR IMPACTED
GROUP. AND IT MAKE SURE THAT
ALL VOICES ARE EQUAL THIRTY
SECONDS LOCAL COMMUNITY
MEMBERS. ARE TRULY ACCOUNTABLE
TO THE COMMUNITY THEY REPRESENT
BECAUSE THEY LIVE AND WORK
THERE. I WANT TO CONCLUDE WITH
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE FILM AND
I THINK YOU. MISS WE ARE THANK
YOU SO MUCH THAT'S MISS WE'RE
FROM THE COUNTY SAN DIEGO AND
ON BEHALF OF NATHAN FLETCHER
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
CHAIRPERSON THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISS WE'RE GRATEFUL YOU'RE IN
COMMITTEE TODAY WE'RE NOW GOING
TO TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO CHRIS
CHAVEZ HE'S THE DEPUTY POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR THE COALITION.
CLEAN AIR CLEAN AIR. WELCOME TO
COMMITTEE YOU ARE A LOT YOU
HAVE THREE. IN A GIVE YOU A
THIRTY SECOND PROMPT PLEASE
PROCEED. RIGHT MORE COMMITTEE
MEMBER MY IS CHRIS OTHER THAN
THE DEATH PAUL DIRECTOR COLIN
FOR CLEAN AIR. I AM ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE WILMINGTON CARSON
WEST LONG BEACH EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTEEN COMMUNITY STEERING
COMMITTEE- THAT RAN BY THE
SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT. COALITION
FOR CLEAN AIR STRONGLY SUPPORTS
SB THREE FORTY TWO WHAT WOULD
ADD TWO NEW SEATS TO SOUTH
COAST EACH YEAR MEANS GOVERNING
BOARD. TO BETTER REPRESENT
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES. THOSE LIVING AND
WORKING IN THE SOUTH COAST AIR
BASIN READ SOME OF THE DIRTIEST
AIR IN THE NATION. SADLY THIS
BURDEN FALLS HEAVIEST ON
DISADVANTAGED AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. MANY OF THE
COMMUNITIES ARE LOCATED NEAR
POLLUTION SOURCES SUCH AS
REFINERIES. THE RECORD.
INDUSTRIAL FACILITIES.
DECISIONS MAY DECADES. SUCH AS
BILL FREEWAYS THROUGH OUR NAME.
CONTINUE TO HAVE ONE LASTING
HEALTH AND- NO LESS FIVE LARGE
OIL. THE BOOK OF CAL OIL
REFINING. ARE WE SEE OR NEAR
LAFAYETTE IS WILLING NC PETER
NEIGHBOR AS WELL AS THE CITY OF
CARSON. TODAY WE'RE ARE SPREAD
UP CLOSE AND CLOSER TO HOME
SCHOOLS IN THE INLAND EMPIRE
BRINGING POLLUTION TRAFFIC IN
OTHER QUALITY OF LIFE IMPACTS
CLOSE TO HOME AND IN SOME CASES
NEXT DOOR. THE SOUTH COAST AIR
BASIN IS CURRENTLY IN A NON IS
IN NON ATTAINMENT OF MULTIPLE
FEDERAL AND STATE AIR QUALITY
STANDARDS. FURTHER THE TOXIC
AIR CANCER RISK WHICH IS
ALREADY ELEVATED IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ITS HIGHEST IN
COMMUNITIES NEAR GOODS MOVEMENT
CORRIDORS DUE TO DIESEL
PARTICULATE MATTER. THE EFFECT
OF THAT COUPLED WITH OTHER
INEQUITIES ARE STARK. THE
LIFESPAN IN MY ZIP CODE ON THE
WESTERN SIDE OF LONG BEACH IS
THAT THE EIGHT YEAR SHORTER.
THAN THE MARK CITIES MORE OF
FLUID EASTERN ZIP CODES. AT
THREE FORTY TWO WOULD BEGIN
CORRECTING THIS PROBLEM BY
GIVING ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES MORE
REPRESENTATION. CURRENTLY THE
FORMS AVAILABLE THE KEY TO YOUR
COMMUNITIES ARE AT BEST
ADVISORY. PRESENTATION WILL NOT
PREDETERMINE OUTCOMES OF THE
RULE MAKINGPROCESS RATHER IT
GIVES IMPACTED COMMUNITIES AN
ACTUAL DIRECT VOICE ON THE
MATTERS ABOUT THE AIR THEY
BREATHE. AND IT'S CENTERED IS
NOTED UNDER SB THREE FORTY TWO
TWO THIRDS OF THE FEET OF THE
SOUTH BECAUSE HUMAN YOU BOARD
WOULD STILL BE APPOINTED BY
CITY AND COUNTY. THIS BILL IS
NOT A THREAT TO LOCAL. IT IS
NOT AFFECT CITIES CAMPAIGNS
WERE COUNTY LAND USE POLICY
DECISIONS. IT'S JUST ABOUT
GIVING IMPACTED COMMUNITIES A
VOICE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
PRETTY GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION IN TODAY'S
HEARING THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR COMMENTS LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE COMMITTEE WE'RE
NOT GOING TO BE LOOKING TO ROOM
ONE TWELVE THAT'S OUR OVERFLOW
ROOM TODAY. AT LOOKING AT ROOM%
ONE TWELVE TO SEE IF WE HAVE
ANYONE WHO'D LIKE TO GO TO
SPEAK IN ROOM ONE TWELVE-
ANYONE WHAT WISHING TO SPEAK IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE ON S. THREE
THREE FOUR TWO PLEASE STAND NOW.
HEARING SCENE NOW AND LAYS IN
GERMAN WE'RE NOT GONNA BE GOING
TOWARD TELECONFERENCE LINE. WE
WANT TO REMIND ALL FOLKS WHO
ARE ON HOLD WE'RE LOOKING FOR
SUPPORT WE'RE LOOKING FOR
SUPPORT OF SB THREE FOUR TWO.
THOSE WHO ARE PREPARING TO BE A
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
FOUR TWO. WE'RE GONNA ASK YOU
TO PLEASE PROVIDE YOUR FIRST
AND LAST NAME. THE ORGANIZATION
YOU REPRESENT IN YOUR STANCE ON
THE BILL. ALL RIGHT. SO WE'RE
NOW GOING TO BE GOING. TO HOPE
I APOLOGIZE. WE SHOULD HAVE
GONE HERE- IT TO THE CHAMBERS
MY DAD. SO I HAD THAT FIRST
START OUT SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
HERE IN HE CHAMBERS WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK. ON SP THREE FOUR
TWO I APOLOGIZE ABOUT THAT.
LET'S GO TO THE CHAMBERS. ALL
RIGHT HERE IN C. KNOWN RISE ON
SP THREE FOUR TWO WE'RE GONNA
GO BACK TO OUR TELECONFERENCE
LINE- AND CHECK IN I'M GONNA
LOOK TO CARLOS IS SERGEANT WE
HAVE ANYONE UP- IN THE BACK AND
HE WOULD LIKE TO BE TO
PARTICIPATE. YEAH OKAY. WE'RE
NOW GOING TO BE GOING TOWARD
TELECONFERENCE LINE MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU CAN PLEASE
PROMPT. ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB THREE FOUR TWO NOW. THANK
YOU YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
THE STATE YOUR POSITION OF
SUPPORT PRESS B. THREE FOUR TWO
AGAIN THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
WE DO HAVE SEVERAL IN Q. FIRST
LINE IS. TWO THIRTY FOUR TWO
THREE FOUR. GOOD MORNING
MORNING. JOSE TRINIDAD CAPPING
AT BOTH THE MANAGER WITH ASKING
HIM ON ALSO LATER MY THAT COULD
BE BE YOU READERS AND THREE AND
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF COUNCIL
GREAT AND STRONG SUPPORT. THE
YOU SO MUCH THAT'S GOING TO
NEXT CALL PLEASE. WHY ONE OH
FOUR. LINE ONE OH FOUR YEAR IN
COMMITTEE PLEASE PROCEED. NEXT
CALLER MISTER MODERATOR. NINE
TO FIFTEEN. NORTH AMERICA
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION VOTERS
AND STRONG COMPORT THANK YOU MR
MARYLAND NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
SEVEN NINE SEVENTY NINE. LINE
SEVENTY NINE YEAR IN COMMITTEE
PLEASE PROCEED. MR MODERATOR
NEXT CALLER. BLIND. ONE FORTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU TURN THE
CURRENT MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE NIKITA KARATE WITH
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU SO MUCH YOUR PHONE CALL
TODAY LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. ONE SIXTY TWO. HELLO.
GOOD ONE SIX TWO GOOD MORNING
MA'AM FIRST AND LAST NAME. FOR
A POSITION ON THE BILL PLEASE.
B. TWO SEVEN ONE NO THIS. TO SP
THREE FOUR TWO PLEASE PROCEED
SCOTT WIENER ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
MISTER MODERATOR. LINE. TWO OH
ONE. HELLO MY NAME IS BYRON
CHAN I'M A RESIDENT OF LOS
ANGELES IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU SO MUCH BYRON NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE FIFTY FIVE. DANIEL
GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ALLIANCE SAY HI CAN
SUPPORT THANKS DANIEL LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER. TWO SIXTY
NINE. HI MY NAME IS ELIAN
GONZALEZ I AM A RESIDENT OF
LONG BEACH AND I'M CALLING TO
SPEAK IN STRONG SUPPORT I'M A
REGULAR ATTENDEE AT THE AIR
QUALITY MEETINGS AND I HAVE TO
SAY THAT SOME OF THE CURRENT
REPRESENTATIVES HOLD THE
SPEAKERS AND SO MUCH TALENT
NEXT CALLER PLEASE WE'RE GONNA
REMIND ALL CALLERS FIRST AND
LAST NAME POSITION ON THE BILL
FIRST AND LAST NAME POSITION ON
THE BILL. THAT'S A MOVE TO OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE SEVENTY
THREE. NINE ONE SEVEN THREE
YOUR IN COMMITTEE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN INCURRING GOING GORE I
AM A RESIDENT FONTENOT MEMBER
THE COUNTY SEMOLINA PLANNING
COMMISSION AND A MEMBER OF THE
H. ONE B. ENVIRONMENT OBJECT
THE BRIGHTER GROUP CALLING IN
FAVOR OF AT THREE THREE FOUR
TWO THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY
THAT'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
BRIAN. SEVEN EIGHT. LINE
SETTLEMENT IS MARIO KART THE
OPERATING ENGINEERS AND I
OPPOSE REPORTED TO ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. LET'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALL A CLEAR LINE.
BEING A RESEARCHER. TO EIGHTY
SEVEN. LINE TWO EIGHTY SEVEN
YOU'RE IN COMMITTEE. I LET'S
SEE THE DEADLINE IS- CLOSED
MORE MOVE ON THAT'S OKAY PLEASE
PROCEED. TO SIXTY EIGHT. HI
THIS IS EVAN MINTON WITH VOICES
FOR PROGRESS FOR CALLING IN
VERY STRONG SUPPORT IN
BARTONVILLE THANK YOU SO MUCH
HAVE INCREASED IT THE PHONE
CALL NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE
NINETY TWO. HELLO THIS IS SEEN
AS A MAN FROM THE LEADERSHIP
COUNSEL PROJECT WITH
ACCOUNTABILITY CALLING THE
SUPPORT AND DEMAND CONDITIONS
FOR REASONS OUTLINED IN OUR
PREVIOUS STUDY THANK YOU. YOUR
PHONE CALL TO THANK YOU SO MUCH
THAT'S GOING TO RENEGE CALLER.
TO SIXTY SIX. NAME WELL THERE
WAITING ONLINE TO SIX SIX YEAR
COMMITTEE FOR C. NEXT CALLER
MISTER MODERATOR. NINE TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT. I AGREE WITH
ARTICLE THEY'RE NOT CAN WE STAY
OUT A BUILDING NOT VISION I
THINK YOU SO MUCH MIKE THE SO I
YOU MAY HEAR DURING SUPPORT MAY
HEAR OPPOSITE DURING OPPOSITE
YOU MAY SOME SOME WE TAKE IT
ALL HEARING AND FINANCE AND
THAT'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. TWO TWENTY SIX. MY NAME
IS MONICA GRAY I'M A RESIDENT
OF VENTURA COUNTY AND I STAND
IN STRONG OPPOSITION. TO THIS
BILL. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO
MUCH MONICA WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PHONE CALL TODAY LET'S GO TO
OUR- NEXT CALLER. ONE
SEVENTEEN. I GUESS WITH THE
OPERATING ENGINEERS AND I SAY
WHAT THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH YOUR
PHONE CALL MR MODERATOR I'M
GONNA ASK YOU TO PLEASE REMIND
ALL CALLERS WERE CURRENTLY IN
SUPPORT IF WE CAN DO AT ALL
CALLED FINAL CALL ALL CALL
FINAL CALL FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT
OF SB THREE FOUR TWO IF YOU
COULD PLEASE QUEUE UP THOSE IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE FOUR TWO MR
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE DO SO
NOW. THANK YOU TO STATE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THAT BILL SB THREE
FORTY TWO MAIN PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. IF YOU'RE IN QUEUE FOR A
DIFFERENT BILL OVER THE
DIFFERENT POSITION YOU MAY
REPEAT THE COMMAND TO REMOVE
YOURSELF AT THIS TIME. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO TAKE THE NEXT CALL
LET'S DO THAT MR MODERATOR
THANK YOU SO MUCH. YOU'RE
WELCOME. NINE SIXTY SIX ZERO.
LINE SIXTY YEAR IN COMMITTEE.
ALL RIGHT NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
ONE ONE NINETY SEVEN. HI GOOD
MORNING THIS IS OSCAR ESPINO
BUT ON AN ATTORNEY AT
EARTHJUSTICE CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT. WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PHONE CALL TODAY THANK YOU FOR
HOLDING AS WELL LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER. ONE SIXTY TWO. I'M
CALLING TO SAY NO TO SPEAK TWO
SEVEN ONE NEXT CALLER BELIEVES
SO MUCH. LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE MR MODERATOR.
NINE EIGHTY EIGHT. GOOD MORNING
GLOBAL OF IRONWORKERS UNION
LOCAL THREE SEVENTY EIGHT
STANDING IN SOLIDARITY WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION
TO THE SP THREE FOUR TWO THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE CALL
TODAY WE'RE GOING TO GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER. TWO FIFTY ONE.
HELLO M NAME IS WE'VE BEEN A
MORE VISIBLE MAKERS LOCAL
NINETY TWO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WE STRONGLY OPPOSES A BILL WITH
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
FIND. ONE OH EIGHT. NINE ONE
AWAIT CORY ARRIVED WITH A VALID.
THIS IS KOREAN RICE WITH THE
VALLEY BUILDING TRADES CAN YOU
HEAR ME. COREY PLEASE PROCEED.
I APOLOGIZE THAT YOU'RE STILL
DOING SUPPORT BUT I STAND WITH
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITIONS. TO THREE FORTY
TWO. I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
COREY THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY THAT- GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE
TO SIXTY SIX. FOUR. EIGHT FIVE
ONE NINE TWO SIX SIX HEARING
COMMITTEE PLEASE PROCEED. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE HELLO MY NAME.
TRYING TO EIGHTY NINE. YES GOOD
MORNING MANY CANAL MODERATION
TITLING TRADES WERE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION S. B. THREE FOUR TWO
WHAT THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH
YOUR PHONE CALL HEY FIRST AND
FOREMOST WE APPRECIATE
EVERYBODY ROLLING WITH THE
PUNCHES TODAY AGAIN YOU'RE
GONNA HEAR FOLKS WHO ARE IN
OPPOSITION- DURING OUR SUPPORT
OUT FOR BILLS YOU'RE GONNA HEAR
FOLKS IN SUPPORT DURING
OPPOSITION FOR BILLS WE REALLY
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S PATIENCE
AND ROLLING WITH US HERE TODAY
MR MODERATOR WERE LOOKING FOR
SUPPORT WITH ABOUT FOUR MORE
MINUTES- OUT HERE IN SUPPORT OF.
THREE FOUR TWO. MR MODERATOR
NEXT CALLER. TWO NINETY NINE.
HELLO GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
JOHN CARLA RUBIO AND I AM WITH
THE VALLEY INDUSTRY AND
COMMERCE ASSOCIATION AND WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SB THREE
FORTY TWO. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE
YOUR- TWO ELEVEN. HI MY NAME IS
RALPH HERNANDEZ PRESIDENT
DONALD KING COUNTY BUILDING
TRADE THEM STRONGLY OPPOSE
FIFTY THREE FORTY TWO THANK YOU
MR ANAND IS AT THAT'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE. THREE
OH TWO. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
MOSES WHATA RESIDENT OF THE
CITY OF PARAMOUNT I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL THREE
FIVE TWO. WE APPRECIATE YOU
CALLING IN TODAY THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. OKAY FINE. TWO
TWENTY TWO. DONNA DO PERON
TORRANCE AREA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE STRONGLY OPPOSE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE CALL
TODAY THAT'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. LINE. ONE TEN. FOR
EVERYONE. NOT JUST TO HELP
THIRTY SIX OUT MORE YOUNG
OPPOSITION TO THE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISS COLOR OF
MINE IS THE THAT WAS LAST CALL
I THIS OF SOME AD THAT WE'VE
ALSO SOME OFF BY- PLEASE
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG MR
MODERATOR. CURRENTLY NO OTHER
LINES IN Q. MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU SO MUCH AS A MODERATOR.
ALRIGHT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE
ARE NOW GOING TO BE GOING TO
THOSE WHO ARE OPPOSED TO SP
THREE FOUR TWO. THAT WE HAVE TO
LEAD WITNESSES EACH LEAD
WITNESS WILL GET THREE MINUTES.
WITH A THIRTY SECOND PROMPT THE
FIRST LEAD WITNESS WE'RE GONNA
HEAR FROM IS RON HERRERA HE'S
THE PRESIDENT TO LOS ANGELES
AND ORANGE COUNTY LABOR
FEDERATION. THAT WORD DIDN'T
GET TO HEAR FROM SERRA WHAT
PHONE SHE IS A POLICY MANAGER
FOR THE LA COUNTY BUSINESS
FEDERATION- THAT'S A WELCOME MR
HERRERA FROM THE LOS ANGELES
AND ORANGE COUNTY LABOR
FEDERATION. TO THE COMMITTEE MR
HER AIR AND WE WELCOME YOU TO A
COMMITTEE YOU ARE NOW LIVE YOU
HAVE THREE MINUTES AND I'LL
GIVE YOU THIRTY SECOND PROMPT
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING CINEMA VIA MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE COMMITTEE. ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE NAME IS
RON WORRIES YOU'VE HEARD. I'M
NOT DO. OF THE PORCH.
CONTAINING BROTHERHOOD
TEAMSTERS. AS WELL DEPENDING
UNLESS AND COUNTY. RIGHT. I'M
HERE TODAY TO SPEAK AN AWFUL OF
THE THREE FOUR TWO. WHICH AGAIN.
IN SENATOR LINEKER. THAT THEY
RECOGNIZE. THAT I HOLD SENATOR.
CONSOLIDATION REGARD. FOR I
HAVE DISAGREE. WITH HOW THE
PIECE OF LAND USE IS CRAP.
RESPOND QUICKLY. CHANGE THIS
FORM TO ADD TO ENVIRON JESS
MEMBER WITHOUT ADDING DIRECT OR-
FROM LABOR IS A CONCERN FOR
MOVIE. WE NEED TO FOLLOW
APPROACH IF WE'RE GOING THIS OF
THE BOARD THE POLICY THAT SOUTH
COAST AIR QUALITY SECTION
MILLIONS OF HARD WORKING. A
BILL. TO BRING IT CLEAN AIR
FUND AND- WE CANNOT LOSE THIS
CALL YOU KNOW WILL AFFECT WORK
HELLO. WITHOUT THE IN THE U.
THAT WRAPPING THE TO BE THE
TABLE. CHECK GONZALO FROM FROM
IT CHANGED FAMILY AND THOSE IN
JULY. BOBSLEIGH H. WHICH MOON
JUNE SHE- LABOR HOW A VOICE OF
THE J. WE HAVE ASKED FOR
MINIMUM THAT BOUND. THE
ADDITION OUR ENVIRONMENT
JUSTICE REPRESENT WITH RAPID.
FROM ONE OF THE NEW THAT RIGHT
WORK. WHO WILL BE CONTACT BY
THE- SET FORTH THE SOCCER AIR
BOARD WEEKS ALSO IN. BLOCK MARK
COLLECT MEMBER. DID NOT MOVE ME
BILL FORWARD. WITHOUT SOME BOMB
WHICH FINALLY. THANK THE OF MY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ZERO THANK
YOU SO MUCH OF YOUR PHONE CALL
HERE TODAY WE'RE GRATEFUL WE'RE
NOW GONNA BE TURN AT THE FLOOR
OVER TO SERRA WILL FUN FAIR IS
THE PA MANGER WITH THE COUNTY
BUSINESS CENTER. MISS WHAT PUNK
WELCOME YOU TO BE YOU THREE
MINUTES I'LL YOU A SECOND
PROMPT THE FLOOR IS YOURS YOU
ARE NOW LIE IN COMMITTEE PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DAVID MY NAME IS TERRIBLE PONG
AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF BEEN.
LOCKED INTO ANY BUSINESS
FEDERATION. AND A LINE FOR OVER
TWO HUNDRED BUSINESS
ORGANIZATION TO REPRESENT OVER
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND EMPLOYERS
AND FINANCIAL ACCOUNTING. WE
ARE CALLING IN OPPOSITION TO SB
THREE FORTY TWO FOR THE
FOLLOWING REASONS. WHY THE BILL
IS UNNECESSARY SPEAKER OF THE
FAMILY THE FEDERAL COMMITTEE
AND THE GOVERNOR ALREADY HAVE
AN APPOINTMENT TO BE CAN BE
BORED. THEIR APPOINTEES TIME
AND TIME AGAIN HAVE EXPRESSED
THEIR COMMITMENT TO IMPROVING
OUR ENVIRONMENT. BUT BOTH THE
SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY
APPOINTEES RESIDE IN
ENVIRONMENTAL. COMMUNITIES
ADDRESS I CALLIN BUYERS. NUMBER
TWO IF WE CAN GOOGLE LOCAL
CONTROL. IT TAKES THREE TO
AUTHORITY AWAY FROM LOCAL. WERE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE THEIR
CONSTITUENTS. AT THREE FORTY
TWO WOULD GET THEIR APPOINTED
NOT ELECTED REPRESENTATIVES ONE
THIRD OF THE SEATS IN THE
REGIONAL BOARD THAT IS MEANT TO
BE REPRESENTED BY LOCAL
INTERESTS. AND IS CURRENTLY
REPRESENTED BY THIRTEEN HUNDRED
BUSHELS FROM THE AREA THE
ELECTED OFFICIALS SERVING ON
THE BOARD HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY
TO THEIR VOTERS. AND THE VOTERS
ALLOWED THE PUBLICATION OF THE
WEEKEND BY ADDING MORE POINTS
YOU SCORE NOT ACCOUNTABLE TO
THE PUBLIC. NUMBER THREE AND
ATTACKED THE COMPETENCE OF
LOCAL LEADERS BY ADDING BOARD
SEATS AT THE THREE FORTY. FIVE
BUT LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS
SERVING ON THE BOARD ARE NOT
EFFECTIVELY SETTING LOCAL
POLICIES. SOMETHING OF A
CURRENT THIRTEEN MORE MEMBER
BOARD HAS DONE FOR ALMOST FIFTY
YEARS. THANK YOU THE RECENTLY
RELEASED THEIR MADE FIVE STUDY
WHICH MEASURES THE PROGRESS
MADE AN ERRANT ACTION. AND SOME
OF THE GREATEST RSK REDUCTIONS
HAVE OCCURRED ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITIES.
SPECIFICALLY THE STUDY SHOWED
BACK IN TWENTY TWELVE TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN A 55% REDUCTION IN THE
CROATIAN HEALTH RISK FROM AIR
CONTAMINANTS. NINETEEN NINETY
THE REGION'S POPULATION
INCREASED BY ABOUT 30% IN THE
REGION HAS EXPERIENCED A
GREATER THAN 75% REDUCTION IN
INFLATION HELPED RESTRICT AIR
CONTAMINANTS. I KNOW DON'T
DESIGN VALUES DECREASED BY
ABOUT FIFTY PERCENT. IT SHOWS
THAT THE PARTICULAR MATTER
CONTINUE TO BE THE PRIMARY RISK
DRIVER IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN. BUT
ON OUR DIESEL EMISSIONS WILL
DROP BY THE DIVISIONAL 7080% BY
TWENTY TWENTY THREE DUE TO
CARBURETION. THE FALCONS AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT.
HAS MORE THAN EFFECTIVELY
REDUCED. FEATURED BUDGETED OVER
SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
OR EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN
COMMUNITIES WHICH REQUIRED THE
DISTRICT TO FORMULATE DURING
MANY. WHO DIRECTLY WORK WITH
STAFF TO PRIORITIZE AREAS FOR
REDUCTION. THIRTY SECONDS
YOU'VE EARNED ALREADY TODAY. WE
DO NOT BELIEVE THE THREE FORTY
TWO IF NECESSARY AND DOES NOT
ACKNOWLEDGE THE INCREDIBLE WORK
THAT'S ALREADY BEEN DONE BY THE
AGENCY BOARD MEMBERS OVER THE
YEARS. THE CURRENT MAKE UP OF
THE BOARD SHOULD REMAIN WITH A
LOCAL ELECTED LEADERS NOT WITH
A POINTY ONLY HELD ACCOUNTABLE
BY THE A POINTERS. WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB THREE FORTY TWO THANK
YOU. THIS WILL COME THANK YOU
SO MUCH VERY GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY ALONG WITH
AROUND HER ERA THAT WE ARE NOW
LAYS IN GERMAN GONNA LOOK TO
THOSE WHO ARE IN THE CHAMBERS.
TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY
WE'RE ASKING FOLKS WHO ARE
CURRENTLY IN THE SENATE
CHAMBERS DO YOU TO PROVIDE
THEIR FIRST AND LAST NAME ALONG
WITH THEIR POSITION ON THE BILL
AND OF COURSE. THE ORGANIZATION
THAT THEY REPRESENT LET'S GO
TO- THE FIRST INDIVIDUALS IN
THE CHAMBERS PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING SENATOR. MEMBERS
OF THE SENATE GOVERNMENT AND
FINANCE ERIN LEHANE ON BEHALF
OF THE HALF A MILLION MEMBERS
OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL IN
STRONG OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL.
UNTIL A VOICE FOR WORKING
FAMILIES IS THAT IT THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH THAT'S GO TO
THE NEXT INDIVIDUAL WHO IS HERE
TO SPEAK. IN OPPOSITION OF SP
THREE FOUR TWO GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN. WITH
NORTH STATE BUILDS THE LARGEST
COALITION OF UNIONIZED
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS. IN
CALIFORNIA'S NORTHERN COUNTIES
STANDING IN SOLIDARITY WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES AND
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU SO
MUCH LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT IN
PERSON THAT WITNESS HERE TODAY
GOOD AFTER I GUESS I KEEP
SAYING GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD
MORNING. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
KEITH DONE HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE DISTRICT COUNCIL AND
WORKERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN THE VICINITY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BUILDING TRADES
IN OPPOSITION OF SB THREE.
FORTY TWO THANK YOU GOOD TO SEE
YOU DONE THANK YOU. SO MUCH
THAT'S GO TO OUR NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBER MIKE. ON BEHALF OF THE
INTERNET UNION OF PAINTERS AND
ALLIED. WE STAND WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES AND OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER WEST COULD YOU SEE SIR
LET'S DO A FINAL CALL FINAL
CALL. GOOD AFTERNOON THE
MORNING GERMAN ACQUIRE KYLIE
WALKING CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATES PIPE
TRADE COUNCIL CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS AND WESTERN STATES
COUNCIL. OF SHEET METAL WORKERS
AND OPPOSITION TO SB THREE FOUR
TWO THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR TALKING VERY
GRATEFUL THIS IS GOING TO BE A
FINAL CALL FOR ANYONE. WHO IS
HERE IN THE CHAMBERS TO BE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. OF SP.
THREE FOUR TWO PLEASE STAND AND
PROCEED TO THE MICROPHONE. ALL
RIGHT HEARING IN SCENE NOW AND
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE GOING TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE WE'RE LOOKING
FOR ANYONE WHO IS IN
OPPOSITION. OF SP THREE FOUR
TWO POLICE STANDING COME TO THE
MICROPHONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
HERE IN CHINO ONE LAYS IN
GERMAN WE'RE NOT GONNA BE GOING
TOWARD TELECONFERENCE LINE
WE'RE GONNA ASK THE MODERATOR
TO PLEASE QUEUE UP ALL
INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE FOUR
TWO. WE WANT TO REMIND ALL
CALLERS TO PLEASE PROCEED WITH
YOUR FIRST AND LAST NAME THE
ORGANIZATION THEY REPRESENT. IN
THE POSITION ON THE BILL WE'RE
CURRENTLY IN OPPOSITION
OPPOSITION TO SB THREE FOUR
TWO. MR MODERATOR LET'S Q.
THOSE FOLKSUP WE'RE PREPARED
TO SPEAK HEARING COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU TO STATE YOUR
POSITION ON THAT BILL YOU MAY
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. WE'LL GO
FIRST. TO LINE ME. NINE SEVEN
NINE. LINE SEVENTY NINE YEAR IN
COMMITTEE PLEASE PROCEED. LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
TWO SIXTY THREE. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CHRISTINE THOMAS ON BEHALF OF
THE INTERNATONAL BROTHERHOOD
OF BOILERMAKERS WE STAND IN
SOLIDARITY WITH BUILDING TRADES
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU SO MUCH
YOUR PHONE CALL LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER. TWO SEVENTY SIX.
NINE TWO SEVENTY SIX YOU ARE IN
COMMITTEE. BACKYARD REALISTIC
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS PROPERTIES
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING THE
BUILDING OWNERS AND MANAGERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA THE
INTERNATIONAL COUNCIL OF
SHOPPING CENTERS AND NAPA
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH MATTHEW
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
MISTER MOTOR. ONE FIFTY TWO.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
PATRICIA BROWN I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES AREA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
REPRESENTING OVER FOURTEEN
HUNDRED MEMBERS IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE DEATH. YOUR
PHONE CALL HERE TODAY LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE
SIXTY SIX. GOOD MORNING SENATOR
MCGUIRE MEMBERS RON MILLER
EXECUTIVE SECRETARY OF THE LA
ORANGE COUNTY BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES IN
REPRESENTATION OF A HUNDRED
FORTY THOUSAND SKILLED AND
TRAINED MEN AND WOMEN IN LA IN
ORANGE COUNTY MANY THOUSANDS
THAT LIVE IN AND WORK AND
ENVIRO ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU AGAIN IN
OPPOSITION WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES THANK YOU SO
MUCH TRYING FOR YOUR PHONE CALL
TODAY THAT'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. TWO EIGHTY TWO EIGHT
ZERO. THE MORNING CARE MEMBER
STEPHANIE MANUEL ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE CALL
STEPHANIE NAH THAT'S GOT OUR
NEXT LINE IS A MODERATOR. ONE
SIXTY NINE. NINE ONE SIX NINE
YOUR NOW IN COMMITTEE PLEASE
PROCEED. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE. SEVENTY SEVEN ZERO. RIGHT
AT THE END RESULTS WITH THE
SMART SHEET METAL LOCAL ONE
ZERO FIVE SEVEN WITH A
DELIBERATE OPPOSITION THANK YOU
SO MUCH YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT LINE IS A
MODERATOR. ONE FORTY SEVEN. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SAYING TO US
NOT BEING UP TO THE TEAMSTERS
AND UTILITY WORKERSUNION OF
AMERICA OPPOSITION THANK YOU SO
MUCH CHANGE. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
TWO SEVEN ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ROB STOKER
REPRESENTING SHEET METAL
WORKERS LOCAL ONE OH FOUR AND
WE'RE JOINING THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN THEIR
OPPOSITION TO SB THREE FOUR TWO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. SHOULD
THE PHONE CALL LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CAR. TWO THIRTEEN TWO ONE
THREE. A LINE TWO ONE THREE YOU
ARE IN COMMITTEE PLEASE PROCEED.
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT LINE
MISTER MODERATOR. ONE NINETY
FIVE. MY NAME IS. COULD NOT BE
HAPPENING. RAMMER AND WE'RE NOT
THAT REPORTS YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER. ONE SIXTY
TWO. ALL SIXTY TWO YES YOU ARE
IN COMMITTEE. I CALLING TO SAY
NO TO SB TWO SEVEN ONE THANK
YOU SO MUCH THE NEXT CALLER
PLEASE I WANT TO REMIND FOLKS
AND AS WE TALKED ABOUT THE
BEGINNING OF THIS HEARING- SP
TWO SEVENTY ONE WILL NOT BE
HEARD TODAY I DO APPRECIATE
THAT- THE PHONE CALL WE'RE NOW
GOING TO BE GOING TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. TWO EIGHTY ONE. SHARE
NUMBERS JOHN WALLIN TIME
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH JOHN LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE THIRTY FIVE.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
SANDERS THIS IS ZACHARY LEARY
ON BEHALF OF THE WESTERN STATES
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION WERE
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO SP THREE
FORTY TWO THANK YOU ZACHARY.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE TWENTY
SIX. GOOD MORNING- COMMITTEE
AND- SHARE MY NAME IS NICK
HARVEY WITH UNITED ASSOCIATION
LOCAL ONE FOURTEEN PLUMBERS AND
PIPEFITTERS SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY I AM CALLING IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SB THREE FORTY
TWO THANK YOU FOR YOUR PHONE
CALL NEXT CALLER PLEASE VISIT
MODERATOR. THREE ZERO SIX. YES
THIS IS CATHERINE MCBRIDE AND
I'M IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO.
THE F. B. REPORTER THANK YOU SO
MUCH KATHY NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE NINETY NINE ZERO. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN MY NAME IS
JOHN SPAULDING I REPRESENT THE
KERN COUNTY BUILDING TRADES
COUNCIL WE ALSO REPRESENT MANY
OF OUR AFFILIATES IN THE LA
BASED AND WE STAND WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION TO THE SP THREE
FORTY TWO THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY
THAT'S GO TO OUR NEXT LINE
PLEASE MR MODERATOR. THREE
FOURTEEN. YES MY NAME IS NICOLE
GARCIA WITH POLLINATORS LOCAL
NINETY TWO AND WE STRONGLY
RECALLS. HELLO AT B. THREE
FORTY TWO THANK YOU SO MUCH
YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY THAT'S
GOOD FOR OUR NEXT CALLER. NINE
THREE SIXTEEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
ERIN GARDNER AND ON BEHALF OF
FUTURE FOR WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
SB THREE FOUR TWO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR OPINION HERE TODAY WERE
GRATEFUL WE'VE ABOUT FIVE
MINUTES LEFT IN OUR TWENTY
MINUTES IN OPPOSITION FIVE
MINUTES LEFT WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
GOING TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
ONE EIGHTY SIX GOOD MORNING DAN
OSMAN WILMINGTON CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND WE ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO SB THREE FORTY TWO
THANK YOU DAN NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. TWO EIGHTY TWO. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS CHRIS KAHN
REPRESENTING THE BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL
REPORTING THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR CALLING CHRIS THAT'S GOT
OUR NEXT CALLER. EIGHTY SIX
EIGHTY SIX. HI HUGH O'CONNOR
DERRICK COUNTY AND I OPPOSE SB.
THREE FORTY TWO THANK YOU SO
MUCH TO THAT'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. TWO TWENTY FOUR. AND A
LOT OF YEARS FROM THE
RESTITUTION AND INDUSTRY AND
COMMERCE AND WE'RE CALLING IN
OPPOSITION TO SB THREE QUARTERS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL TODAY NEXT CALLER
MISTER MODERATOR. SEVENTY SIX.
I REPRESENTED WITHIN IMAGES
LOCAL SIX HUNDRED IN LOS
ANGELES HIS STRONG OPPOSITION
TO SP THREE FORTY TWO. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY
NEXT CALLER. TWO SEVENTY EIGHT.
HI THIS IS LOUIS PORTILLO I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE BEAUMONT
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE THE BIG
BEAR CHAMBER OF COMMERCE JOE
ABOUT EUROPE COMMERCE CORONA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE BUT
GENICHIRO COMMERCE THE GREATER
CONTROL ABOUT YOUR PROGRAMMERS
GREATER HIGH DESERT CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE THE GREAT HONOR OF
BUSINESS COUNCIL THE END OF THE
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE TALENT
EVERY CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
INTEMPERATE MOMENT PARTNERSHIP
MEDICALLY THAT WHICHEVER COMES
FIRST WHAT ABOUT YOUR COMMENTS
MARIA WILL DEPART INTO COMMERCE
THERE IS THAT WHAT YOU WERE
PROMISED. THE MOMENT YOU WERE
PROMISED RANCHER FROM OTHER
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE RESIDENCY
REQUIREMENTS TO MAKE ABOUT SHE
RECOVERS AND THE UPPER CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE. IN OPPOSITION TO
SB THREE FORTY TWO. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. IT DESERVES A- MEDAL
FOR THE QUICK- NUMBER IF YOU
WERE CALLING SAYING SO MUCH SIR
AND ALL SINCE WERE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR YOU INTO THANK YOU
REPRESENTING WE'RE NOT GONNA GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER. NINE EIGHTY
SEVEN. GOOD MORNING NOT BOB
TAYLOR WITH THE PLUMBERS
PIPEFITTERS LOCAL FOUR FOR
SEVEN IN SACRAMENTO AND I STAND
WITH THE BUILDING STATE
BUILDING TRADES- IN OPPOSITION
OF SB THREE FORTY TWO. YOUR
PHONE CALL TODAY LET'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER. TWO FORTY SIX.
NINE TWO FOUR SIX HEARING
COMMITTEE. ALL RIGHT IT'S
MODERATOR THAT'S A MOVE TO OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE ZERO
FOUR ONE OH FOUR. MORNING TOM
LEVINSON VEHICLE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
PROUDLY REPRESENTING THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND YOU NEED
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS STANDING
IN SOLIDARITY WITH STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION.
TO THREE FORTY TWO THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
ONE ELEVEN. A GOOD MORNING TONY
TO STEAL CARPENTERS LOCAL SEVEN
OH ONE COVERING FRESNO MADERA
TULARE AND KINGS COUNTY-
STANDING BUT WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SB THREE FORTY
TWO THANK YOU THANKS SO MUCH
FOR HANGING WITH US AND YOUR
PATIENCE AND THAT'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER. TWO THIRTY SEVEN.
HELLO ABOUT THAT ORDER MY NAME
IS MITCHELL BATTLE I REPRESENT
THE IRON WORKERS LOCAL ONE
EIGHTEEN WE STAND WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADED IN
OPPOSITION AT B. THREE FORTY
TWO THANK YOU SO MUCH HAVE A
GOOD ONE WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PHONE CALL LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. NINE EIGHTY NINE. HI MY
NAME'S ADAM GIBSON WITH
OPERATING ENGINEERS LOCAL THREE
I'M JOINING THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES THE NURSES AND STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE SP THREE FOUR
TWO. EIGHT THAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE
TWO SIX ONE. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
DIANA CORONADO VICE PRESIDENT
OF THE BUILDING INDUSTRY
SENSATION MARKANDE OR INTERACT
WE ARE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE YEAH
THE THREE FORTY PM THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PHONE CALL
TODAY LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. NINE ONE FORTY NINE. HI
THIS IS NORMA LOPEZ WITH
TEACHERS- NOT LOCAL NINE FIFTY
TO ORANGE COUNTY IN THE CITY
STRONGLY OPPOSING SENATE BILL
THREE FORTY TWO NOTHING AGAINST
MY SISTER- CONTROLLERS- THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WHO ARE
CURRENTLY ON HOLD WE HAVE NINE
INDIVIDUALS LEFT WE HAVE ONE
MINUTE LEFT IN TESTIMONY WE'RE
GONNA WORK TO GET THROUGH THOSE
NINE INDIVIDUAL SO WE'RE GONNA
DO A LIGHTNING ROUND WE'RE
CURRENTLY IN OPPOSITION TO
THREE FOUR TWO. FIRST AND LAST
NAME PLEASE ORGANIZATION. IN
YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL
CURRENTLY IN OPPOSITION LET'S
DO OUR FINAL NINE MR MODERATOR
NEXT CALLER. LINE. SIXTY NINE
SIX ZERO HEARING COMMITTEE
PLEASE PROCEED. HI MY NAME IS
FRANCISCO ROME WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS LOCAL
ELEVEN- I STAND IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL A CALL DURING THE
CALL THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINETY FOUR.
ANDREW DAVEY LOCAL FOUR FOUR
SEVEN FORMER SPIDER SACRAMENTO.
LOWS S. B. THREE FORTY TWO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR CALLING
IN TODAY FOR YOUR PATIENCE
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. SEVENTY NINE. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN SENATORS- THIS
IS ED EVANS WITH CARPENTERS
LOCAL TWO SEVENTEEN AND WE
STAND INS WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL THREE
FORTY TWO THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH THIS IS OUR FOURTH OF
NINE I THAT'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE SIXTY FIVE.
NINE SIX FALLING FROM
CARPENTERS LOCAL. GO AHEAD SIR.
IT DIDN'T GET A CALL FROM
CARPENTERS LOCAL ONE TO KEEP
YOU REPRESENTING CONTRACT
DOWNEY WE ARE THROWING UP AND
USING THE FIFTY THREE FORTY TWO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL SORRY ABOUT
INTERRUPTING THEIR LET'S GO TO
ITEM NUMBER FOR- COLOR. AS NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. TWO SIXTY SIX.
HELLO GOOD DAY A GOOD AFTERNOON
CALLER I YOU ARE NOW IN
COMMITTEE PLEASE PROCEED. HI MY
NAME IS VICKY FOR THAT MUCH
MORE THAN A WESTERN IN THE
BALATA. JESTER CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE FOUR TWO
THANK YOU THANK SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PHONE CALL TO WE PREACH
THAT A- NEXT CALL OF. LIME
THREE IF THERE FOUR THREE OKAY.
THIS GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
ERIN PACKED WITH THE BUILDING
AND AS GREATER LAW AND THEY IN
OPPOSITION SB FOUR TWO THANK
YOU SOME NEXT CALL PLEASE.
THREE TWENTY. COLOR THREE TWO
ZERO YOU ARE CURRENTLY IN
COMMITTEE PLEASE PROCEED. ALL
RIGHT LASING GENERATE YOUR
FINAL TWO CALLERS IN OPPOSITION
OF THREE FOUR TWO MR MODERATOR.
NINE THREE TWENTY ONE. JERRY
MCGUIRE MEMBERS DON MADDIE ON
BEHALF OF A CLASS ONE RAILROADS
BNSF RAILWAY AND UNION PACIFIC
RAILROAD IN OPPOSITION TO THE
SP THREE FORTY TWO THANK YOU SO
MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR PHONE CALL
THIS IS GONNA BE OUR FINAL
CALLER IN OPPOSITION OF THREE
FOUR TWO MR MODERATOR. THREE
NINE THREE ZERO SIX THREE ONE
SIX. CATHERINE BRAGG PLASTER
COUNTY STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
REPORT S. B. THREE FOUR TWO ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH AMAZING
JAN COMMITTEE WE HAVE GONE AND
DID OVER OUR TWENTY MINUTES
THERE FOR THOSE WHO ARE OPPOSED
TO TWENTY BE COMPLETELY
TRANSPARENT THOSE ARE GONNA BE
OUR FINAL NINE CALLERS- IN
OPPOSITION WE HAD ONE IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE FOUR TWO.
SO WE'VE GOT TO BE ABLE TO
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GONNA START WITH
SENATOR WIENER CENTER WE ARE
THE FLOORS YOUR. I THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND I. WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR. FOR BRINGING. THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION FORWARD-
TO MAKE SURE THAT- OUR
FRONTLINE COMMUNITIES WHO ARE
MOST IMPACTED. BY AIR POLLUTION
AND BY THE CLIMATE CRISIS- HAVE
A GUARANTEED. A SEAT AT THE
TABLE- TABLE FROM WHICH THEY
HAVE BEEN HISTORICALLY
EXCLUDED. OFF FOREVER. THESE
ARE COMMUNITIES- THAT- FOR SO
MUCH OF. HISTORY DECISIONS HAVE
BEEN MADE. ABOUT THEM. I AM NOT
BY THEM. OR NOT WITH THEIR
PARTICIPATION. AND INPUT- AND
WE KNOW WHAT THE IMPACTS ARE.
WHEN OUR FRONT LINE WORKING
CLASS COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IN
PARTICULAR- ARE NOT AT THE
TABLE AND DON'T HAVE THE VOICE
THAT THEY NEED. IT IS NOT A
COINCIDENCE WHEN WE LOOK AT
WHERE FREEWAYS ARE BUILT WITH A
MASSIVE AMOUNT OF POLLUTION
THAT COMES OFF THOSE FREEWAYS
IT'S NOT A COINCIDENCE. THAT
THOSE FREEWAYS THAT
OVERWHELMINGLY WERE BUILT
THROUGH LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
BECAUSE THAT WAS CONSIDERED TO
BE THE POLITICALLY EASIEST
QUOTE ON QUOTE- APPROACH.
BECAUSE THESE ARE COMMUNITIES
THAT WERE PERCEIVED AS NOT
BEING ABLE TO STAND UP. FOR
THEMSELVES AND SO THEY GOT
ROLLED HI AND THE AND THE
IMPACTS THE HEALTH IMPACTS WERE
HUGE IN TERMS OF HEALTH AND THE
HEALTH OF CHILDREN AND SO
FORTH. HIGHWAYS TO GO RIGHT BY
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES SCHOOLS
AND PLAYGROUNDS AND HOMES. WHEN
WE LOOK AT WHERE. THE DIFFERENT
KINDS OF PLANTS ARE CITED- DI
PRODUCE POLLUTION REFINERIES-
OTHER KINDS OF POLLUTION
PRODUCING. PLANTS IT'S
OVERWHELMINGLY IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR IN HIS FRONTLINE
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE THAT WAS
CONSIDERED THE POLITICALLY
EASIEST. WHERE SITE THEN WE
LOOK AT WHERE OIL DRILLING
HAPPENS. WITH VERY FEW
EXCEPTIONS IT'S NOT HAPPENING
AND WEALTHY WHITE COMMUNITIES
IT'S HAPPENING NEAR IN LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR EVEN RIGHT
NEXT TO WHERE KIDS GO TO SCHOOL
OR PLAY ON THE PLAYGROUND OR
WHERE THEY LIVE. THAT'S A IT'S
A VERY UGLY HISTORY IN THIS
COUNTRY. IT IS A FORM OF
STRUCTURAL RACISM. AND IT HAS
TO STOP. AND THESE FRONTLINE
COMMUNITIES I BET THEY'RE NOT
TAKING IT ANYMORE AND THEY
SHOULDN'T TAKE IT ANYMORE AND
THE ORGANIZING THAT WE'VE SEEN
IN OUR EVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES IS REALLY DEEPLY
INSPIRING- AND THEY HIRED THESE
ARE FROM MY COMMUNITIES ARE NOT
COMING TO US AND SAYING WE WON.
NOT JUST THE VOICE WE WANT A
FORMAL SEAT AT THE TABLE WE
DON'T WANT TO HAVE. TO RELY ON
WHETHER SOMEONE HOP TO SOME
FROM THE MOST IMPACT IN WE WANT
TO GUARANTEE AND IT'S A IT'S A
GUARANTEE THAT TO OF AND WHAT
IT'S NOT EVEN TO OF THE EGGS
THIRD. IT'S EXPANDING IT FROM
THIRD THE IN THOSE TWO ADDED
SEATS ARE FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITIES IT'S A VERY
REASONABLE- I ASK. AND I REALLY
RESPECT. THEIR PERSPECTIVE IN
THE OPPOSITION- OF THE BUILDING
TRADES I DON'T THINK THAT THIS
BILL IS INCONSISTENT. WITH
SUPPORTING WORKERS- BUT IT IT
IT IS CONSISTENT WITH OUR VALUE
OF ENGAGING V. MOST IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES THE COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE BEING MOST. BADLY
HARMED WHO ARE GETTING SICK
BECAUSE OF THIS POLLUTION SO
THIS IS A GOOD BILL I SUPPORT
AND I MOVED THE BALL. THANK YOU
SO MUCH CENTER WINNER LAYS IN
GENERAL COMMITTEE WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR MOTION ON
THE FLOOR ON SP THREE FOUR TWO.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS. COMMENTS CONCERNS
FROM ANY AT THIS TIME. KAREN C.
NINE S. IN ARKANSAS SAID
ACTIVATED SAY THAT LOOKED AT
SOONER GONZALEZ HAS BEEN
ENGAGED ON THIS ISSUE WITH ALL
SIDES. BOTH THOSE WHO SUPPORT
BUT IN PARTICULAR THOSE WHO
OPPOSE THAT COMING IN COMMITTEE
AND MADAM SENATOR I KNOW THAT
IT'S GOING TO BE A AN ITEM.
THAT YOU TAKE PRIDE IN COMING
OUT OF COMMITTEE IF THIS BILL
WERE TO PASS TODAY- AT A
COMMITTEE TO CONTINUE TO ENGAGE
ALL SIDES- AND THAT'S BEEN A
STRENGTH OF CENTER GONZALEZ
WHEN HER TIME ON THE CITY
COUNCIL. AND IN BUSINESS AND
NOW HERE IN THE SENATE I CENTER
IN DALLAS WE'RE GONNA TURN THE
FLOOR OVER TO YOU FOR CLOTHES
YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAN I
WANNA THANK MY COLLEAGUE- FROM
SAN FRANCISCO FOR SAYING SO
ELOQUENTLY WHAT I FEEL- THIS
ISN'T JUST ANOTHER BILL FOR ME-
THIS IS A DEEP PASSION OF MINE
TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE CLEANING
UP OUR MOST BURDENED
COMMUNITIES AND THAT WE
ACTUALLY DO HAVE A SEAT AT THE
TABLE- I WANT TO ALSO THANK MR.
CHAVEZ WHO IS MY CONSTITUENT MS
WE'RE WHO'VE TESTIFIED BUT I'M
VERY PROUD DAUGHTER OF A
TEAMSTER TRUCK DRIVER VERY
PROUD DAUGHTER. FOR THIRTY
YEARS MY FATHER WOKE UP VERY
EARLY IN THE MORNING TO PUT%
FOOD ON THE TABLE FOR ME VERY
PROUD I UNDERSTAND WHAT WORKING
FAMILIES GO THROUGH. AND I
REALLY REALLY RESPECT- THE
TRADES AS WELL OF ALL THE
OPPOSITION THAT CALLED IN AND
THE SUPPORTERS THAT HAVE CALLED
IN BUT WE ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO
HAVE A SEAT AT THE TABLE AND IN
SENATE DISTRICT THIRTY THREE WE
HAVE DEALT WITH EXIDE. PORT OF
LONG BEACH DIESEL PARTICULATE
MATTER FROM MOBILE SOURCES
REFINERIES THE LIST GOES ON IN
THESE COMMUNITIES DO NOT HAVE A
SEAT AT THE TABLE THAT'S ALL
WE'RE ASKING. TWO SEATS THERE
IS A PRECEDENT OF COURSE SAN
DIEGO ADDED TWO SEATS. SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY ADDED TO THE
POLLUTION CONTROL BOARD
ADDITIONAL THREE FOUR SEATS
WHICH INCLUDED- AEGEE. MEMBERS
AND I WOULD JUST LIKE OUR- OUR
STAKEHOLDERS TO KNOW THAT WE
HAVE TO SHARE POWER IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE NEW PERSPECTIVES WE
ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO WE CANNOT
IGNORE THE DEEPEST- IMPACTS OF
BAD AIR QUALITY. I LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING THE MEANINGFUL.
MEANINGFUL DISCUSSIONS THAT
WILL HAVE BUT WE ABSOLUTELY
NEED THIS AT MOVE FORWARD AND I.
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND
I. AS B. THREE FORTY TWO. THANK
YOU SO MUCH SOONER BECAUSE
AGAIN WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR BY SENATOR WIENER. WE'RE
NOT GOING TO GO TO OUR FORMAL
VOTE. MR CANAL IS GOING TO READ
THE FORMAL MOTION. IN CALL THE
ROLL MR NOW. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE SENATE FOR SENATOR
MCGUIRE HI REQUIRE. A SENATOR
NIELSEN. NIELSEN KNOWS SENATOR
DURAZO. SENATOR HERTZBERG.
SENATOR WIENER WIENER HI TWO TO
ONE. THE HE CURRENTLY ENJOYS A
TWO ONE VOTE LAYS IN GERMAN TO
ONE VOTE WE'RE GONNA KEEP THAT
BILL ON CALL- AND ALLOW BOTH AT
CENTER DRIVES- IN THE MAJORITY
LEADER TO POTENTIALLY ADD ON TO
THE BILL TODAY'S IN JENIN WERE
NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
THREE S. B. THIRTEEN EYES BY
SENATOR DODD THIS IS A DISTRICT
BILL FOCUSING ON NAPA COUNTY
THAT SENATOR DIED- I'VE BEEN
MADE AWARE THAT WE HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON THE BILL.
SO WHAT WE'RE GONNAASK SINGER
DIED TO DO IS SET THANK YOU SO
MUCH MR ERGEANT WE'RE GOING TO
ASK FOR A TRUNCATED VERSION
YOUR STATEMENT WE WELCOME YOU
SINNER DIED TWO COMMITTEE THE
FLOOR IS YOURS SIR IN YOUR LEAD
WITNESS THAT SUPERVISOR DYLAN
IS CURRENTLY ON THE LINE. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS I
AM GOING TO BE VERY BRIEF AND
LET SUPERVISOR DEAL AND- HAVE
HER REMARKS- IT'S B. THIRTEEN
BOOKS IN THE SUNSET OF A PILOT
PROGRAM IN NAPA AND SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTIES ALLOWING
LOCAL AGENCY FORMATION
FORMATION COMMISSION SLAPPED
GOES TO AUTHORIZE THE CITY
INDOOR DISTRICT SERVICES
OUTSIDE URBAN BOUNDARIES-
THERE'S A COUPLE OF OTHER-
TWISTS AND TURNS TO THIS BUT
I'VE WORKED OUT THEN WE ACCEPT
THE TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS OF
THE- COMMITTEE AT IT FROM THE-
COMMITTEE STAFF AND SHARE IT
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER SENATOR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE GOING TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE WE DO HAVE
ONE LEAD SUPPORT WITNESS THAT
SHE REPRESENTS- UPPER NAPA
VALLEY ON THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS HER NAME IS DIANE
DILLON SUPERVISOR DYLAN THE
FLOOR IS YOURS AND WE WELCOME
YOU TO COMMITTEE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT PROVIDE
TODAY. ON BEHALF OF THE NAPA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN AND WOULD LIKE TO
THANK SENATOR DODD FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE. NAPA
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THAT. FIRST
WE HAVE LONGSTANDING LAND USE
ORDINANCES TO HELP PREVENT
URBAN SPRAWL AND PROTECT
NATURAL RESOURCES WHILE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO INCREASE
THE BUILDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. IN NINETEEN SIXTY
EIGHT FIFTY THREE YEARS AGO WE
ESTABLISHED THE FIRST
AGRICULTURAL PRESERVE ZONING
DESIGNATION IN THE UNITED
STATES. AND SINCE THEN OUR LAND
USE PRINCIPLES ARE AGRICULTURAL
LAND SHOULD BE PROTECTED AND
DEVELOPMENT SHOULD OCCUR IN
URBAN AREA. AND THE PILOT
PROGRAM WOULD NOT DISTURB THOSE
GUIDING TENET. OUR SECOND
CENTRAL REASON FOR SUPPORTING
SB THIRTEEN RELATE TO HOW IT
CAN HELP PROPERTY OWNERS IN THE
AGRICULTURAL PLAN TO CREATE
MORE AGRICULTURAL EMPLOYEE
HOUSING. PURSUANT TO HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE SECTION ONE SEVEN
OH TWO ONE POINT EIGHT. THE
COST OF BUILDING SUCH HOUSING
INCLUDE ADEQUATE WELL WATER AND
SEPTIC SYSTEM IF ONE BUILDING
ON AGRICULTURAL LAND. REDUCING
THOSE COSTS BY MAKING THE
POSSIBILITY OF ACCEPTING PUBLIC
WATER AND SEWER WILL ADD AN
INCENTIVE. FOR AGRICULTURAL
PROPERTY OWNERS TO SEEK TO
BUILD SUCH HOUSING WITHOUT
REQUIRING TO AG LAND BE TAKEN
INTO. INFLUENCER ANNEX WHICH
ALMOST ALWAYS LEADS
URBANIZATION OF SUCH PLANS AND
DEFEAT THE PURPOSE OF THE
AGRICULTURAL ZONING. FOR THESE
REASONS NAPA COUNTY PROUD TO
SUPPORT SB THIRTEEN AND THANK
SENATOR DODD FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
THANK YOU SO MUCH READING.
THANK YOU SO MUCH READING
SUPERVISOR WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR
YOU TAKING THE TIME IN YOUR
BUSY SCHEDULE TO BE ABLE TO BE
WITH US IT'S ALWAYS GOOD TO
HEAR YOUR VOICE AND WE'RE SORRY
WE CAN'T SEE IN PERSON. LAYS IN
GERMAN WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE-
THAT WE ONLY HAVE ONE LEAD
WITNESS ON THIS BILL SO WE'RE
GOING TO LOOK TO THOSE WHO MAY
BE IN SUPPORT HERE. IN THE
SENATE CHAMBERS WE WELCOME YOU
IF YOU COULD PLEASE STEP OVER.
THE MICROPHONE TO MY LEFT AT
THIS TIME. HERE IN C. KNOWING
FOR WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
MOVING. OUR OVERFLOW ROOM
THAT'S IN RE ONE. LET'S SEE IF
ANYONE IS THERE WHO'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN
THERE'S NO LOVE- DEAR SPEAK IN
SUPPORT WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO
TO OUR TELE. CONFERENCE LINE IF
YOU'D LIKE YOU TO JOIN US ON
THE TELECONFERENCE ON TODAY.
PLEASE DIAL EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO
MR MODERATOR WE ARE NOW GOING
TO ASK YOU TO PLEASE QUEUE UP.
ALL THOSE IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN NOW. THANK YOU TO
STATE YOUR POSITION OF SUPPORT
FOR S. B. THIRTEEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE.
AGAIN THAT'S A ONE FOLLOWED BY
THEIR- PLEASE. BUT IT'S GOING
TO WAIT FOR THOSE CALLERS TO BE
QUEUED UP AND THEN WE'RE GOING
TO TURN IT OVER TO THE
MODERATOR. FOR THE ANNOUNCEMENT
MR MODERATOR. THANK YOU WE DO
HAVE SEVERAL IN Q. ARE YOU
READY FOR THE FIRST. CALLER YES
PLEASE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
SMARTER. YOU'RE WELCOME LINE.
THREE ZERO SEVEN THREE OH
SEVEN. THANK YOU- CHERRY
MEMBERS ERIC CALLED
COUNCILMEMBER CITY OF ST
CLEANER IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN THANK YOU SO MUCH
COUNCILMAN PC OR PHONE CALL
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
NINE THREE OH THREE. HI MARK
PARTRIDGE AND THE DUTY MANAGER
OF THE CITY OF SAINT HELENA AND
THE VIDEO FROM SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN THANK YOU MISS SO MUCH
AS A CITY MANAGER APPRECIATE
THE PHONE CALL TODAY THAT'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER. BUT. NINE
THREE THREE THREE. LINE THREE
THREE PLEASE PROCEED. RIGHT
KOMODO I SUPPORT SB SIX SIX
EIGHT. ALL RIGHT. SIX SIX EIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH THAT IS GOING
TO BE COMING UP HERE IN JUST A
BIT BUT VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT-
TESTIMONY WE'RE GONNA LOG THAT
NOW LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
IN SUPPORT. OF SB THIRTEEN.
NINE THREE TWENTY EIGHT. NINE
THREE TWENTY EIGHT YOU'RE IN
COMMITTEE PLEASE PROCEED. NOT
ALL RIGHT LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. AT TIMES THE
TEACHER TURNOVER THAN LINES IN
Q. ALL RIGHT MISTER MODERATOR
WILL BE BACK WITH YOU HERE IN
JUST A FEW MOMENTS LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN WE DO NOT HAVE A LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS A LOT DO
WITH THE COMMITTEE SO WE ARE
NOT GONNA BE GOING TO ELITE
OPPOSITIONWHEN IT'S ON A
TELECONFERENCE LINE. WE ARE
GOING TO LOOK TO THOSE WHO ARE
HERE IN THE CHAMBERS WITH US
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO HEAR
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
THIRTEEN PLEASE STEP TO THE
MICROPHONE TO MY LEFT AT THIS
TIME. SEE NO ONE RISE WE'RE NOT
GONNA BE GOING TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE ROOM ONE TWELVE TO SEE
IF ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO BE A
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. OF SB
THIRTEEN PLEASE RISE AND COME
TO THE MICROPHONE. ALL RIGHT
HERE IN C. NOTARIZED TO COME TO
THE MICROPHONE SP THIRTEEN
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO. OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE MR
MODERATOR IF YOU CAN PLEASE
QUEUE UP PLEASE QUEUE UP. ALL
THOSE IN OPPOSITION OF SB
THIRTEEN NOW. THANK YOU TO
STATE YOUR POSITION OF
OPPOSITION TO SB THIRTEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AGAIN USING YOUR
TELEPHONE THIS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THERE ARE NO
LINES IN Q. ALL RIGHT LAYS IN
GERMAN WE'RE GONNA BRING IT.
BACK TO COMMITTEE AGAIN WE
BELIEVE THERE'S FIVE. SUPPORT
ON S. V. THIRTEEN THANK YOU MAY
MODERATOR. IS THEIR CORE COME.
OR A- ON AS THIRTEEN. WE HAVE A
MO BY THE WE THINK YOU SO MUCH.
AT CENTER DOT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PLEASE REACH. ASK YOUR I. ON
THIS DISTRICT BILL THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE DO HAVE A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR BY SENATOR WIENER MR NOW
CAN YOU PLEASE READ THE FORMAL
MOTION. IN CALL THE VOTE. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR SENATOR.
MCGUIRE HI REQUIRE I A SENATOR
NIELSEN. NIELSEN HI SENATOR DO
ALL. SENATOR HURTS. SENATOR
WE'VE- WINNER HI THREE ZERO
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A THREE ZERO
VOTE LATE IN GENERAL WE'RE
GONNA KEEP THAT BILL ON- HOLD
HERE IS SO THAT WE CAN ADD TO
MR MAJORITY LEADER AS WELL AS
CENTER DRIVE SO BEIJING GERMAN
ONE REMIND YOU WE HAVE MOVED
ITEM FOURTEEN THE ITEM NUMBER
THREE WE'RE GOING TO WELCOME
THAT SENATOR GROVE TO THE
PODIUM AT THIS TIME- ITEM
FOURTEEN IS NOW ITEM THREE THIS
IS S. B. SIXTEEN REALLY
GRATEFUL FOR THE WORK THAT
CENTER ROPE IS PUT INTO THIS.
CRITICAL BILL FOCUSING ON-
VIRTUAL LEARNING COSTS. MADAMS
YOU DO HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
ON THIS BILL SO WE'RE GOING TO
ASK FOR A TRUNCATED- THE
TURKISH FLOOR STATEMENT IF YOU
DON'T MIND THE FLOOR IS YOURS
ON SB SIX TEN GOOD AFTERNOON
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT JUST A FEW
MINUTES EARLY. THIS BILL IS
SIMPLE I'M NOT GOING TO GO
THROUGH THE WHOLE PROCESS IT
JUST ALLOWS PARENTS THAT HAVE
HAD TO ADJUST TO VIRTUAL.
VIRTUAL LEARNING OR DISTANCE
COSTS THAT THEY'VE HAD TO
EXPEND OUT IT ALLOWS PARENTS TO
HAVE A TAX DEDUCTION OF TWO
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED. AND FIFTY
DOLLARS PER STUDENT TO COVER
COSTS LIKE TECHNOLOGY SUPPLIES-
HIGH COST INTERNET INCREASING
INTERNET IT JUST IS A REPORT
BACK TO OUR PARENTS ALL IN%
THERE SIR AND I WILL KEEP MY
COMMENTS BRIEF EVEN THOUGH I
HAD FOUR PAGES AND I ALSO HAD-
FIVE HUNDRED PEOPLE THAT SIGNED
THE PETITION ONLINE TO SUPPORT
THIS PARTICULAR PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. BECAUSE PARENTS
ARE STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS
MEET AND SO I WILL KEEP IT
BRIEF AND I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT NO THANK YOU SO MUCH
MADAM SENATOR IN THIS IS BE
HONEST THIS IS BEEN A HELL OF A
YEAR- OVER THE PAST MANY MANY
MONTHS AND- AND HAS BEEN IN
ENHANCED EXPERIENCE FOR. MANY
FAMILIES SO APPRECIATE YOUR
FOCUS ON THIS ISSUE WITH
FAMILIES AND KIDS ALL RIGHT
THESE IN GERMAN WE HAVE TO LEAD
TO SUPPORT WITNESSES ALONG WITH
SENATOR GROWTH THAT WE'RE GOING
TO START WITH JAMIE COOKS IN
THAT JAMIE IS MORE HAS MORE
THAN A FULL TIME JOB SHE'S A
PARENT OF THREE KIDS. TWO OF
WHICH ARE VIRTUAL LEARNING AND
A RESIDENT AND TO HATCH A P.
JAMIE THE FLOOR IS YOURS YOU
HAVE THREE MINUTES AND WE'LL
GIVE YOU THIRTY SECOND. PROMPT
DURING COMMITTEE GOOD AFTERNOON.
GET OUT THERE AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND- SOUND
LIKE I DON'T NEED TO CONVINCE
THE ROBERT YES HELLO MY NAME IS
KEY BECAUSE- WHEN I'M A
CONSTITUENT OF CENTER GROVE AND
I DO LIVE IN FACT APPEAR. AND I
AM A MOTHER OF THREE TWO WHICH
HAVE BEEN VIRTUAL THING. MARCH
EIGHTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY AND IT
HAS BEEN A DIFFICULT YEAR THE
FAMILY IS. I SUPPORT SB SIX AND
BECAUSE WHAT I BELIEVE THE
BIGGEST COST INCURRED OVER THE
PAST FOURTEEN MONTHS WHERE THE
EMOTIONAL AND SOCIAL COSTS. TO
OUR CHILDREN'S MENTAL HEALTH
THIS YEAR HAS NOT BEEN FREE OF
FINANCIAL BURDEN EITHER. WE HAD
TO ADD DEVICES INCREASED
INTERNET CAPACITY ACQUIRED
THAT. BIND HEADPHONES TO GET
SUPPLEMENTAL MATERIALS JUST TO
TRY TO KEEP OUR HEADS ABOVE THE
WATER AND NOT REGRET I'M
LEARNING. I SUPPORT AT THE BIG
FAN BECAUSE IT WILL HELP THOSE
WHOSE NEEDS ARE THE GREATEST.
AS A MOM COULD VOLUNTEERED
INSIDE CLASSROOMS IN THE PAST
THERE'S A CLEAR DIVIDING LINE
BETWEEN THE KIDS WHO UNDERSTAND
THE MATERIAL. AND THOSE WHO
JUST AREN'T EVEN CLOSE. AND
BADLY BECAUSE IT HAD MADE THAT
GAP EVEN LARGER AND I THINK SIX
TEN WILL HELP THOSE WHO HAVE
FALLEN BEHIND THE LEARNING
CURVE BY PROVIDING THE PARTIAL
TAX CREDIT FOR TUTORING.
SPECIAL EDUCATION NEEDS BOOK A
FLIGHT AND OF COURSE INTERNET.
AND COMPUTER SERVICES. I WE ALL
KNOW CODE DERAIL THIRTY.
CALIBER STUDENTS WE WANT TO
BACK ONTO. WE WANT TO GIVE BACK
ON TRACK WITH EXCEL. AND ONE
MANY HAVE. HELPLESS AND HE
HOPELESS THIS YEAR- I THAT THE
IS A WAY OF PROVIDING. CAN
FAMILY WHO ARE REALLY
STRUGGLING SO I SINCERELY
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME. I THANK
YOU ALL FOR WORKING HARD FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS FAMILIES AS WE
SEEK. TO MOVE FORWARD AND GROW
STRONGER TOGETHER AWAY FROM
THESE TRYING TIMES. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. IT'S A GOOD THING
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU HOLDING AND I
KNOW YOU'VE BEEN ON HOLD FOR
QUITE SOME TIME SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH. FOR TAKING TIME TODAY TO
TESTIFY HERE TODAY. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE WE'RE NOT
GONNA BE TURNED OVER TO BEN
HOWELL MR HOWELL IS A PARENT OF
THREE KIDS. ALL OUR VIRTUAL
LEARNING- IN HE'S A RESIDENT OF
SCOTTS VALLEY. MR HOW THE FLOOR.
IS YOURS WE WELCOME YOU TO
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU SO MUCH I
APPRECIATE A GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYBODY ATTENTION MY NAME IS
BEN HALL AND I'M CONVINCED YOU
KNOW CENTRIC. SENATOR GROWTH
THAT YOU LIVE IN STOCK VALUE
WHICH IS IN SANTA CRUZ CONTY
AND I DO HAVE THREE KIDS
FIFTEEN THIRTEEN AND TEN. ALL
OF WHICH YOU HAVE BEEN VIRTUAL-
I DO WORKFROM HOME FULL TIME
AS WELL AND THAT THAT POLICE
PANDEMIC CHANGE BUT IT'S BEEN
OUR FIRST ONE AFTER THE
CHALLENGE. I DO CERTAINLY
SUPPORT SB SIX TEN. VIRTUAL
LEARNING BUT A LOT OF STRAIN ON
US AS JEANNIE MENTIONED SO VERY
WELL NOT JUST FOM THE
EMOTIONAL IMPACT BUT- YOU KNOW
FROM A PARENTAL PERSPECTIVE WE
HAD TO BE VERY PRESENT AND VERY
VIGILANT WITH LEARNING EVERY
DAY ESPECIALLY WITH OUR TEN
YEAR OLD SON. AND JUST KEEPING
THEM ON TASK AND THEN A VERY.
TIME CONSTRAINED. AREA PRESS TO
BE PUBLISHED ON. THE IMPACT HAS
BEEN AROUND FINANCIAL SO
EVERYTHING THAT THEY NEED FOR
SCHOOLING FROM PAPER PENS
CALCULATORS NOTEBOOKS. MANY OF
WHICH WERE PROVIDD TO THE
SCHOOLS IN THE PAST I THINK
THAT WE NEEDED TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE READY TO GO. AND A LARGE
EXPENSES JEANNIE OFTEN MENTION
WAS MAKING SURE THEY CAN
ACTUALLY ACCESS THE INTERNET
AND DO THE WORK WE HAD TO.
REPLACE THE LAPTOPS THAT WERE
PROVIDED BY THE SCHOOL IF THEY
WEREN'T FUNCTIONAL SO WE HAD TO
GET THREE LAPTOPS. THREE DESKS.
AND CHAIRS THREE NIGHTS AT THE
HEADPHONES. AND FIND THREE
STATIONS WITHIN THE HOUSE FOR
THEM ALL TO BE ABLE TO DO THE
WORK THAT WAS REQUIRED. AND THE
TONGUE IN CHEEK BUT- IT'S
AMAZING HOW MUCH EXTRA FOOD
THEY NEED WHEN THEY'RE AT HOME
ALL DAY AS WELL SO THERE IS AN
IMPACT. ON THE ON THE DIET AND
SOMEONE ON THAT SIDE AS WELL.
WE DID NEED TO UPGRADE OUR
ENTIRE HOME INTERNET AS I
MENTIONED I WORK FROM HOME AS
WELL SO THERE'S- T. P. PERIODS
DURING THE DAY WHEN WE HAD FOUR
PEOPLE ON STREAMING VIDEO
SYSTEMS SIMULTANEOUSLY- AND OUR
SYSTEM JUST WASN'T UP TO THE
TAX SO I NEEDED TO REPLACE OUR
ENTIRE INTERNET SYSTEM INSIDE
THE HOUSE WE ALSO HAD TO
UPGRADE- OUR PROVIDERS SO THAT
YOU'RE GETTING UNLIMITED
BANDWIDTH AND HIGHER SPEEDS TO
BE ABLE TO KEEP UP. SO ALL IN
ALL THERE'S THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT TO US LAST
YEAR WELL IN IN. WELL HIGHER
THAN THE TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS
THAT'S BEING ASKED FOR BUT IT
WOULD MAKE A SIGNIFICANT
DIFFERENCE FOR US. TO BE ABLE
TO GET THOSE DOLLARS AS PART OF
A TAX RELIEF. AND WE ALSO
NEEDED TO GET COMPUTERS AT OUR
TEN YEAR OLD. THAT WAS
STRUGGLING. WITH WITH VIRTUAL
LEARNING BEING THE FACT THE WAY
FOR HIM TO LEARN. SO WE HAD GO
OUT. OF THIS IS. AND LOOK FOR
ADDITIONAL WAYS FOR. HE CAN UP
SPEED. THANK YOU THEM ON. AND
SO IT HAS BEEN A LONG. EACH
THAT HAS IN. THAT IMPACTED THE
NUMBER OF WAYS THERE'S ALSO
BEEN SOME POSIT. TO HAVING
EVERYBODY HOME. I'M FROM A
FINANCIAL PERSPECTIVE THERE
WERE SOME. THAT OR ONYX. THE
OVERALL. THAT IMPACT. BEEN TO
OUR TIME. OUR HOUSE OUR
FINANCES OUR LIVES. IN THIS
BILL WOULD GO A LONG WAY TO
HELPING MAKE ONE PART OF THAT
THE FINANCES MUCH EASIER TO
BEAR SO I DO APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME. AND LETTING ME TESTIFIED
AND I DO ASK THAT YOU BOTH. HI
AND SUPPORT SB SIXTY. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER HOW WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
TODAY THANKS FOR HANGING WITH
US. DURING THE WAIT TIME SO WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT. BUT IN
GENERAL COMMITTEE WERE NOT
GOING TO BE LOOKING TO THOSE
WHO ARE IN PERSON WHO'D LIKE TO
BE TO SPEAK. IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIXTEEN. LOOKING TO HEAR IN THE
CHAMBERS MY LEFT HEARING SEMEN
SEE NO ONE WRITES FOR NOT GOING
TO GO TO OUR OVERFLOW ROOM.
ROOM ONE TWELVE. WE'RE GONNA
CHECK IN WITH ROOM ONE TWELVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON SIR IF YOU DON'T
MIND GIVING US YOUR FIRST AND
LAST NAME ORGANIZATION IN YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL WERE
CURRENTLY. IN SUPPORT. THE
FLOOR IS YOURS SIR. OUR KAUFMAN
HARDER. TAXPAYER SCI. INSP
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH IN
REALLY FISHY. YOU HANGING. US
IS A- HERE TODAY. THEY SING
GERMAN WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE.
CHECKING IN WITH EVERYONE FROM
ANYONE ELSE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
WHO'D LIKE TO GET TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. NO LOVE R. I. TO WE'RE
NOT GONNA BE GOING TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LIVE LINE WE'RE
GONNA CHECK IN WITH THAT OUR
MODERATOR. WE'RE GOING TO ASK-
ARE THE FOLKS WHO ARE ON HOLD.
IF YOU CAN PLEASE QUEUE THEM UP
MR MODERATOR. ON S. V. SIXTEEN
PLEASE GIVE THEM UP NOW. THANK
YOU TO SHARE YOUR SUPPORT PRESS
B. SIX TEN ME PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR PHONE AGAIN THAT'S
A ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME. IT IS WORKING FOLKS UP
WE'RE GONNA REMIND YOU IF YOU
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO TALK WITH
THE COMMITTEE TODAY WE WELCOME
YOUR PHONE CALL EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE
FIVE TWO MR MODERATOR. WE'LL GO
FIRST TO LINE ONE SIXTY TWO.
I'M CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB SIX TEN MY NAME IS ANDREA
HAD STRONG GROWTH FOR GOVERNOR
THERE WE GO WE HAVE THE FIRST
SIGN UP FOR HER MAY SAID JIM
THANK YOU SO MUCH YOU SAID
SHERMAN LET'S GO TO OUR- NEXT
CALLER. NINE EIGHTY SIX. HI I'D
LIKE TO EXPRESS MY SUPPORT FOR
SB SIX TEN AND I THINK- SENATOR
GROW FOR- SUPPORTING FAMILIES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PHONE CALL
HERE TODAY LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. O'CONNOR SORRY. ONE
SIXTEEN ONE ONE SIX. MY NAME IS
DEBORAH GOOD FROM THE KERR
COUNTY IN SUPPORT OF SIX CAN
THANK YOU THANKS DAVE
APPRECIATE THE PHONE CALL TODAY
THAT'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THREE FORTY SEVEN. MR
CHAIRMAN I'M ACTUALLY IN
OPPOSITION FOR THE REASONS
LISTED IN THE ANALYSIS IT'S ON
THE WRONG LINE ACCORDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH AS
CORBIN VERY GRATEFUL THANK YOU
FOR CALLING IN ALL OOD- THAT'S
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER. THREE
TWENTY EIGHT. THREE TWENTY
EIGHT YOU'RE IN COMMITTEE
PLEASE PROCEED. LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE MR MODERATOR.
THANK YOU LINE THREE FIFTY. YES
HELLO HI MY NAME IS MARK.
PLEASE HELLO MY NAME IS MARTHA
CARMEN AND I AM IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH YOUR PHONE
CALL AND THANK YO FOR HOLDING
WITH US HERE TODAY VERY MUCH.
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALL KILLS.
NINE THREE OH SIX. THIS IS
CAPTAIN MIKE PRIVATE PLASTER
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE SIX TEN HOLES THANK YOU
MYSTIC BRIDE PRESET YOUR PHONE
CALL HERE TODAY THAT'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER. TWENTY THREE
TWENTY. GOOD MORNING IT'S
JENNIFER KENNEDY IN LA COUNTY
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANKS JENNIFER VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. AT THIS TIME
THERE ARE NO OTHERS IN Q. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
MODERATOR WE'RE NOT GONNA LOOK
TO THOSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL WE'RE GOING TO START
HERE IN THE SENATE CHAMBERS WE
DO NOT HAVE A LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS LOG THROUGH THE
COMMITTEE WE'RE GONNA SEE IN
CHAMBERS DECEIVED AS ANYONE.
WHO WOULD LIKE TO RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO SIXTEEN PLEASE DO
SO NOW. AIN'T SEEN NO ONE RISE
RIGHT NOW GOING TO BE GOING TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE THAT'S OUR
OVERFLOW ROOM. TODAY TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN OPPOSITION OF
SB SIX TEN. TINO AND RISING
COME TO THE MICROPHONE WE'RE
NOT GOING TO GO TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE. THAT'S
RIGHT WE'RE GONNA CHECK IN WITH
OUR MODERATOR AT MR VICE CHAIR
IS THRILLED IN DEBT WE ARE
MOVING SO- MISTER- MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE.
IF YOU DON'T MIND QUEUE UP ALL
THOSE IN OPPOSITION OF SB
SIXTEEN. THANK YOU. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
AGAIN TO STAY IN THE POSITION
OF OPPOSITION TO SB SIX TEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
THEIR OWN. THERE ARE NO LINES
MAKE YOU. ALL RIGHT WE DID HEAR
FROM ANYONE IN THE SUPPORT COME
WHO IS OPPOSED TO ANY OF THOSE
MISS CORBIN ADMIT LET'S BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE LET'S SEE
IF WE HAVE ANY DISCUSSION
DEBATE FROM COMMITTEE. HEARING
THE- POLICE- MISTER VICE CHAIR.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I'D LIKE TO
MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE DO HAVE A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR BY THE VICE CHAIR VICE
CHAIR NEIL SEEN. ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. CURRENCY NINE CENTER
GROVE AGAIN YEAH IT'S ALWAYS A
PLEASURE TO BE TO WORK WITH
YOU. WOULD LIKE TO SEE IF YOU'D
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I REALLY APPRECIATE IT
AND I DID KEEP IT TRYING TO BE
TRUNCATED. BUT I DO WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT EVERYBODY
UNDERSTANDS THAT THIS BILL IS
GOING TO ALLOW PARENTS THAT
HAVE HAD TO ADJUST TO VIRTUAL
LEARNING- GIVE ENOUGH HOURS AT
WORK INCREASING INTERNET ACCESS
TEACHING THEIR KIDS AT HOME
SOME OF THEM BECOMING A FULL
TIME TEACHER AS WELL AS MAKING
SURE THEIR FAMILY STILL IS
ABLE. TO PUT FOOD ON THEIR
TABLE IT WOULD ALLOW THEM THIS
TWO THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY DOLLAR. TAX CREDIT AT THE
END OF THE YEAR TO CLAIM BACK
SOME OF THE MONEY THAT THEY'VE
EXPANDED OUT FOR EITHER LAPTOPS
COMPUTERS INTERNET SERVICE. AND
ASSOCIATED BOOKS AND SUPPLIES
THAT THEY'VE HAD TO INVEST IN
SO THAT THEIR CHILDREN HAVE A
MINIMALLY CHIEF MAKE GAP OF
BEING OUT OF SCHOOL FOR ALMOST
THIRTEEN MONTHS NOW. SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NIGHT
OUT THANK YOU SO MUCH IN A ROW
OF SEATS TRAVELS BACK HOME HERE
TODAY- BENEFITS FIVE FIVE AND A
HALF HOUR TRACK. SO I THINK YOU
SO MUCH CENTER GROVE. MR NOW A-
GOING TO READ THE FORMAL MOTION
AND THEN CALL THE ROLL MR NOW.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR MCGUIRE
I. REQUIRE A SENATOR NIELSEN.
NIELSEN SENATOR ALSO. SENATOR
HERTZBERG SENATOR WIENER WIENER
HI THREE ZERO THANK YOU JIM
THAT ENJOYS A THREE ZERO VOTE
WE'RE GONNA KEEP THAT BILL ON
CALL IN WILL ADD ON IT MR
HERTZBERG MR EYES THOUGH IF
THEY SO CHOOSE WHEN THEY GET
BACK WE'RE NOW GOING TO WELCOME
THE PRIDE OF ORANGE COUNTY AT
TWO COMMITTEE THAT IS SENATOR
I'M BERG CENTER NUMBER IS GONNA
BE PRESENTING AS P. FORTY NINE
REALLY FOCUS SEEN ON FAIR FEES
APPRECIATE ALL OF HIS WORK ON
ALL ISSUES OF THIS DEAL- THIS
IS ITEM NUMBER FOR. THAT MR
NUMBER GET YOU HAVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT SO WE'RE GOING TO ASK
YOU TO PLEASE PROVIDE A
TRUNCATED VERSION OF YOUR FLOOR
STATEMENT THE FLOOR IS YOURS
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH- SINCE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF MANY WANT TO THANK IN
PARTICULAR JUST JUST COULD
DOCUMENT FROM YOUR STAFF WHO'S
BEEN MOST HELPFUL IN IMPROVING
THE BILL. THIS BILL SIMPLY
PROVIDES THAT. FOR THOSE WHO'VE
PAID CERTAIN FEES THE
GOVERNMENTAL ENTITIES DURING
THE COURSE OF THE PANDEMIC THIS
PROVIDES A TAX CREDIT IT IS
RETROSPECTIVE ORIGINAL VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THAT WE
AGREE WITH YOU JESSICA IS IN
TOWN IN AS SOON OF BERGEN THANK
YOU ALL YOUR ON THIS. IS ALL
RIGHT WE DO NOT HAVE A PRIME
WHAT LAW AS THE WITNESSES ON
THIS. BUT WE ARE GOING SEE IF
THERE'S WHO THAT TO SPEAK
INSTEAD OF IT FOURTEEN HERE IN
THE CHAMBERS. MISMA KAYLEE. HAS
RISEN A MECHANICALLY PROCEED.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN AFTER. CHRIS
MCKAY ON THE OF THE HALL CHAIN
OF COMMERCE IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE THANK YOU SO MUCH MISS
MCKINLEY- AND WE WERE GRATEFUL
YOU'RE HERE WITH US TODAY
ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE TO GET A
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB FORTY
NINE PLEASE DO SO NOW THE
CHAMBERS. SCENE NO ONE ELSE
RISE ARE NOT GOING TO GO TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE TO SEE IF
ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO BE A
SPEAK. IN SUPPORT OF SB FORTY
NINE. NO ONE IS SAID STANDING
ON THIS ISSUE WE ARE NOW GOING
TO BE. GOING TOWARD
TELECONFERENCE LINE WE WELCOME
YOUR PHONE CALLS AT EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE
FIVE TWO. MR MODERATOR IF YOU
COULD PLEASE QUEUE UP ALL
FOLKS. WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
FORTY NINE NOW. PLEASE JOIN ME
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN.
SUPPORT OF SB FORTY NINE PLEASE
PRESS. ONE ZERO. WE DO HAVE ONE
IN OUR QUEUE. GO TO LINE TWO
FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
PRESTON YOUNG FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
HERE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH YOUR PHONE CALL
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AT THIS TIME THERE ARE
NO OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE ALL
RIGHT LAYS IN GERMAN WE'RE
GONNA BRING IT BACK HERE TO THE
SENATE CHAMBERS TO BE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN OPPOSITION OF
SB FORTY NINE. WE'RE LOOKING
FOR FOLKS IN OPPOSITION OF SB
FORTY NINE IF YOU COULD PLEASE
RISE NOW. SEE NO ONE RIDES ARE
NOT GOING TO GO TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE ROOM ONE TWELVE.
NOTHING'S HAPPENED AND SO WE
ARE NOT GOING TO GO TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE. THERE'S A
GENTLEMAN IN MR MODERATOR WE'RE
GONNA ASK ALL THOSE WHO ARE IN
A POSITION OF SB FORTY NINE. MR
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE
THEM UP NOW. AND NOW HERE IN IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FORTY NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. ONE ONE
ZERO FOR OPPOSITION. WE DO HAVE
ONE IN OUR QUEUE. WE'LL GO TO
NUMBER THREE FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ACCORDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
REPATRIATION AND OPPOSITION
TRUSTED AND GET OUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HANGING
WITH US HERE TODAY WE'RE
GRATEFUL LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. AT THIS TIME THERE ARE
NO OTHERS IN THE QUEUE THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR AT WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO QUESTIONS COMMENTS AND
CONCERNS BUT FIRST. MR AMBER
YOU'RE TAKING THE COMMITTEE
MINUTES TODAY CORRECT. YES WE
ARE THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
AMBERG MISTER VICE CHAIR PLEASE.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THE FLOOR WITH A MOTION BY ON
BY VICE CHAIR NIELSEN THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER VICE CHAIR.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS.
FROM THE COMMITTEE. HERE IN C.
NINE WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR BY VICE CHAIR NIELSEN
CENTER- BUT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE PLEASURE WORKING WITH YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND YOUR STAFF ARE
TONIGHT VOTE. ALWAYS A PLEASURE
SIR THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
MISTER AMBERG. ALL RIGHTS TO MR
NOW'S GONNA READ THE FORMAL
MOTION IN CALL THE ROLL MR NOW.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED AND
WE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR MCGUIRE
HI REQUIRE- A SENATOR NIELSEN
HI NIELSEN- SENATOR ALSO.
SENATOR HERTZBERG HURTS BURGER
FI SENATOR WIENER WIENER HI
THANKS IN JOY IS A FOUR ZERO
VOTE WE'RE GONNA KEEP THE ROLL
OPEN AND CHECKING CENTER DRIVE
SO WHEN SHE'S DONE WITH HER
BUDGET SUB BASIN GENTLEMAN I
WANT TO DO A QUICK LOOK AT OUR
AGENDA- WE HAVE WE'RE GONNA GO
THROUGH. ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
WHICH IS S. C. FOUR EIGHTY FIVE
THEN WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
BRIEF FIFTEEN TO TWENTY MINUTE
RECESS AND THEN COME BACK SO-
THAT'S GO TO OUR NEXT AUTHOR-
IF WE'RE LOOKING AT FILE ORDER
INFORM FILE ORDER IT SENATOR
SKINNER BUT WE DO HAVE CENTER
MY CASKEY WHO IS HERE AT CENTER
WHITE COW SKI IS GONNA BE
PRESENTING ON A. S. V. FOUR.
SIX SIX. FOCUSING ON COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT CENTER MY CASKET WE
WELCOME YOU TO GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE THE FLOOR IS YOURS SIR.
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR I
WANTED THANK YOUR STAFF AND I
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS AS
OUTLINED IN THE MOCK UP AND AS
A STAFF REPORT- NOTES EXISTING
LAW AUTHORIZES CITIES AND
COUNTIES OR CITIES. AND
COUNTIES TOGETHER WITH THE
APPROVAL OF THE LEGISLATIVE
BODIES TO. BUY RESOLUTION UP
FOR PUBLIC HEARING TO ACQUIRE
SELL LEASE. A PROPERTY IN
FURTHERANCE OF THE CREATION OF
AN ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT THE
CITY OF CLARA- MAY SELL LEASE
PROPERTY LOCATED AT FIVE
HUNDRED BENTON STREET TO CREATE
ECONOMIC. OPPORTUNITY IN THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY. SHELL FIRST
APPROVED THE SALE. OR LEASE BY
RESOLUTION AFTER PUBLIC
HEARING. THIS DEVELOPMENT WILL
IMPROVE THE COMMUNITY THAT I
REPRESENT BRINGING- NECESSARY.
HOUSING FOR- THE- STUDENTS.
ATTEND SANTA CLARA UNIVERSITY
AND I HAVE WITH ME TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS CHRIS SHAY WITH THE
REPUBLIC METROPOLITAN AND I
URGE YOU TO VOTE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH CINEMA CASKEY WE DO HAVE
ONE LEAD WITNESS. WHO WILL BE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT THAT'S
CHRIS SHAY HE'S REPRESENTING
REPUBLICAN REIMS GETTING
REPUBLIC METROPOLITAN COLLEGE I
SISTER SHAY REPUBLIC
METROPOLITAN AT MISTER SHEA YOU
HAVE THREE MINUTES THE FLOOR IS
YOURS AND WE WELCOME YOU TO
COMMITTEE. BUT QUITE A LOT
RIGHT GOOD AFTERNOON YOU'RE
REQUIRING CREDITORS AND THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO JOIN
THEY FIND IT. MY NAME IS
CHRISTIAN EIGHTEEN- VICE
PRESIDENT FOR PUBLIC
METROPOLITAN AN INNOVATIVE AND
PROUD OF THE WORK HEADQUARTERED
IN SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA. GOOD
KNOWLEDGE HERE THIS MORNING AT.
THE WHITE HOUSE HE'S. GOT A
BILL FOR SIXTY SIX. BUT
AFTERNOON STOP THE EXCITING
HELPING UP TO THE LOW. AT FIVE
HUNDRED ALBANY RIEL IN THE
CLEAR CALIFORNIA. WITH ALL
BUILDINGS LIKE THIS ANY REAL
ATTACKS THAT WILL BUILD.
COMPUTERS HERE OF HOW THE
CRISIS. THAT COMPLEXITY THAT WE.
WERE PUBLIC THRIVE ON HOLDING.
IT'S AN ACQUIRED VERY INTEREST
IN COMPLYING WITH ALL RELATED
PERTAINING TO LAND USE IT WILL
LIKELY TO PROTECT THE PROPERTY
TO CREATE AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AND CREATING ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY HEALTH SUPPORT
SERVICES. A QUICK BACKGROUND
UPDATE OUR PROJECT TO PROVIDE
20% AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO ALL
LEVELS LOOKING AT MY ACCOUNT.
WITH SPECIAL FOCUS. ON THE
LOWER LEVEL WITH ME IN MY
COMMENTS. IN ADDITION THE 29%
HOW FOR SOME FOUR HELP YOU PAY
CONSENTED TO WORK OUT. IT IS
VERY HIGH THAT THE PRODUCT THAT
WOULD HELP US KEEP RUN WILD FOR
ALL THE RESIDENTS. AND HELP HOW
THE MISSING MIDDLE COMMUNITY
AND YOUNG ADULTS. THIS PRODUCT
WOULD BE IDEAL FOR STUDENTS AND
YOUNG ADULTS ARE JUST CONCERNED
ABOUT THE MECHANIC. CHANNELS
AREA HAVE BEEN PRICED OUT OF
THE MORE TRADITIONAL HEALTH
PRODUCTS. WHAT THE PROPERTY
WILL. ON A PARCEL TO COME
CONTAIN. EIGHTEEN EXISTING CITY
WELL BUT WE WOULD. IT OR
EXPENSE WE DON'T BE ABLE TO HEY
THIS IS POLICE OTHERWISE.
PARKING FOR THE- STATION
COUNTER PARKING. PROJECT SO IS
AN EXISTING. WHY LOCATED
ADJACENT THE NEWLY.BY CALTRAIN
STATION. PARKER STATION.
LOCATION PERFECT FOR QUITE A-
THANK YOU WE- HI WE- ALL.
TRENDS KOREAN HOW THINGS IN
COURT MASK. RIDERSHIP THROUGH
EITHER STOP THE GROUP. AWAY AND
DID A PORTABLE HOW. HOW. YOUR
PLACE AT ECONOMIC. OPPORTUNITY
THAT THIS COMMUNITY DESERVES.
YOU MIGHT HAVE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY HERE TODAY THERE IS A
GEM AND WE DO NOT HAVE
ADDITIONAL LEADS PART WHEN IT'S
LOG WITH COMMITTEE WE'RE GONNA
CHECK IN THOUGH WITH THOSE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB FOUR SIX SIX CHECK IN
FIRST YEAR IN COMMITTEE IN THE
CHAMBERS. CURRENCY KNOWN RISE
TO BECOMING A MICROPHONE WE'RE
NOT GONNA CHECK IN WITH ROOM
ONE TWELVE NO ONE WOULD LIKE TO
BE TO SPEAK IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR SIX SIX
SEVEN NOW LAYS IN GERMANY GO TO
ART TELECONFERENCE LINE MR
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE
AND ALL THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT. OF FOUR TO SIX SIX NOW.
AND IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR SIX SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN
ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT. AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NONE IN OUR QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOU SO
MUCH YEAH WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO
TO THOSE WHO ARE OPPOSED FOR
LOOKING NOW IN OPPOSITION WE DO
NOT HAVE A LEAD OPPOSITION A
LOG AGAINST FOUR SIX SIX WE ARE
GOING TO CHECK IN HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS TO BE TO SEE IF ANYONE
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF FOUR SIX SIX
PLEASE RISE NOW. HERE IN C. NOW
AND WE'RE NOT GONNA GO TO ROOM
ONE TWELVE. SEE WE KNOW IS HE
KNOWN RISE ON FOR SIX SIX IN
OPPOSITION WE'RE NOT GOING TO
GO BACK TO OUR MODERATOR TO BE
ABLE TO ASK. YOU TO QUEUE UP
ANYONE IN A POSITION OF FOUR
SIX SIX NOW. AND NOW IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
SB FOUR SIX SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. AT THIS TIME THERE
ARE NONE IN OUR QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE THANK YOU SO MUCH
WE'RE GONNA BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE APPRECIATE THAT MR
MODERATOR GONNA BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE I WOULD LIKE TO BE
TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE PLEASE
JUST THE MAJORITY LEADER. SURE
MISTER MISTER CHAIRMAN YOU KNOW
I'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS FOR
SOME MONTHS WITH- THE AUTHOR
AND WITH SLUDGE COUNCIL AND-
TRYING TO GET THIS DONE-
THROUGH INTERPRETATION OF
LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL AND WE'VE
HAD TO GO TO. TO A STATUE TO
MAKE THESE CHANGES AND I JUST
WANT TO STAND IN SUPPORT
INDICATING THAT THIS PROPOSED
PROJECT WOULD INCLUDE A MIXED
USE STUDENT HOUSING. WHICH
WOULD COMPRISE OF TWO BUILDINGS
WERE 29% OF TOTAL UNITS ARE
RESERVED FOR AFFORDABLE
WORKFORCE HOUSING. AND THE
PROJECT WOULD CONSIST OF A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY UNITS WHICH
IS FIVE HUNDRED FORTY FIVE BIDS
MEMBERS OF STUDENT PART MISSING
WORK FORCE HOUSING IN SEVENTY
UNITS OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
RESTRICTED TO LOW OR VERY LOW
INCOME PERSONS. THIS IS ANOTHER
STEP FORWARD IN THIS GIGANTIC
EFFORT IN WHICH WERE ENGAGED TO
PROVIDE HOUSING FOR FOLKS AND I
STAND IN A STRONG SUPPORTERS
MEASURE. THANK YOU SO MUCH MR
MAJORITY LEADER ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. THEIR
MOTION ON THE FLOOR THE MOTION
BY THE MAJORITY LEADER MAJORITY
LEADER HERTZBERG HAS MADE THE
MOTION WE APPRECIATE AGAIN
CENTER MY CASKEY- WORKING WITH
US TAKING THOSE AMENDMENTS
SARAH CASKEY A PLEASURE TO WORK
WITH AS ALWAYS- THAT PLEASE MR
CENTER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
MR JOURNAL DHIR CITIES AND
COUNTIES THAT FEAR THAT THEY
MAY FACE SOME FINANCIAL
PENALTIES. IF THEY FAIL TO
COMPLY WITH THE SURPLUS LAND
SEX BEFORE THEY USE THE
ECONOMIC. OPPORTUNITY LAW AND
THIS CLARIFIES IT FOR THE FIVE
HUNDRED BENTON PROJECT IN A
GROUP AND I POST. THANK YOU SO
MUCH CINEMA CASKEY MR NOW IS
GOING TO READ THE FORMAL MOTION
IN CALL THE RULE. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE FOR SENATOR MCGUIRE HI
REQUIRE- A SENATOR NIELSEN.
SENATOR ALSO. SENATOR HERTZBERG
HIGH PERCH BERG RA SENATOR
WIENER ALL RIGHT WINGER HI
THREE ZERO THAT CURRENTLY
ENJOYS A THREE ZERO VOTE WE'RE
GOING TO KEEP THE ROLL OPEN AND
COME BACK TO US IN A CASKET THE
APPROPRIATE TIME GERMAN PLEASE
GIVE US THIRTY SECONDS TO BE
ARRANGED PAPERWORK. LAYS IN
GERMAN A COMMITTEE WE'RE GOING
TO ASK FOR YOUR INDULGENCE TO
BE ABLE TO TAKE ITEMS NUMBER
NINE IN TEN I KNOW WE'RE GOING
TO BE OUT OF ORDER BUT WE'RE
GOING TO ASK FOR THE
COMMITTEE'S INDULGENCE INTO ALL
THOSE WHO ARE HERE WITH US AS
WELL AS ON THE LINES. WE'RE
GONNA NEED TO BE HERE TO TAKE
ITEMS NINE IN TEN HERE AT RIGHT
NEXT ITEM NINE IS SP FIVE FORTY
TWO CENTER THE MON ITEM TEN IS
S. B. FIVE FIVE THREE SEVEN THE
MON WE'RE GOING TO ASK SOME OF
THE MON IS GONNA BE TESTIFYING
REMOTELY. TO BE ABLE TO PROCEED
PLEASE PROCEED ON SP FIVE FORTY
TWO CEREMONY WE WELCOME YOU TO
COMMITTEE. CEREMONY OR NOT
GETTING YOUR AUDIO. ALL RIGHT
GIVE US- IT GIVES THIRTY SECOND
CEREMONY WE'RE HAVIN- BRIEF
AUDIO CHALLENGE GIVE US THIRTY
SECONDS CENTER MON. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN WE ARE JUST GONNA BE
TAKING THE TWO BILLS OF SERRA
THE MOANS AS P. FIVE FORTY TWO
IS WELL AS SP FIVE FIVE THREE
WE APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S
PATIENCE. WILL BE RIGHT BACK
WITH YOU.
MEMBERS. ALL RIGHTS
IN THE MON WE HEAR YOU LOUD AND
CLEAR LOOK AT THAT SO IS IT A
MON MAR YOU PROCEED ON ITEM
NUMBER NINE SP FIVE FORTY TWO
THEN WE'LL TAKE ITEM TEN.
PLEASE PROCEED WELCOME. THANK
YOU KAREN MEMBERS A APOLOGIES
FOR THAT SP FIVE FOR TWO OR
THREE TO FIVE YEARS STATE ONLY
SALES TAX EXEMPTION FOR ALL NEW
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY ZERO
EMISSION TRUCKS IN ORDER TO
MEET CALIFORNIA'S GOLD A 100%
DURING MISSION MEDIUM. AND
HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS BY TWENTY
FORTY FIVE THE BILL WOULD ALSO
ENSURE THAT THERE IS TEAM BEAT
THE PARITY BETWEEN M. H. D.
ZERO EMISSION TRUCKS. AND THEIR
DIESEL OR GASOLINE EQUIVALENT
THESE INCENTIVES WOULD ONLY
APPLY TO THE STATE GENERAL FUND
A PORTION OF THE SALES TAX AND
WOULD NOT APPLY TO LOCAL FUNDS.
EMISSION TRUCKS ARE
SUBSTANTIALLY MORE EXPENSIVE
THAN. CONVENTIONAL DIESEL
TRUCKS. AND THEREFORE THIS
STILL IS NEEDED. WITH US TODAY
WE HAVE CHRIS ASH MOTIVE FROM
THE CALIFORNIA TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION AND BILL MCGOVERN
FROM THE COALITION OF CLEAN AIR
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU O MUCH IS
THERE THE MON WE APPRECIATE
THAT THAT'S GO TO MR SHIMODA
FROM THE CALIFORNIA TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION. MR SHIMODA YOU
HAVE THREE MINUTES I'LL GIVE
YOU A THIRTY SECOND PROMPT THE
FLOOR IS YOURS SIR WELCOME THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU JERRY
MCGUIRE AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CHRIS ROCK-
CALIFORNIA TRUCKING ASSOCIATION
AND WE'D LIKE TO THANK MANY
STAFF FOR THEIR HARD WORK ON
THIS BILL. WE ARE PROUD TO JOIN
A BROAD COALITION OF
ENVIRONMENTAL AND BUSINESS
INTERESTS INCLUDING THE
CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION. AND
THE COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR AND
SUPPORTING SP FIVE FORTY TWO.
SP FIVE FORTY TWO ADDRESSES THE
SIGNIFICANT TAX AND
REGISTRATION THE PENALTIES. THE
TRUCKERS FACE WHEN PURCHASING
MORE EXPENSIVE YOUR MISSION
TRUCKS. INSTEAD OF TRADITIONAL
DIESEL OR GASOLINE VEHICLES. SP
FIVE FORTY TWO ENSURES THAT
TRUCKERS STEPPING UP TO GO
GREEN. DO NOT FACE UP TO
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
ADDITIONAL TAXES AND FEES. AS
YOU KNOW 96% OF TRUCKING
COMPANIES OPERATE TWENTY OR
FEWER TRUCKS. OUR DRIVER
WORKFORCE TO MAKE UP THE
BACKBONE OF CALIFORNIA'S BLUE
COLLAR IDDLE CLASS. IS
MAJORITY MINORITY. CALIFORNIA'S
AMBITIOUS CLIMATE GOALS WHILE
ALSO SUPPORTING ESSENTIAL BLUE
COLLAR INDUSTRIES AND WORKERS.
THE STATE MUST USE EVERY TOOL
AT ITS DISPOSAL TO ENSURE THAT
YOUR MISSION TRUCKS. MAKES
SENSE ECONOMICALLY. AND THE
PREDOMINANTLY SMALL BUSINESS
TRUCKERS WHO PURCHASE THEM CAN
COMPETE. SP FIVE FORTY TWO IS
AN IMPORTANT PIECE OF THE
STATE'S OVERALL CLIMATE
STRATEGY. WE THANK SENATOR
LAMONT SEPARATE LEADERSHIP ON
THIS BILL I THANK THE.
COMMITTEE COURTS TIME AND HARD
WORK THANK YOU AGAIN. THANK YOU
SO MUCH CHRIS CHRISTIAN
ISHIMOTO WITH THE COPPER
TRUCKING IS. WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
GOING TO THE SECOND FINALLY AND
FORTY. THAT'S BILL MCGOVERN
FROM THE COALITION FOR CLEAN
AIR. IS IN THE GOVERN WE
WELCOME YOU TO COMMITTEE THE
FLOOR IS YOURS PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH GERMAN
MCGUIRE. THANK YOU TO CENTER
WELL KNOWN FOR AUTHORING. THIS
IMPORTANT BILL. CALIFORNIA IS
ON THE VERGE OF A
TRANSFORMATION THAT WILL CLEAN
UP. THE TRUCKING SECTOR. WE'RE
GOING TO SHOW THE WORLD THAT WE
CAN. MOVE THE GOODS THAT WE
NEED WITHOUT INFLICTING DIESEL
EXHAUST. ON THE RESIDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES. THERE
ARE ALREADY MANY ZERO EMISSION
TRUCKS THAT ARE COMMERCIALLY
AVAILABLE. AND OTHERS THAT ARE
IN A PILOT OR DEMONSTRATION
DEMONSTRATION STAGE. AND THESE
TRUCKS OVER TIME WILL INCUR
SAVINGS. IN FUEL AND
MAINTENANCE COSTS. BUT THEIR
INITIAL STICKER PRICES ARE MUCH
HIGHER. THAN THE COST OF
CONVENTIONAL DIESEL FUEL
TRUCKS. AND THAT MEANS THAT
TAXES AND FEES ARE ALSO HIGHER.
AND THAT'S WHY WE NEED THIS
BILL. DIESEL TRUCKS THAT HAVE A
LOWER PRICE. BUT HIGHER COSTS
IN FUEL AND ALSO HIGHER COSTS
INFLICTED ON SOCIETY. IN THEIR
POLLUTION. SO THIS BILL WOULD
BE A SMART INVESTMENT FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THEN THE
REDUCED COST. IT ADDS MORE.
PREMATURE DEATHS. WILDFIRES AND
THE OTHER IMPACTS OF OUR TWIN
CRISES OF AIR POLLUTION. AND
CLIMATE CHANGE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR LISTENING WE SUPPORT
THE BILL. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISS MCGOVERN WERE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
HERE TODAY. THOSE ARE TWO LEAD
SUPPORT WITNESSES WERE NOT
GOING TO CHECK IN WITH. ANYONE
ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL HERE IN
THE SENATE CHAMBERS. SEE NO ONE
WRITES WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE. ROOM ONE
TWELVE SEE IF ANYONE WOULD LIKE
TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB. FIVE FOUR TWO NO ONE IS
STANDING AT THAT MICROPHONE
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO OUR
PHONE LINES. WE'RE GONNA CHECK
IN WITH THE MODERATOR MR
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
QUEUE UP ALL INDIVIDUALS. WHO
WOULD LIKE TO BE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB. FIVE FOUR TWO
PLEASE DO SO NOW. I DIDN'T JUMP
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO. IN OF SB
FOUR PLEASE PRESS G. AT THIS
TIME. WE CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT
SEVEN IN THE QUEUE. WE'LL START
WITH NUMBER ONE THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AGAIN DURING AND WE ARE
HERE ON BEHALF OF ADVANCED
ENERGY ECONOMY- IN SUPPORT OF
F. B. FIVE FOUR TWO HELLO THANK
YOU SO MUCH ANDREW THAT'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER MISTER
MODERATOR. NEXT IS NUMBER THREE
SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
DOING JACK HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS.
CHILD STAR DAIMLER TRUCKS NORTH
AMERICA MIGHT NEED NEW MOTORS-
I KNOW LECTURE DANCE ALL
WEEKEND WE'VE IN. TERMS OF BALL
BALLARD POWER SYSTEMS AND
BOLLINGER MOTORS ON SUPPORTED
THE BILL THANK YOU JIM THANK.
YOU FOR YOUR PHONE CALL LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER. NEXT IS
THREE SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU SIR MEMBER OF
THE COMMITTEE DAVID INVOLVED
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE TRUCK
AND ENGINE MANUFACTURERS
ASSOCIATION HAPPEN AGAIN STRONG
SUPPORT AND SOME RECRUITERS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CALL CALL
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT IS
THREE FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MR CARE MEMBERS- BUILDER ON
BEHALF OF BRUCE MAC GRAY AND
YOU PS IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANKS SO VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT IS NUMBER THREE
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU TURN NUMBERS NIKITA KARATE
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL IN SUPPORT VERY
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR PHONE CALL
TODAY THAT'S GOING TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. NEXT IS THREE SEVENTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD- MEDICARE
MEMBERS THIS IS JUDY MALINOWSKI
BALL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION AND
SUPPORT THANKS JULIE NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. AT THIS TIME
THERE ARE NO OTHERS IN THE
QUEUE ALL RIGHT ANY. THANK YOU
MR MODERATOR WILL BE BACK WITH
YOU IN JUST A MOMENT WE DO NOT
HAVE LEAD THE OPPOSITION
WITNESSES LOG FOR THIS BILL
WE'RE GONNA CHECK IN TO SEE IF
ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO BE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO FIVE
FORTY TWO HERE IN THE SENATE
CHAMBERS. SEE NO ONE RIDES ARE
NOT GOING TO GO TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE SEE NO ONE RIDES WERE
NOT GOING TO BE GOING TO OUR
PHONE LINES MR MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE CAN YOU PLEASE-
QUEUEUP ALL INDIVIDUALS WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION IN OPPOSITION OF
FIVE FORTY TWO. NOW AND NOW YOU
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THE SP FIVE FORTY TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. TEN ONE ZERO
FOR OPPOSITION. AT THIS TIME WE
DO NOT HAVE ANYBODY IN THE
QUEUE THANKS SO MUCH CHRIS
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR WILL BE
BACK WITH YOU ALL RIGHT
COMMITTEE WE'RE GONNA BRING IT
BACK TO YOU QUESTIONS COMMENTS
OR EMOTION. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
CENTER WINNER THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER WINNER- ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE. AARON C. NINE.
SIMONE WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
EIGHTY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AND I AM A THANK YOU SOON THE
BONE WE HAVE ONE MORE FROM THE
GOOD SENATOR I'M FROM SANTA
BARBARA IN JUST A MOMENT MR NOW
CAN YOU PLEASE READ THE FORMAL
MOTION IN CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR MCGUIRE
HI REQUIRE A CINDER NIELSEN.
NIELSEN KNOWS SENATOR DRAWS SO.
SENATOR HERTZBERG SEARCH FOR HI
SENATOR WIENER WIENER- THREE
TWO ONE THERE IS CURRENTLY A
THREE LINE OF VOTE LAYS IN
GERMAN THREE ONE VOTE WE HAVE
ONE MORE BILL FROM CENTER TO
THE MON AND THAT'S- ITEM NUMBER
TEN SP FIVE FIVE THREE SEVEN
THE MON WE DO WANT TO LET YOU
KNOW HONESTY FIVE FIVE THREE
YOUR BODY PARTISAN SUPPORT SO
WE'RE GONNA ASK FOR TRUNCATED
STATEMENT. THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU AND I WILL START OFF
BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT. AND LET YOU KNOW
THAT THIS IS A TAX CREDITS THAT
PROVIDE. FOR ANY BUSINESS THAT-
IS ABLE TO HIRE SOMEONE HAS
USUALLY FACED BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT. AND WITH THAT I
RESPECT THE US FOR NINE MONTHS
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIS ANOTHER
MOMENT WE ARE NOW GOING TO BE
GOING TO THE U. LEAD WITNESS.
WHO IS JOINING CEREMONY IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE FIVE THREE
AND HER NAME IS GENET QUICK THE
LEAD COUNSEL OF FINANCIAL
SERVICES. BUT LET'S GO TO MISS
QUICKNESS QUICK GOOD AFTERNOON.
YOU ARE NOW IN COMMITTEE THE
FLOOR IS YOURS PLEASE PROCEED
YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS GENET QUICK- HAD A
COMPLAINT IN THE LOCALITY
PROGRESSO. WE ARE PROUD TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
FIFTY THREE TODAY AND THANKS
FOR THE MONTH OF THE YEAR
SHOULD. GO THROUGH THIS EVERY
SINGLE BEAD PEOPLE PLATFORM
PROVIDING PAYROLL BENEFITS
COMPLIANCE AND HR TO MORE THAN
THREE THOUSAND SMALL BUSINESSES
IN CALIFORNIA. MORE THAN A
HUNDRED THOUSAND ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES. MANY OF OUR
BUSINESSES HAVE FEWER THAN
FIFTY EMPLOYEES AND CUSTOMERS
FOCUS ON. CREATING A BETTER
SYSTEM. WE CREATE A WORLD WHERE
HARD AT THE LIGHT DEEPLY. TO
HELL OUR TRIP. THROUGH AND
BELIEVE THAT THE CRITICAL
BECAUSE IT PROVIDES INCENTIVES
FOR EMPLOYERS TO HIRE
INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE
CHALLENGES FINDING A JOB. THAT
YOU GO THROUGH THE CRIMINAL
BACKGROUND INSTABILITY VETERAN
LONG TERM UNEMPLOYED- THERE'S A
PROFESSOR AT THE WHARTON SCHOOL
UNIVERSITY FOR PENNSYLVANIA DR
PETER. PETER CAPELLI. WHO
ANALYZED THE FEDERAL WORK
OPPORTUNITY TAX CREDIT IN A
SERIES OF STUDIES. AND
CONCLUDED THERE ARE
DEMONSTRABLE AND DOCUMENTED
BENEFIT TO WHAT THE PROGRAMS.
INCLUDING INCREASED PROBABILITY
OF EMPLOYMENT LENGTH OF
EMPLOYMENT AND IMPROVED WHICH
IS FRANKLY THE COMPANY. WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL WOULD
ALLOW COMPANIES IN CALIFORNIA-
TO ADDRESS. IF YOU'VE THE BASE
BY THOSE THAT HISTORICALLY
UNDER- I HAD HAD CHALLENGE IN%
THE CAN A POINT. WELL AT THE
SAME TIME HELPING IN. SMALL BIZ
OWNERS TO HIRE. THAT HAVE BEEN.
TOLD THEM TO LOOK AT THEM MAKE
WE'RE SAYING THAT WE SMALL
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA STILL
HAVE A LARGE DOG THAT THAT THAT
OUT OF WHICH THEY CONTINUE TO
CLIMB. THROUGH THE END OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IN APRIL HEAD
COUNT AMONG SMALL BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA THREE POINT 3% LOWER
THAN WHAT THE VICTORY TWENTY
TWENTY. AND EVEN FINANCIAL BE
IMPORTANT IN THE RECOVERY- WE
DID SEE THAT- AFTER THE GREAT
RECESSION IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN. UNEMPLOYMENT AMONG
DISABLED WORKER DID NOT FULLY
RECOVER UNTIL TWENTY FOURTEEN.
YOUNG VETERANS HAVE HAD A
PARTICULARLY DIFFICULT
EXPERIENCE IN A CIVILIAN LABOR
FORCE. IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
WHEN YOU ESSENTIAL EMPLOYMENT
RATE WAS 9% THE UNEMPLOYMENT
RATE OF YOUNG VETERANS OF 29%
THIRTY SECONDS THERE'S- A YOU
KNOW IT. OKAY TO THANK YOU
AFTER MEETING YOU TO- TO
TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF- DISTILLED
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT URGE
YOUR SUPPORT IS. GOOD MEASURES
THE FORTY YOU FOR PRETTY HAPPY.
IT'S QUICK THING YOU SO MUCH WE
APPRECIATE PATIENCE IN HANGING
WITH US HERE TODAY NO IT'S BEEN
A BIT OF A DELAY SO WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL. ALL RIGHT LAYS IN
GERMAN WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
GOING TO THOSE WITNESSES WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SP FIVE. FIVE THREE WE'RE
GONNA. SEE IF ANYONE WOULD LIKE
TO RISE HERE IN THE CHAMBERS.
AARON SCENE KNOWN NOT GOING TO
GO ROOM. TWELVE NO ONE IS
RAISING ROOM ONE TWELVE IN
SUPPORT OF S. C. FIVE FIVE
THREE SO THAT YOU DON'T WE'RE
NOT GOING TO BE GOING TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE. WE'RE
GONNA ASK OUR MODERATOR TO
PLEASE QUEUE UP ALL THOSE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE FIVE THREE
NOW. AND IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE FIVE THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE THREE IN THE
QUEUE. WE'LL START WITH NUMBER
THREE FORTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ALEX
TOWARDS A STRATEGY. NOT IN THE
SENATE THANK YOU. ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE CAL ASIAN PACIFIC
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE THE SPORT
THANK YOU BIG STORIES VERY MUCH.
THANKS FOR THE PHONE CALL LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER. NEXT IS
THREE SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH HI- THIS IS MIKE
ROBESON ADULTS TO GO AROUND TO
SPEND ON THE- I'M HAPPY
CALIFORNIA STAFFING
PROFESSIONALS SUPPORT THANKS
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR FOR
YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY NEXT
COLOR. THANKS TO NUMBER TWO
FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT YOUR
AUTOMATED LINE THOUGH. ALL
RIGHT LET'S GO TO THE NEXT
CALLER MISTER MODERATOR. AT
THIS TIME THERE ARE NO OTHERS
IN OUR QUEUE ALL RIGHT PRECIADO
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND MISTER
MODERATOR WE ARE NOW GOING TO
BE GOING TO THOSE WHO ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF FIVE FIVE THREE
WE DO NOT HAVE ANY OFFICIAL
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES LOG
IN WITH COMMITTEE. WE'RE GONNA
CHECK IN HERE- IN THE SENATE
CHAMBERS TO SEE IF ANYONE WOULD
LIKE TO BE A SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF FIVE FIVE THREE
HEARING SEEN NOMINATION DOWN
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE GOING TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE SEE NO ONE RISE
IN OPPOSITION OF SP FIVE FIVE
THREE WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO. TO
OUR TELECONFERENCE LINE WE'RE
GONNA CHECK IN WITH OUR
MODERATOR IS TO PLEASE QUEUE UP
ALL THOSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE
A SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. OF FIVE
FIVE THREE NOW. NOW IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SP FIVE FIVE THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. AT THIS TIME WE DO
NOT HAVE ANYONE IN THE QUEUE WE
SHOULDN'T THANK YOU SO MUCH AS
A WRITER PROCEED YOUR HARD WORK
HERE TODAY BUT ACTIVATED TURN
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONVERSATION OUR
MOTION IS AN EMOTION I SENT IT
WEINER WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR BY SENATOR WIENER ON SP
FIVE FIVE THREE HEARING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION FROM
COMEDY CENTRAL AMONG. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
IPHONE. THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM
SENATOR THE MOTION IS ON THE
FLOOR BY SENATOR WIENER MR NOW.
CAN YOU PLEASE READ THE FORMAL
MOTION AND CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST A MAN AND WE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR MCGUIRE
HI MIK WEIR- A SENATOR
NIELSEN. NIELSEN A SENATOR ALSO.
SENATOR HERTZBERG. HERZBERG
SORRY SENATOR WIENER. WIENER HI
FOUR ZERO THAT'S CURRENTLY
ENJOYS A FOUR ZERO VOTES THANK
YOU SO MUCH THAT'S BIPARTISAN
THANK YOU CENTER THE MON I
INVEST YOU OVER THE WEEKEND AS
WELL INTO THE BABY I HOPE SHE'S
DOING GOOD- THE- THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THERE'S A GENTLEMAN WE
APOLOGIZE- BUT WE ARE GOING TO
NEED TO TAKE UP AS BEFORE
EIGHTY FIVE RIGHT NOW WE'RE
GONNA ALLOW FOLKS THIRTY
SECONDS TO GET CAUGHT UP. RIGHT
NOW WE'RE GONNA TAKE UP SP FOUR
EIGHTY FIVE THAT'S ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT. WE'RE GONNA GIVE FOLKS
JUST A FEW MOMENTS TO BE ABLE
TO CATCH UP HERE SP FORTY FIVE
IS GOINGTO BE NEXT CENTER
FORTINO I GIVE US JUST A FEW
MOMENTS AND WE'LL TAKE IT
SENATE BILL FOUR EIGHTY FIVE UP
NEXT. ALL RIGHT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN WE ARE NOW GOING TO
TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO CENTER
PORTENT TINO AND SP FOUR EIGHTY
FIVE. WE DO WANT TO LET FOLKS
WHO ARE WATCHING AT HOME IN
HERE IN THE CHAMBERS IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE WE'RE GONNA BE
TAKING A TEN MINUTE RECESS.
RIGHT AFTER SP FOUR EIGHTY FIVE
CENTER PARDON TINO THE FLOOR IS
YOURS ON THE DELL WE WELCOME
YOU TO COMMITTEE SIR. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'M PROUD
TO PRESENT HAS BEFORE EIGHTY
FIVE- CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO
REMAIN THE GLOBAL LEADER IN
ENTERTAINMENT PRODUCTION IT'S
ONE OF THE OLDEST INDUSTRIES
AND OUR GOLDEN STATE. AND IT IS
IMPORTANT AND CENTRAL TO THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY. CALIFORNIA
FILM TAX CREDITS THAT HAVE BEEN
PASSED OVER THE LAST. FIVE TO
SIX YEARS HAVE BEEN ENORMOUSLY
SUCCESSFUL BRINGING PRODUCTION
AND JOBS BACK TO CALIFORNIA. WE
MUST MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
PHYSICAL SPACE AND CAPACITY TO
MEET THAT DEMAND AND SO S. B.
FORTY FIVE SIX TO CREATE. A TAX
CREDIT TO HELP STUDIOS BUILD
FILMS. PHYSICAL LOCATIONS THIS
WILL NOT ONLY CREATE. A BOON TO
CONSTRUCTION JOBS CREATING
THOSE FACILITIES BUT THEN ON
GOING PRODUCTION FACILITIES
HAVE A CAPACITY TO HAVE MORE
PRODUCTIONS. IN OUR TATE SO IN
ORDER TO ENSURE. THAT THIS
WONDERFUL INDUSTRY STAYS IN
TRIBES IN CALIFORNIA FORTY FIVE
SEEKS TO DO THAT IT ALSO HELPS
FUND. THE CAREER PATHWAYS
PROGRAM WHICH IS VERY
IMPORTANT- A TRAINING PROGRAM
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CONTINUE
TO TRAIN EMPLOYEES AND-
DIVERSIFY. OUR IT THE EMPLOYEE
POPULATION AS WELL SO INVESTING
IN MODERNIZATION AND STUDIO
INFRASTRUCTURE IS A SOUND
INVESTMENT IN CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMIC HEALTH. AND A CORE
INDUSTRY AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I VOTE WITH ME TO
TESTIFY TODAY I HAVE ERIN
LEHANE. BUT THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
AND EDUARDO MARTINEZ WHO IS THE
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE
MONTHS THANK YOU SO MUCH.
SOONER PORTENT TINO- YOU KNOW
YOU AS YOU KNOW. WE HAVE A VERY
MINOR- AND THEN MINUTES THERE
AND YOU'RE BUT I WILL TAKE IT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ALL RIGHT SO
WE'RE GONNA START IN THE CITY
CHAMBERS WITH MISSILE HANGING-
AND WE'RE STILL WAITING FOR
MISTER MARTINEZ TO JOIN THE
TELECONFERENCING CENTER POINT
YOU KNOW WE JUST WANT TO GIVE
YOU A HEADS UP SO. LET'S START
WITH ERIN THE HANGING HERE IN
THE SENATE CHAMBERS YOU HAVE
THREE MINUTES ON THE THIRTY
SECOND PROMISING. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON AGAIN SENATOR REQUIRE
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ERIN
LEHANE. APPEAR BEFORE YOU ON
BEHALF OF THE HALF A MILLION
MEMBERS OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL. IN INTO THE ESSEX
SUPPORT OF OUR SPONSOR BILL
SENATE BILL FOUR EIGHT FIVE-
THE BUILDING TRADE ARE ONCE
AGAIN THRILLED TO PARTNER. WITH
THEIR BROTHERS AND SISTERS IN
THE ENTERTAINMENT UNIONS AND
SENATOR PORN TEEN- ON THIS BILL
THAT WILL INCENTIVIZE THE LOCAL
PRODUCTION OF ENTERTAINMENT.
AND CREATE THOUSANDS OF WELL
PAYING CONSTRUCTION JOBS FOR
CALIFORNIA SKILLED TRADESPEOPLE
BUILDING THE NEXT GENERATION OF
SOUND STAGES. IT'S BEEN QUITE A
YEAR AND QUITE HONESTLY I DON'T
KNOW HOW WE WOULD HAVE GOTTEN
THROUGH IT WITHOUT THE
CALIFORNIA ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY. FOR MANY OF US THE
STREAMING CONTENTWAS OUR SOLE
COMPANION WILL BE PULLED
QUARANTINE AND FIGHTING THE
CORONAVIRUS. BOOK FOR KIDS WHO
FACE CATACLYSMIC ISOLATION IT
PROVIDED A MUCH NEEDED LAUGH
AND ESCAPE FROM THE GLITCHY
NESS OF ZOOM SCHOOL. WELL OUR
STUDIOS WERE MOSTLY SHUTTERED
DURING THE WORST OF THE
PANDEMIC THEY ARE NOW OFTEN
OPERATED WITH MORE DEMAND THAN
EVER. TO MEET CONSUMER
APPETITES AT A POSSIBLY BEEN
CHANGEDFOREVER DUE TO THE LAST
YEAR. AND WE HAVE NO TIME TO
WASTE NEW YORK AND GEORGIA ARE
ATTEMPTING TO CHASE THEIR
TITLE. IN DECEMBER THE NEW YORK
TIMES WROTE ABOUT HOW TO THE
TAX CREDITS IN NEW YORK HAVE
GREATLY ACCELERATED THE
INDUSTRY IS SOUND STAGES NOW
STRETCH OUT. INTO QUEENS AND
BROOKLYN PRETTY OPPORTUNITIES
FOR NEW YORKERS THAT WE SHOULD
BE CAPTURING HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
IT IS ESTIMATED THAT FOR EVERY
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OF
SOUNDSTAGE CONSTRUCTION
CALIFORNIA STANDS TO BENEFIT
FROM TWO THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE NEW
CONSTRUCTION JOBS. AND ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS IN WAGES AT THREE
HUNDRED SEVENTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS IN ECONOMIC IMPACT. IT
ALSO IS PROJECTED THE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
SOUNDSTAGE INVESTMENT IN THE
FIRST FIVE YEARS OF OPERATION.
WILL GENERATE ALMOST TWELVE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED NEW
PRODUCTION RELATED JOBS AND ONE
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN
WAGES FOR FRIENDS AT I. AT. MPA
TEAMSTERS AND SAG AFTRA. THE
TOTAL PRODUCTION IMPACT WOULD
BE FOUR POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS OF ECONOMIC AND
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY. IN OUR STATE
WELCOME ECONOMIC ACTIVITY AFTER
THIS LAST YEAR. S. B. FORTY
FIVE IS ABOUT CALIFORNIA
INVESTING IN OUR STATE'S WORLD
RENOWNED ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY
IT'S CREATIVE LEGACY AND THE
PEOPLE THAT WILL PRODUCE THE%
INFRASTRUCTURE. THE SACKS THE
STORY LINES THE LAUGHTER AND
TEARS THEY WILL MAINTAIN
CALIFORNIA'S POSITION AS A
GLOBAL LEADER IN ENTERTAINMENT.
LIGHTS CAMERAS IN CONSTRUCTION
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
STAYING VERY GRATEFUL FOR THE
TESTIMONY LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
WE DO NOW HAVE EDUARDO MARTINEZ
WHO IS OUR SECOND LEAD SUPPORT
WITNESS. ON OUR TELECONFERENCE
LIVE LINE HE'S REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
MISTER MARTINEZ WE WELCOME YOU
TO A COMMITTEE YOU ARE NOW IN
COMMITTEE THE FLOOR IS YOURS
YOUR THREE MINUTES. OKAY THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- AND I WILL
NEED ALL OF THAT TIME EDUARDO
MARTINEZ WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION. A HARD TO PUT
IT MORE ARTICULATELY THAN MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE BUILDING
TRADE- SP FORTY FIVE IT'S GOING
TO ENCOURAGE THE BUILDING AND
RENOVATION OF MOTION PICTURE. I
DON'T THINK IT'S IN OUR STATE
ON THE SUCCESS OF THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY TAX CREDIT
PROGRAMS HAVE KEPT MANY
TELEVISION MOTION PICTURE
PRODUCTION IN THE STATE OF
PREVENTED TWENTY TWO SHOWS FROM
SHOOTING OUT OF STATE OR- THE
COUNTRY. YET WITH THE INCREASED
DEMAND HERE IN CALIFORNIA
STATED THAT NOT HAVE ENOUGH.
DOWNSTAGE TO MEET DEMAND. FORTY
FIVE ADDRESS PROBLEM BY
PROVIDING ME ANTENNA FOR THE
BUILDING AND RENOVATION OF
CALIFORNIA SOME FEATURES. THAT
EXPAND PRODUCTION CAPACITY AND
JOBS IN CALIFORNIA- WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR I.
BODEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISS MARTINEZ
THANKS FOR CALLING IN WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BE LOOKING TO THOSE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO GO TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL HERE IN
THE SENATE CHAMBERS. LET'S GO
TO MR DONE. OPEN HANG ON ONE
SECOND MR DONE WE NEED TO GET
YOUR MICROPHONE UP AND RUNNING.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN KEITH
DONE HERE ON BEHALF OF DISTRICT
COUNCIL OF IRON WORKERS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN THE CITY
IN SUPPORT OF SB FORTY FIVE AND
OUR DOORS THE STATEMENTS BY THE
BUILDING TRADES AND- LABOR FOR
IT AS WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU SO MUCH. PRETTY
GRATEFUL. WE HAVE FOUR WHO ARE
QUEUED UP YOUR TOTAL- SPEAKING
IN THE CHAMBERS. WATERMAN
REMEMBERS KIND OF WALKING IN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PIPE TRADES COUNCIL CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS AND WESTERN STATES
COUNCIL OF SHEET METAL WORKERS.
HOW TO SUPPORT SB FORTY FIVE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
SO MUCH. FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
TODAY. COS THANK YOU MR. MIKE
WESTER PRESENTING INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES WE STAND IN SOLIDARITY
WITH THE BUILDING TRADES. I
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN KALEY IS
BACK. YES MISTER CHAIRMAN
CHRISTOPHER KELLY ON BEHALF OF
THE HOLLYWOOD CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL FORTY FIVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH YOUR
TESTIMONY. SEE NO ONE ELSE RISE
IN SUPPORT OF FORTY FIVE HERE
IN THE CITY CHAMBERS YOU'RE
GOING TO NOW GO TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE. SENIOREN RISE IN
SUPPORT OF FORTY FIVE AND ONE
TWELVE FOR NOW GOING TO GO TO
OUR LIVE TELECONFERENCE LINE.
YOU'RE WELCOME TO CALL ANYTIME
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX
EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO. MR
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE
UP ALL THOSE IN SUPPORT OF
FORTY FIVE NOW. GERMAN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB FOUR EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT TWENTY IN
OUR QUEUE. ALL RIGHT WE'LL
START. WE'LL START WITH NUMBER
THREE EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TRANSACTION ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
PUBLIC AFFAIRS COUNCIL AND SAG
AFTRA IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NEXT IS TWO EIGHTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YOUR CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
BELIEVES THEY WANT THIS ON
BEHALF OF THE MOTION PICTURE
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AS A MEMBER NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXUS THREE
FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MATT CRIMMINS HERE I'LL BE
HAPPY TO CALIFORNIA NEVADA
CONFERENCE OF OPERATING
ENGINEERS HAPPY TO BE HERE
TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
FORTY FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NEXT TO BE ONE OH FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HEY GOOD AFTERNOON
PROBLEM IN SETTING A BUILDING
TRAINS IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL TODAY THAT'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER. NEXUS THREE
SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS NOT HOLD ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF TALENT
AGENTS IN SUPPORT OF SB FORTY
FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE CALL NEXT
CALLER. NEXUS TWO THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL UP INTO
THE LITTLE BOTTLE ABOUT THE
FRONTLINE RECRUIT LOCAL ONE
EIGHTEEN. K. GOLD INCLUDED WITH
THE COURT OF THAT BEFORE YOU
START THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PHONE. CALL AGAIN- THAT'S
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER. NEXT TO
THE THREE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
SENATORS AT EVANS WITH
CARPENTERS LOCAL TWO SEVENTEEN
CEMETERY ACCOUNTING WE STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL
FOUR EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PHONE CALL
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT IS
THREE EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE- AT
DUFFY VICE PRESIDENT TEAMSTERS
LOCAL THREE NINETY NINE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AT E. FORTY
FIVE. THANK YOU SO MUCH AT NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. TEXAS THREE
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RIGHT THANKS. COLOR YOUR
INFINITY PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THIS IS ROB STOKER REPRESENTING
SHEET METAL WORKERS LOCAL ONE
OH FOUR AND WE STAND WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
SUPPORT THANKS ROB VERY MUCH
THAT'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
NEXT WILL BE EIGHTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE EIGHTY
SEVEN YOU'RE IN COMMITTEE WHAT.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. SIX OF THE
THREE SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JUAN CAMACHO
WITH FOX CORPORATION IN LOS
ANGELES CALLING EXTRABUCKS
SUPPORT ABOUT THE FORTY FIVE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL TODAY THAT'S A GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER. NEXUS THREE
THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- DIGESTIVE PROBLEMS
CALLING FOR CARPENTERS LOCAL
ONE FIFTY TO REPRESENT A
CONTRACT ACCOUNTING WHEN WE
STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF IT
BEFORE EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH YOUR PHONE
CALL NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXUS
NUMBER SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CALLERHEARING COMMITTEE
PLEASE PROCEED. IT LOOKS LIKE
THEY DID DROP- NEXT TO THE
NUMBER THREE NINETY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS YOUR NUMBER IS. WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL
LABOR'S SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH VERY GRATEFUL NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT TO BE NUMBER THREE
NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE MEMBERS THIS IS
MARK FLYNN BUSINESS MANAGER
IBEW LOCAL FORTY EXECUTIVE
BOARD MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS ON BEHALF OF I B. W.
AND ITS MEMBERS WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU
SO MUCH YOUR PHONE CALL NEXT IN
LINE PLEASE. NEXUS THREE NINETY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON JOANNE DESMOND
FINALLY HERE YEP THE COKE STAGE
EMPLOYEES LOCAL SIX SAN
FRANCISCO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU JOANNE NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXUS THREE FORTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MICHAEL ALL REPRESENTREPRESENT
WARNER BROTHERS STUDIOS WARNER
MEDIA STRONG SUPPORT FOR THIS
CATALYST FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
DEVELOPMENT THANK YOU MICHAEL
NEXT CALL. NEXUS THREE THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS TONY
CASTILLO CARPENTERS LOCAL SEVEN
OH ONE COVER IN FRESNO MADERA
TULARE AND KINGS COUNTIES-
STANDING WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR EIGHTY FIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR CALLING
IN TODAY NEXT CALLER. NEXUS
THREE EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS GREGORY IS
BUSINESS REPRESENTATIVE OF
IATSE LOCAL SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT
LEADING TECHNICIANS FROM
HOLLYWOOD CALIFORNIA SPEAK IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FORTY FIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PHONE CALL NEXT CALLER.
SIX IS A THREE EIGHTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SH GOOD
AFTERNOON LESLIE SIMMONS FIELD
REP I SEE LOCAL EIGHT THIRTY
NINE IN SRONGSUPPORT AT THE.
FORTY FIVE THANK YOU LESLIE
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT IS
NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE
DON'T. LINE NINETY FOUR
ENTERING OUR LIVES ON. BY
NINETY FOUR YEAR IN COMMITTEE.
ANDREW DAVEY LOCAL FOUR FOUR
SEVEN SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT M.
S. P. FORTY FIVE THANK YOU SO
MUCH YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
NEXT AT NUMBER SEVENTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE INTERVIEWS ALL
WHO'S SMART SHEET METAL WORKERS
LOCAL ONE ZERO FIVE GETTING A
CALL THERE THE BUILDING TRADES
THE PORT THANK YOU SO MUCH YOUR
PHONE CALL. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NEXUS NUMBER ONE SIXTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LET'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT TO
NUMBER ONE OH EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THE NEXT WOULD
BE NUMBER THREE EIGHTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TOM DAVIS ITS
BEEN LOCAL NUMBER EIGHTY
PERSONS MANAGER STEMS FROM
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PHONE CALL NEXT CALLER.
NEXUS CAN BE NUMBER THREE
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS KATHY GARMENT SAFE FROM
THE CALIFORNIA OUT TO COUNCIL
IN THE ENTERTAINMENT UNION
COALITION STANDING AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PHONE CALL LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER. NEXT TO NUMBER
THREE NINETY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS NORMA LOPEZ WITH
TEAMSTERS LOCAL NINE FIFTY TO
ORANGE COUNTY IN THE CITY I'M
STANDING AND STRONG SUPPORT SB
FOUR EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU
THANKS TO IRMA NEXT CALLER.
NEXT TO NUMBER TWO EIGHTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWO EIGHTY
EIGHT YEAR IN COMMITTEE PLEASE
PROCEED. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER THING TO
EAT IS CRUISING DOWN THE
HIGHWAY RIGHT NOW SO LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER- NEXT TO THE
NUMBER ONE TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE TEN YEAR IN COMMITTEE
PLEASE PROCEED. LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT WE
HAVE NUMBER EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON TO A
LEVEL OF IRON WORKERS UNION
LOCAL THREE SEVENTY EIGHT IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FORTY FIVE
ALONGSIDE THE OTHER BUILDING
TRADES THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR PHONE CALL
THANKS FOR YOUR PATIENCE TODAY
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
NEXT WE HAVE ONE TEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE ONE TENURE IN
COMMITTEE PLEASE PROCEED. LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT LINE MODERATOR.
AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO
OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A
MODERATOR WILL BE BACK WITH YOU
HERE IN JUST A FEW MOMENTS
WE'RE NOT GOING TO CHECK IN FOR
THOSE WHO MAY BE IN OPPOSITION
A FORTY FIVE WE'RE GOING TO SEE
IF ANYONE IS IN OPPOSITION HERE
IN THE SENATE CHAMBERS SCENE
KNOWN RISE YOU'RE GONNA GO TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE. SCENE KNOWN%
RISE AROUND TWELVE WE ARE NOW
GOING TO BE GOING TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE LOOKING FOR
OPPOSITION THE MODERATORS GOING
TO QUEUE UP ALL OPPOSITION SP
FOUR EIGHTY FIVE. MR MODERATOR
PLEASE QUEUE UP ALL THOSE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR EIGHTY
FIVE NOW. AND NOW IF YOU LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FORTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. N. ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. LAUREN WHO IS-
WONDERFUL WORKING BEHIND THE
SCENES AS THERE'S ONLY FORTY
TWO PEOPLE IN OPPOSITION SO- IT
SHOULD ONLY TAKE ABOUT AN HOUR
I'M KIDDING I KID SO- THAT WE
ARE GONNA TURN IT BACK TO THE
MODERATOR YES THAT LAUREN IS
GIVING ME THE EVIL EYE NOW
LET'S GO TO THE MODERATOR AND
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FOUR EIGHTY
FIVE- YES WILL GO TO NUMBER
EIGHTY SIX. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
O'CONNOR IN MADERA COUNTY AND I
AM. ENTRANCE PRESENTED OR
EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU SO MUCH
TWO WE APPRECIATE YOU CALLING
IN TODAY LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT IS NUMBER
THREE EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS RICHARD
MARCUS AND FOR THE WESTERN
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION WE OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED TO THE P. L. A.
PROVISIONS IN THE MEASURE ONE
OF WHICH DENIES THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER THE AUTHORITY TO
ENFORCE THE LABOR CODE ON SOME
OF THESE CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO
OTHERS IN THE QUEUE. PLEASE
CONTINUE ALL RIGHT SO- LACING
GENTLEMEN THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR THAT'S TURN IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONVERSATION. WE HAVE A MOTION
BY SENATOR WIENER THANK YOU SO
MUCH. MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE DO
WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONVERSATION. HERRINGTON IN
SCENE NINE WE DO HAVE A MOTION
ON THE FLOOR. CENTER FORTINO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AS YOU
HEARD FROM. THE PROPONENTS FROM
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THIS IS A WELCOME BOON TO BOTH
THE ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY-
CONSTRUCTION JOBS AND OUR LABOR
MARKET AND OUR LABOR PARTNERS.
WHO REPRESENT MEN AND WOMEN WHO
WANT TO CONTINUE TO WORK AS THE
ENTERTAINMENT IN THE INDUSTRY
RE OPENS. IN CALIFORNIA SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I VOTE
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER
PORTENT TINO MOTION BY SENATOR
WIENER WE'RE GONNA TURN TO
MISTER RIGHT NOW TO BE ABLE TO
GIVE US A FORMAL MOTION. AND TO
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDEDBUT FIRST AMEND
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR
MCGUIRE I REQUIRE- SENATOR
NIELSEN. NIELSEN. IS SENATOR
DURAZO. SO HURTS. HERZBERG SIZE
SENATOR WIENER. WIENER FORTY
ZERO. CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FOUR
ZERO VOTE WE'RE GONNA KEEP THE-
ROLE OPEN TO ALLOW CENTER DRIVE
SO TO BE ABLE TO ADD ON. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN COMMITTING TO ALL
THOSE WHO ARE WATCHING HERE
WITH US IN THE CHAMBERS WERE
GOING TO TAKE A BRIEF RECESS TO
ONE THIRTY BRIEF RECESS INTO
ONE THIRTY. THAT WE WILL BE
BACK THAT WE ARE GOING TO GO TO
WHEN WE GET BACK TO SENATOR
SKINNER. S. V. TWO FIVE SEVEN
AND THEN THE SENATOR MAN AS
BEFORE ZERO EIGHT AT
APPROXIMATELY ONE THIRTY. FOUR
IN A BRIEF RECESS.
MORNING. FINNA
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE WILL BE COMING BACK
TOGETHER IN SIXTY SECONDS.
ALL
RIGHT IS IN GERMAN WE'RE GONNA
BE BRINGING BACK THE SENATE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE WE WANT TO FIRST AND
FOREMOST SAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU TO THE PATIENTS OF ALL
THOSE WHO ARE HERE WITH US
TODAY THE SENATE CHAMBERS IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE AS WELL AS- ON
A TELECONFERENCE ON. DATING
GERMAN WE'RE GONNA BE TAKING
ITEM NUMBER FIVE SP TWO FIFTY
SEVEN FIRST MEMBER TO GO TO
ITEM SIX FIFTY FOUR OH EIGHT
NEXT. WE'RE GOING TO TURN THE
FLOOR OVER TO SENATOR SKINNER
HONESTY TO FIFTY SEVEN. CENTER
SKINNER- WE DO WANT TO LET YOU
KNOW THAT YOU HAVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT ON THE BILL. ALL RIGHT
SO WE'RE GONNA ASK FOR
TRUNCATED STATEMENT THE FLOOR
IS YOURS AND I JUST WANTED
KNOWLEDGE CENTERS CAN SHE ISN'T
WORKING ON THIS BILL FOR QUITE
SOME TIME. IT'S CRITICAL. FOR
THE FACILITIES THAT ARE GONNA
BE HELPING THANK YOU AFTER YOUR
FOCUS THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. MISTER CHAIR. THE
ISSUE IS THAT NONPROFIT
MUSEUMS. ARE GIVEN A WELFARE
EXEMPTION. TO NOT HAVE TO PAY
PROPERTY TAXES THAT'S THE NORM.
HOWEVER WE'VE HAD A SITUATION
WHERE SOME COUNTY ASSESSOR'S.
HAPPY GUN TO. ASSESS SUCH
MUSEUMS WHEN THEY RENT THEIR
PROPERTY TO A THIRD PARTY FOR
EVENTS. SO S. P. TWO FIFTY
SEVEN CLARIFIES THAT MUSEUMS
THAT RENT FOR SPECIAL EVENTS
WHERE IS THE EVENT PROVIDES
ACCESS TO THE MUSEUM'S
COLLECTIONS. EXHIBITIONS OUR
EDUCATIONAL OFFERINGS.
OFFERINGS THAT FURTHERS THE
MUSEUM'S CHARITABLE PURPOSE AND
BY GETTING THAT CLARIFICATION.
THEN IT WILL PREVENT. THEM FROM
BEING ASSESSED PROPERTY TAXES.
ON THE REVENUE RELATED TO THE
RENTAL OF THOSE EVENTS AND WTH
THAT WE'VE GOT TWO WITNESSES
LORI FOGARTY WHO IS THE
DIRECTOR AND CEO OF THE OAKLAND
MUSEUM OF CALIFORNIA. AND
CELESTE WALL TO SEE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF MUSEUMS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH INNER SCANNER WE'RE
NOT GOING TO GO TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE WE HAVE. TO
LEAVE WITNESSES WE DO WANT TO
LEAD WITNESSES NOW THAT WE HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON THE BILL-
IN WE'RE GONNA TURNER FIRST
OVER TO MISS FOGARTY FROM THE
OAKLAND MUSEUM OF CALIFORNIA.
MR PRETTY YOU HAVE UP TO THREE
MINUTES AND I'LL GIVE YOU
THIRTY SECOND PROMPT THE. FLOOR
IS YOURS AND WE WELCOME YOU TO
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
CHECKED HER MEMBER ID REQUIRING
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS LORI FOGARTY I'M THE
DIRECTOR AND CEO OF THE OAKLAND
MUSEUM OF CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE
THE SPONSORS OF SENATE BILL TWO
FIFTY SEVEN SH I WANT TO
ESPECIALLY THANK SENATOR
SKINNER FOR AUTHORIZING THE
FLOOD LEGISLATION ANSWER FOR
THE COUNTY ASSESSOR'S
ASSOCIATION FOR WORKING WITH
US. ON THE AMENDMENT SH OUR
MISSION AT THE OAKLAND MUSEUM
OF CALIFORNIAIS TO INSPIRE ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO CREATE A MORE
VIBRANT FUTURE FOR THEMSELVES
AND THEIR COMMUNITIES. MORE
MULTI DISCIPLINARY MUSEUM OF
CALIFORNIA ART HISTORY AND
NATURAL SCIENCES AND WE HOLD
THE STATE'S MOST COMPLETE
HOLDINGS OF CALIFORNIA'S
CULTURAL AND ENVIRONMENTAL
HERITAGE WE ARE THE LARGEST
CULTURAL ORGANIZATION BY BUDGET
SIZE AN AUDIENCE IN OAKLAND AND
WE'RE VITAL EDUCATIONAL
RESOURCE FOR SCHOOLS THROUGHOUT
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. SH IN THE
SELLING OF OUR MISSION WE OFFER
A BREATH OF PROGRAMMING WHILE
MAKING OUR LANDMARK FACILITY
AVAILABLE AT AN EVENT LOCATION
AND COMMUNITY HOUSE. S. C. TWO
FIFTY SEVEN WOULD PROVIDE
MUSEUMS WITHIN THE PRODUCTION
FROM TRAJECTORY OR PROPERTY
TAX. WHEN THEIR FACILITIES ARE
USED FOR ABOUT HOSTED BY
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
BUSINESSES COMMUNITY PARTNERS
OR INDIVIDUALS. MAKING ART
SPACES AVAILABLE TO OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS FOR EVENTS THE
FUNDAMENTAL PART OF THE MISSION
OF THE MUSEUM. THROUGH THESE
EVENTS WE INVITE NEW VISITORS
TO OUR FACILITIES AND MAKE
AVAILABLE OUR COLLECTIONS
EXHIBITIONS AND EDUCATIONAL
OFFERINGS. THEREBY SERVING AS
INFORMAL EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS BENEFITING
AUDIENCES OF ALL AGES AND
BACKGROUNDS. WE OFFER GROUPS
WHO ARE UTILIZING OUR SPACES
VARIOUS WAYS TO ENJOY AN ACCESS
OUR CULTURAL AND EDUCATIONAL
EXPERIENCES. AND IN MANY CASES
ABOUT SERVICE THE FIRST
INTRODUCTION TO A MUSEUM FOR
NEW AUDIENCES SH AS YOU ALL
KNOW MUSEUMS HAVE BEEN ONE OF
THE HARDEST HIT SECTORS BY THE
PANDEMIC MANY OF OUR
INSTITUTIONS ARE JUST NOW
OPENING AFTER MORE THAN A YEAR
CLOSER SH AND YET THEY ARE
REALLY ONE OF THE SAFEST PLACES
FOR GATHERING AND CONNECTIONS.
SHOWS WE BEGIN TO RE YEAH WE
FIRMLY BELIEVE MANY INDIVIDUAL
AND GROUPS WILL BE LOW FOR
PLACES TO GATHER AND TO SOCIAL.
THROUGH SP TWO- TWO FIFTY SEVEN
MUSEUMS WILL SECURE A PLATFORM
EXPANDING OUR AUDIENCES AND
EARNING URGENTLY NEEDED
REVENUE. WHILE PROVIDING VITAL
CENTERS FOR LEARNING
INSPIRATION AND HEALING FOR
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS AND
VISITORS. SO IN CLOSING I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR- VOTE ON THIS IMPORTANT
PIECE OF LEGISLATION. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MY PHONE THANK YOU MISS
FOGARTY GRATEFUL FOR YOUR WORK-
IN YOUR TESTIMONY HERE TODAY
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE GOING TOWARD
SECOND AND FINALLY WITNESS ON
TWO FIFTY SEVEN. HER NAME IS
CELESTE WITH THE WALLED HE'S
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
MUSEUMS MR WALLS YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES AND I'LL GIVE YOU
THIRTY SECOND PROMPT WELCOME
THE COMMITTEE. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU
TERRY MCGUIRE AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I APPRECIATE YOUR
YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION ON THIS
MATTER. OUR ASSOCIATION TWO
HUNDRED MEMBER MUSEUMS
REPRESENT ORGANIZATIONS OF ALL
SIZES DISCIPLINES AND
GEOGRAPHICAL REGIONS. IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN OUR
ASSOCIATION SURVEYED OUR
MEMBERS ABOUT PROPERTY AND
POSSESS VERY TAX. I'M DOWN THAT
THERE IS- VARIOUS WAYS IN WHICH
THE STATE LAWS BEING APPLIED
UNDERSCORING THE NEED FOR
CLARIFICATION. OUR POSITION IS
THAT NONPROFIT MUSEUM SHOULD
NOT BE A FACTOR PROPERTY TAX ON
AREAS OF THEIR FACILITY. THAT
ARE INTEGRAL TO THEIR
CHARITABLE PURPOSES AND IN
SERVICE TO THEIR COMMUNITY.
USING AREAS OF THE MUSEUM FOR
COMMUNITY EVENTS WHETHER
REVENUE PRODUCING OR NOT SHOULD
NOT COMPROMISE THEIR PROPERTY
TAX WELFARE EXEMPTION. AS SUCH
WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB TWO
FIFTY SEVEN AND THE INTENT TO
CLARIFY IN STATE LAW THAT
PROPERTY A MUSEUM MAKES
AVAILABLE FOR SPECIAL EVENTS
DOES INDEED FURTHER THE
MUSEUM'S CHARITABLE PURPOSE. AS
LONG AS ACCESS TO THE MUSEUM'S
COLLECTION EXHIBITIONS OR
EDUCATIONAL OFFERINGS IS
PROVIDED. THANK YOU THAT
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER WHILE THIS
GROUP WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT
YOU'VE JOINED US HERE TODAY- IT
LAYS IN GERMAN COMMITTEE WERE
NOT GOING TO BE LOOKING TO
THOSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO SPEAK. IN SUPPORT IN THE
CHAMBERS AT LET'S GO TO FIRST
PLEASE GOOD AFTERNOON.
CHAIRPERSON REQUIRE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE NICCOLO DELUCA
HERE DO A HANDFUL OF ME TO THIS
BEFORE I DO THAT I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE SENATOR SENATOR
SKINNER FOR OVER LEADERSHIP. ON
BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWO FIVE SEVEN THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF SCIENCES THE MUSEUM
OF CINEMA COUNTY RIVERSIDE ART
MUSEUM CHARLES M. SCHULZ MUSEUM
AND RESEARCH CENTER. HUMBOLDT
ARTS COUNCIL MORRIS GRAVES
MUSEUM OF ART CALIFORNIA INDIAN
MUSEUM AND CULTURAL CENTER AND
FINALLY THE SEVERANCE IS GOOD
MUSEUM OF MODERN ART SO THANK
YOU. MESSAGE LOOK AT THANK YOU
AND APPRECIATE THAT MR DELUCA
ALSO WAS ON A CALL TAT WE HAD.
LAST WEEK WITH SEVERAL MUSEUMS
ACROSS THE NORTH COAST
APPRECIATE- THE WORK ON THAT IS
WELL BUT LIKE TODAY TO SEE IF
THERE IS ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN. SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL HERE IN THE CHAMBERS.
PARENTS NINE WITH THAT GO TO
ROOM TWELVE. WE GOT CRICKETS IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE WE'RE NOT GONNA
BE GOING TO THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE WE'RE GONNA CHECK IN WITH
THE MATTER OFTHE MODERATOR. MR
MODERATOR IF YOU CAN PLEASE
QUEUE UP ALL THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT. OF SENATE BILL TWO
FIFTY SEVEN NOW. IN LATE GERMAN
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN
ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT. AT THIS
TIME WE DO HAVE ONE IN OUR
QUEUE. WE'LL GO TO NUMBER FOUR
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
HELLO THIS IS LUCY SALCEDO
CARTER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF NONPROFIT
CONSTRUCT A PORT OF THE BILL
THANKS SO MUCH FOR CALLING IN
THE C. VERY GRATEFUL. MR
MODERATOR THAT'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. AT THIS TIME THERE ARE
NO OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
MODERATOR WILL BE BACK WITH YOU
HERE IN JUST A FEW MOMENTS-
LAYS INJURED ON THE COMMITTEE
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE GOING TO
OPPOSITION OF SENATE BILL TWO
FIFTY SEVEN. WE DON'T HAVE ANY
LEAD WITNESSES LOGGED IN- IT
WOULDN'T HAVE ANY LEAD
WITNESSES LOG WITH THE
COMMITTEE SO WE'RE GONNA START
WITH OPPOSITION HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS IF YOU COULD PLEASE
STAND IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE EXCUSE ME IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TWO FIFTY
SEVEN. C.NO ONE STAND WE'RE
NOT GONNA GO TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE. NO ONE'S IN ONE ROOM
ONE TWELVE WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
GOING TO OR TELECONFERENCE
LINE. MR MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE QUEUE UP THOSE WHO ARE
IN OPPOSITION. OF SENATE BILL
TWO FIFTY SEVEN NOW. LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE TWO
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. AT THIS TIME WE DO
NOT HAVE ANYONE IN OUR QUEUE
THE DATE ANYWAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH AS THE MODERATOR WILL TALK
TO YOU IN JUST A FEW MOMENTS
FOR THAT TO GET A TURN IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE. LOOKS LIKE WE MAY
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR OSLO.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION BY CENTER
DR SO AND- THEN RISES IN BUSY
TODAY SHE SAID BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE SHE'S BEEN
CHAIRMAN AND HOW. BACK HERE TO
GO AND FIND SOMETHING DECENT
GROUNDS- IT'S ALWAYS GREAT TO
HAVE YOU IN COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU FOR ALL YOUR WORK. ALL
RIGHT SO WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THE FLOOR BY CENTER DRIVE SO
LET'S CONSIDER SKINNER FOR THE
CLOTHES PLEASE. THANK YOU
CHAIR- PREHEAT THE SUPPORT
CHRIS BETWEN FIFTY SEVEN. AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU AGAIN SOON
SKINNER SINCERELY- ON THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE- ESPECIALLY FOR
THE CULTURAL. COMMUNITY HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. MR
CANAL IS GOING TO READ THE
PROMOTION IN COLORADO. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR REQUIRE
I REQUIRE- A SENATOR NIELSEN.
NIELSEN IS SENATOR DRAWS A-
TERRAZZO HI SENATOR HERTZBERG.
SENATOR WIENER. THREE TO ZERO
IT CURRENTLY ENJOYS THE THREE
ZERO VOTE WE'RE GOING TO KEEP
pTHE BILL ON CALL THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR MINOR VERY GRATEFUL
FOR THIS GENTLEMAN THE MAN THE
MYTH THE LEGEND FROM THE COUNTY
OF ORANGE WE HAVE SENATOR MAN
HERE WHO IS VERY FOCUSED ON
RECOVERY FOR SMALL BUSINESSES
AND THOSE HARDEST HIT SCTORS
RESTAURANTS BARS HOTELS FOR
EXAMPLE PRECIADO THE WORKER
THAT ADD MISTER MAN IS PUT INTO
SP FOUR OH EIGHT A SENTIMENT WE
DO WANT TO LET YOU KNOW THAT
YOU ARE BI PARTISAN SUPPORT- IN
COMMITTEE HERE TODAY SO WE'RE
GONNA ASK FOR A TRUNCATED
STATEMENT. THE FLOOR IS YOURS
AND YOU WANT TO SAY THANKS TO
THE SERGEANT'S OFFICE FOR THEIR
WORK AS WELL SO MR MAN THE
FLOOR IS YOURS COULDN'T ANSWER
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
TO THE STAFF FOR WORKING
CLOSELY WITH OURS- WE ALL KNOW
THAT RESTAURANTS AND
HOSPITALITY BUSINESSES HAVE
BEEN HIT PARTICULARLY HARD BY
THE PANDEMIC AND WHILE THERE
HAS BEEN A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF RELIEF DIRECTLY FROM THE
FEDERAL AND STATE GOVERNMENTS.
MY BELIEF IS THAT IT'S NOT BEEN
ENOUGH FOR THIS PARTICULARLY
HARD HIT SECTOR SO WE'RE
OFFERING A MODEST TAX CREDIT
HERE AND I WOULD URGE ARRIVAL
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
MEANING IN DATA TRULY SENATOR
THANK YOU FOR YOUR FOCUS ON
THIS CRITICAL ISSUE IN THERE
ARE LITERALLY TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF BUSINESSES- THAT WILL
BENEFIT SO THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
SO WE DO HAVE TWO INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE PREPARED TO BE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL WE DO
WANT TO LET OUR LEAD WITESSES
KNOW THAT YOU DO HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN COMMITTEE
WE'RE GONNA ASK FOR TRUNCATED
WITNESS TESTIMONY. FROM BOTH
JULIE MOUNT ASKEY BALL AS WELL
AS SEAN VENUS LET'S START WITH
MISS MALINOWSKI BALL
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
HOTEL AND LODGING ASSOCIATION
JULIE WE WELCOME YOU TO
COMMITTEE. THE FLOOR IS YOURS
PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CARE MEMBERS JULIE IT OUT
ALL THE HAPPY. HOTEL LODGING
ASSOCIATION WHICH REPRESENTS
OVER SIX THOUSAND HOTELS MOTELS
AND LODGING PROFESSIONALS IN
CALIFORNIA. HE ACTUALLY IS HERE
TODAY TO SUPPORT SB FOUR OH
EIGHT- JUST A COUPLE POINTS TO
ADD TO THE AUTHOR'S. STATEMENT
YOU KNOW DEMAND FOR LODGING IN
CALIFORNIA IS ONLY SLOWLY
RETURNING. ROOM RATES REMAIN
DEPRESSED AFTER A YEAR IN WHICH
20% OF ALL HOTEL CLOSE. OVER
NINETY ONE THOUSAND EMPLOYEES
LOST THEIR JOBS WITH AN
ADDITIONAL THIRTY ONE THOUSAND
FURLOUGHED IN TWENTY TWENTY.
BUSINESS TRAVEL WHICH IS
APPROXIMATELY 38% OF ALL TRAVEL
STOPPED ALMOST COMPLETELY- IT
IS ALL EXACERBATED BY THE LACK
OF- THE FACT THAT CALIFORNIA
WAS THE LAST DAY THE NATION
SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO HAVE
MEETINGS ONLY JUST LAST MONTH
BUT THE DAMAGE HAD ALREADY
BEEN. ALREADY BEEN DONE. AS
BEFORE- IT WOULD HELP BOOST THE
RECOVERY FOR HOTELS ACROSS THE
STREET THEY ALLOW HOTEL
DRINKING THE FUNDS NEEDED TO
REHIRE LAID OFF EMPLOYEES. AND
ALLOW HOTELS TO WEATHER THE
COMING SLOW. SEASON WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. THIS ASK YOU BOTH
THINK SO MUCH FOR WORK IT'S
BEEN EVERY CHALLENGE TIME FOR-
YOUR MEMBERS VERY GRATEFUL
WE'RE NOT GONNA TURN IT OVER.
SKEWS ME TO SHINE VENUS WITH
VENUS SPIRITS HI MR VENUS WE
WELCOME YOU TO COMMITTEE THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. AT PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU- MY NAME IS
SEAN BE ASSIGNED OPERATE
MINISTER IT'S IN SANTA CRU.
THANK YOU SENATOR MEN FOR
OFFERING. THAT SUPPORT
LEGISLATION I AM IN SUPPORT OF
US BEFORE- EIGHT. BECAUSE IT
WILL SERVE AS A VITAL LIFELINE
TO MY BUSINESS AND THOUSAND
OTHERS SMALL BUSINESS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE- TO YOU
REALLY QUICK ABOUT IT- WE WERE
HIT HARD AND- TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY- WITH THE CLOSURE OF OUR
RESTAURANT- WE- RECENTLY JUST
OPENED IT UP- AND- AUGUST- OF-
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY- WE WERE
HIT WITH THE CDU LIGHTNING
FIRES QUICKLY AFTER. FORCING IT
TO CLOSE FOR TEN DAYS AND RE
OPENING WHEN AIR QUALITY IN
FIRE SUBSIDED. IN SEPTEMBER-
BECAUSE OUR BUSINESS. WAS NOT A
LEGACY BUSINESS FROM TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN WE HAVEN'T
REALLY BEEN ABLE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF ALL THE ALL GREAT.
FEDERAL AND STATE PROGRAMS- SO-
IF BEFORE WE WOULD BE VITAL FOR
OUR BUSINESSES ALL THOUSANDS OF
OTHER BUSINESSES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE- I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME MR RESPECTFULLY AFTER
I BROKE. MR VENUS THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR CALLING IN FROM SANTA
CRUZ TODAY WERE REALLY GRATEFUL
AND I KNOW HOW AWFUL A YEAR IT
HAS BEEN AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN ADVOCACY TODAY.
ALL RIGHT THEY SING GERMAN
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO THOSE
WHO ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
OH WAIT HERE IN THE SENATE
CHAMBERS WE'RE GONNA SEE IF
ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO RISE A BIT
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. SEEN AT NO
ONE WRITES FOR NOT GOING TO GO
TO ROOM ONE TWELVE LOOKING ON
OUR BIG BOARD HERE DO NOT SEE
ANYONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE WE'RE
NOW GOING TO GO TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE. WE'RE
GONNA ASK THE MODERATOR TO
PLEASE QUEUE UP ALL INDIVIDUALS
WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR OH EIGHT.
NOW GERMAN. TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB FOUR OH EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THE N. ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT. AS
THE MODERATOR IS BRINGING FOLKS
ON SUPPORT WE DO HAVE TWO BILLS
THAT ARE IN FRONT OF THIS FROM
SENATOR A CHILL ABODE I SAID
FROM THE SERGEANT'S OFFICE IS
ON IT AND- MISS OTOBO IS IN
ROUTE SO THAT'S GREAT NEWS MR
MODERATOR- PLEASE- LET'S GO TO
THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR AWAIT. ABSOLUTELY AND WE
WILL START WITH NUMBER FOUR
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. PRESTON
YOUNG FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE HERE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR CALLING IN TODAY LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NEXUS NUMBER FOUR FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF- SIX SIX
EIGHT- I FEEL LIKE PUBLICATION
NINETEEN WAS RAILROADED DEMAND
WE DID NOT AND BE A LOT OF
PEOPLE DID NOT UNDERSTAND AND
WE DID NOT HAVE ENOUGH TIME
ONCE WE FOUND OUT WHAT IT WAS
ABOUT. AN INTERNEE AND WE'RE
VERY GRATEFUL THINK YOU'RE AT
AT SO WE HAVE NOT TAKEN UP THE
BILL FIVE SIX SIX EIGHT YET
THAT SENATOR BATES WHAT WE DO
WE JUST HEARD THAT THERE IS
SOMEONE IN SUPPORTS AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CALL I DON'T MEAN
TO CUT YOU OFF MA'AM WE'RE ON
ITEM FOUR IS ZERO EIGHT RIGHT
NOW SP FOUR ZERO EIGHT. I MISS
A MODERATOR AT LET'S SEE
CHECKING TO SEE IF THERE IS
ANYONE ELSE ON OUR LINES IN
SUPPORT. OF SB FOUR AWAIT MR
MODERATOR. AT THIS TIME THERE
ARE NO OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE WITH
A CONTINUE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
AS A MODERATOR OR NOT GOING IT
LOOKED TOWARDS OPPOSITION
OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR AWAIT.
WE'RE GONNA START HERE IN THE
COMMUNITY IS EXCUSE ME HERE IN
THE CHAMBERS. SEE IF ANYONE
LIKE TO RISE IN OPPOSITION OF
SB FOUR OH EIGHT SCENE NO ONE
RISE YOU'RE NOT GONNA GO TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE THE LONELINESS.
ROOM HERE IN THE CAPITAL TODAY.
NO LOVE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WE'RE NOT GONNA GO BACK. TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE TO CHECK IN
WITH THE MODERATOR MR MODERATOR
WE'RE LOOKING FOR THOSE WHO ARE
IN OPPOSITION. OF SB FOUR AWAIT
NOW. ABSOLUTELY AND THOSE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE SP FOUR OH
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
ONE ONE ZERO FOR OPPOSITION. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE TWO IN THE QUEUE.
WE'LL GO TO NUMBER THREE FIFTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI KATIE
HARTMAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
UNFORTUNATELY IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ARLENE LET'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT IS
NUMBER FOUR FORTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ACCORDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN OPPOSITION
TO THE RECONSTRUCTION IN THE
ANALYSIS THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISS CORBIN MISS CORBIN IS WITH
US I THINK ALL AFTERNOON LONG
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH MISS
CORBIN AT THAT'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. AT THIS TIME
THERE ARE NO OTHERS IN THE
QUEUE TWENTY SEVEN. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER MODERATOR WE'RE
GONNA BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE- INTO OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ARE LOOKING FOR A
DEBATE CONVERSATION AND OR A
MOTION. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR RAZA WOULD LIKE TODAY
TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. HERRON SCENE NINE
EMOTION ON THE FLOOR BY CENTER
DRAWS A MISTER MAN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE PLEASE YEAH WE'RE
OBVIOUSLY IN THE MIDST OF AN
ECONOMIC RECOVERY WE'RE JUST
MONTHS AWAY FROM RETURNING
NORMALCY THESE BUSINESSES
REALLY CAN USE THE HELP. I ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU FOR YOUR
DEDICATION TO THIS CRITICAL
KERR CENTER MAN WE'RE REALLY
GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE HERE. AT
MR CANAL IS NOW GOING TO READ
THE FORMAL MOTION- AND THEN
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS. BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR MCGUIRE
HI. REQUIRE A SENATOR NIELSEN.
NIELSEN HI SENATOR DURAZO.
TERRAZZO ON A SENATOR HERTZBERG.
SENATOR WIENER. THREE ZERO
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A THREE ZERO
VOTE WE'RE GONNA KEEP THE BILL
ON CALL LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER MAN
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE TWO BILLS IT
IS NOW THE SOON TO BE THE
ACTUAL BOAT SHOW WE HAVE TWO
BILLS ITEM TWELVE IN ITEM
THIRTEEN- THE GOOD SENATOR IS
GOING TO FIRST PRESENT ITEM SIX
ZERO ONES THEN WE'RE GONNA GO
TO ITEM THIRTEEN SB SIX SEVENTY
FIVE I DO WANNA LET CENTER
CHILL BUT WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON THE BILL
SO WE'RE GOING TO ASK FOR A
TRUNCATED VERSION OF YOUR
STATEMENT PLEASE SINCE WE HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. WE ALSO
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
SENATOR UNTIL A BOGEY FOR ALL
OF THE WORK THAT SHE'S PUT IN
WE HAVE BEEN GOING BACK AND
FORTH ON THESE BILLS AND TRULY
AND TRULY APPRECIATE THE
COLLABORATIVE ENGAGEMENT THAT
WE'VE HAD WITH BOTH THE SENATOR
AND HER TEAM AT MADAME SENATOR
THE FLOOR IS YOURS AN ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE AGAIN YOU HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON BOTH
BILLS. THANK YOU SO MUCH-
MISTER CHAIR VERY EXCITED TO BE
HERE AND- I'VE ALWAYS BEEN AN
ADVOCATE FOR- COLLABORATIVE
IMBALANCE LEGISLATION SO WE CAN
COME TOGETHER AND WORK.
COLLABORATIVELY TO MAKE THESE
HAPPEN- WERE ON BOARD. I WOULD
LIKE TO THINK THAT YOU'RE IN
THE SOUTH FOR ALL THE HARD WORK
THEY HAVE PUT INTO BOTH OF MY
BILLS THAT ARE UP TODAY SB SIX
WANTED TO STEP TO THE RIGHT
DIRECTION TOWARDS AT LEVELING
THE PLAYING FIELD FOR FIRST
TIME HOME BUYERS. IT WOULD DO
SO BY ALLOWING HOMEOWNERS TO
SELL THEIR HOMES TO A FIRST
TIME HOME BUYER TO EXCLUDE
CAPITAL GAINS- OF THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR SINGLE
FILERS INSTEAD OF THE CURRENT
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS MAXIMUM. IS SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND FOR JOINT FILERS
INSTEAD OF THE CURRENT FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND MAXIMUM FOR
BOTH FOR. FROM THEIR GROSS
INCOME. AS WE KNOW CALIFORNIA
IS MADE TO THE HOUSING CRISIS.
THE MEDIAN PRICE OF A SINGLE
FAMILY HOME IN CALIFORNIA'S
OVER SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS WHICH IS MORE
THAN TWICE THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE. AN ANALYSIS DONE BY
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS SHOW THAT ONLY 20% OF
HOUSEHOLDS COULD AFFORD A HOME
AT THIS PRICE. 28% BECAUSE OF
THESE HIGH PRICES MOSTLY DUE TO
THE SEVERE LACK OF HOUSING
SUPPLY TO MEET INCREASED
DEMAND. ONE OF THE MANY
CONSEQUENCE OF THE SUPPLY
SHORTAGE. IS EXTREMELY
COMPETITIVE MARKET FOR
POTENTIAL HOME BUYERS.
ESPECIALLY BUYERS LOOKING.
BUYERS LOOKING TO PURCHASE
THEIR FIRST HOME. MMHM AND THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT I EXPERIENCED
PERSONALLY AS A REAL TORE. UP
MEANT THAT CALIFORNIA RANKED AS
A TOP THIS RATE IN THE NATION
PER PERSON HOME BUYERS
ACCORDING TO A REPORT DONE BY
BANKRATE .COM. THE REPORT NAMES
AND NUMBER OF REASONS FOR THIS
RANKING. THE RELATIVELY HIGH
COST OF HOUSING THE TIGHT
MARKET FOR AVAILABLE ENTRY
LEVEL HOMES. AND THE STRUGGLE
FOR THE MILLIONS FACING SAVING
FOR A DOWNPAYMENT.
HOMEOWNERSHIP IS THE BEDROCK OF
THE AMERICAN DREAM TOO MANY
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE SEEING THIS
REMOVED FURTHER FURTHER AWAY.
BUT IF THE REACH DUE TO THE
HIGH COST OF HOUSING AND THE
LACK OF OPPORTUNITY IN
CALIFORNIA. SIX A ONE IS JUST A
SMALL STEP THAT WE CAN TAKE
TOWARDS MAKING THAT DREAM A
MORE ATTAINABLE. FOR THE HARD
WORKING CALIFORNIANS DREAMING
TO TESTIFY TO TODAY IS IN
SUPPORT IS VANESSA CHAVEZ WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS CAN CAN SCOTT WITH THE
EAST VALLEY CESSATION OF
REALTORS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND MADAM SENATOR WERE
VERY GRATEFUL WE'RE NOT GOING
TO GO TO OUR- TELECONFERENCE A
LIVE LINE. FIRST CHECK IN WITH
MS CHAVEZ- MISS TRAVIS IT FROM
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
REALTORS. VANESSA YOU DO HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON THIS BILL
WE'RE GOING TO ASK FOR A
TRUNCATED STATEMENT I. AND SP
SIXTY ONE IN SUPPORT. OF IT AS
WE WELCOME YOU TO COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISS CHAIRMAN- MY
NAME IS AND I SAID LOOK A CHILD
IS REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORSAND
WE'RE PLEASED TO JOIN. SENATOR
CELLO BOW IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
ALIGN WITH MAJOR SEEKS TO
PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PROSPECTIVE HOME BUYERS TO MAKE
THEIR- DREAMS OF HOMEOWNERSHIP
MORE ACHIEVABLE BY PROVIDING
INCENTIVES TO EXISTING.
HOMEOWNER THIRTY REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR I
DON'T HONESTLY THINK. THAT ONE
THANK YOU MISS THOMAS THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU SO MUCH YOUR
PATIENCE TODAY SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT NO WE'VE BEEN A BIT
DELAYED WITH SOME OF OUR LINK
THE BILL SO THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO TURN THE
FLOOR OVER TO EIGHTEEN CAN
SCOTT. OUR SECOND AND FINAL
LEAD WITNESS ON SIX OH ONE HE'S
REPRESENTING THE EAST VALLEY
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS MISTER
SCOTT. YOU DO A BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT ON THIS BILL WE'RE
GONNA ASK FOR TRUNCATED
STATEMENT. THE FLOOR IS YOURS
SIR. VERY GOOD THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING TO YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
LET ME OPPORTUNITIES TO
CONNECT- MONIES KENT'S GOBBLE
REAL ESTATE BROKER. I THINK I
SPEAK FOR MYSELF- BUT ALSO BE
AFTER TWO THOUSAND OTHERS IN
THE EAST VALLEY ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS. SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB SIX A ONE- I MAY NOT BE AS
THAT WANT TO BE ENCOUNTERED
ECONOMIST BUT WHAT I AM IS A
REAL LIVE WORKING BROKER WHICH
MEANS THAT I WORK WITH BUYERS
AND SELLERS ON A DAILY BASIS
FOR A LIVING. IF YOU WANT L.
POLICY LEGISLATION TRANSLATES
TO REAL WORLD REALISTIC
EXPERIENCES IN THE TRENCHES
WITH REAL BUYERS REAL SELLERS.
I THINK I HEARD YOU SPEAK TO
PEOPLE LIKE ME- SP SIX OH ONE.
IS CONSEQUENTIAL- IN IN IN THE-
THE RESPECT. THEY WILL GIVE
WILL GIVE FOR TIME OPERA- FIRST
TIME BY. AND DEALING PARTIALLY
KNOWN FOR BEING THE MOST
AFFORDABLE METRO AREAS IN
CALIFORNIA FIRST TIME HOME
BUYERS WATCH HERE. FOR SO
LITTLE INVENTORY V- THE
MULTIPLE OFFER SITUATION IS
JUST IS INSANE- SELLERS DON'T
NECESSARILY CARRY BY SIR HOME
BUT THEY TEND TO GIVE A LOT OF
WEIGHT A LOT OF CREDENCE. TO
OUR EXISTING HOMEOWNERS WELL
HEELED BUYERS INVESTORS- WE
TEND TO HAVE A LOT MORE CASH IN
THE BANK- ELEGY FOR FIRST TIME
HOME BUYERS TO COMPETE. AND NOT
BE DISADVANTAGED BY THEIR- BY
THEIR MORE WELL HEELED-
COMPETITORS. I THINK I THINK
STANDS. STANDS TO BE A REAL
GAME FOR FIRST TIME HOME
BUYERS- I BELIEVE THE FIRST OF
ALL ARE THE FIRST LINK IN THE
CHAIN OF HOME SALES ALL ACROSS
OUR GREAT STATE AND I BELIEVE
IT'S CRUCIAL FOR US GIVEN EVERY
OPPORTUNITY WE CAN TO THE BEST
OF THEIR HOMES. THEIR FUTURES
AND THEIR SHOT AT THE AMERICAN
DREAM I APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY. I
JUST GOT I THINK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE GREAT PHONE AGAIN THANK
YOU FOR HANGING WITH US AND
YOUR PATIENCE. HERE COMING IN.
AND HAVING TO WAIT ON SP SIX A
ONE WE'RE REALLY GRATEFUL SIR.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE NOT GOING TO
CHECK IN HERE IN A COMMITTEE IN
THE SENATE CHAMBERS WE DO HAVE
AN INDIVIDUAL HAS RISEN TO BE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SIX ONE
PLEASE PROCEED SIR. SCOTT
KAUFMAN HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU SCOTT HAS BEEN WITH US ALL
DAY SO THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR
VERY GRATEFUL WE'RE GONNA SEE
IF ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX OH
ONE. SCENE KNOWN RISE YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO GO TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE SEE NO ONE RIDES ARE NOT
GOING TO GO TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE ROOM AT
TELECONFERENCE. LINE WE'RE
GONNA CHECK IN WITH THE
MODERATOR MR MODERATOR CAN WE
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANYONE IN
SUPPORT. OF SB SIX OH ONE NOW.
AND IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX OH ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. IN ONE ZERO FOR
SUPPORT. WE DO HAVE THREE IN
OUR QUEUE. WE'LL START WITH
NUMBER FOUR THIRTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS VICKY
CARPENTER WITH THE INLAND TO
EXPIRATION OF REALTORS I SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX A ONE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I KEEP NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT IS NUMBER
FOUR TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON IT'S JENNIFER
KENNEDY IN LA COUNTY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY
THAT'S GOT HER NEXT CALLER.
NEXT UP FOR THIRTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE FOUR THIRTY FOR
A YEAR IN COMMITTEE PLEASE
PROCEED. I'M HERE FROM THE KERR
COUNTY AND I SUPPORT- BILL AND
I APPRECIATE THE BIPARTISAN.
AND I APPRECIATE SENATOR JOE
ABOVE. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR CALL TODAY WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXUS FOUR SIXTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE FOUR
SIX FOR YOUR COMMITTEE PLEASE
PROCEED. LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
LINE MISTER MODERATOR. NEXUS
FOUR FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE RAPTORS YOUR- I
DON'T. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER. AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO OTHERS IN OUR
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE ALL RIGHT
MISS MODERATOR WILL BE BACK
WITH YOU HERE MOMENTARILY THAT
SIDE CHECK IN WE DON'T HAVE ANY.
LIED ABOUT POSITION WITNESSES-
ON THIS BILL RECORDER WITH THE
COMMITTEES ARE GOING TO CHECK
IN WITH THOSE WHO MAY WANT TO
RISE IN OPPOSITION HERE IN THE
SENATE CHAMBERS. PLEASE DO SO
NOW. SEE NO ONE RISER NOW GO TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE ROOM ONE TWELVE
IS ABSOLUTELY EMPTY WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GO TO OUR LIVE
TELECONFERENCING LINE. WE'RE
GONNA CHECK IN WITH THE
MODERATOR MR MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY INDIVIDUAL
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SIX OH ONE NOW.
IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SIX OH ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. TEN ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. BUT WE DO HAVE TO
IN OUR QUEUE. WE'LL GO TO
NUMBER FOUR FORTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AND ACCORDING TO CALIFORNIA TAX
REFORM ASSOCIATION HAPPY TO
JOIN YOU FOR THE AFTERNOON
OPPOSITION UNDER PRESSURE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH WITH THE
CORPSMAN WERE VERY GRATEFUL ALL
RIGHT LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THE NEXT WE'LL
GO TO NUMBER FOUR SIXTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL YES MY
NAME IS GREG THOMPSON AND THE
POTENTIAL FIRST TIME HOME BUYER
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS WILL BE
SOMETHING PRECIOUS FROM. THANK
YOU SO MUCH YOUR PHONE CALL SIR
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER. AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO OTHERS IN
OUR QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU MR MODERATOR
WE'RE GONNA BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEEFOR QUESTIONS
CONVERSATIONS OR EMOTION. MR
VICE CHAIR THAT A MOTION SIR.
BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH WE DO
HAVE A MOTION AC GENERAL
COMMITTEE EMOTION BY- THE DEAN
OF THE SENATE VICE CHAIR
NIELSEN. ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS CONVERSATION PLEASE
SENATOR AWESOME YES I JUST WANT
TO SAY I HAVE. TO WELL CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BILL- IN THAT WHAT IT
REALLY- HELP FIRST TIME HOME
OWNERS. I THINK THAT'S A BIG
QUESTION FOR ME AND I WOULD
PREFER THAT WE DO THIS THROUGH
PROGRAMS THAT ALREADY EXIST FOR
FIRST TIME HOME BUYERS- I THINK
OTHERWISE IT'S THIS THE
TAXPAYER THE SELLER OF THE
HOME. THAT WOULD BE GETTING A
WINDFALL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH VERY GRATEFUL. ALL
RIGHT. SEEING NO ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS COMMENTS- WE'RE GONNA
TURN IT BACK TO CENTER TO A
VOTE IF YOU WANNA PLEASE
ADDRESS THE CONCERN THAT WAS
ADVANCED BY CENTER DRAWS ABOUT.
HOW THIS IS SERIOUS THE
FINANCING- RECEIVING THE
FINANCING. THE INSURING THAT
FIRST TIME HOME BUYERS ARE
GOING TO BE ASSISTED BY THE
BILL AND THEN WE'LL TAKE THAT
YOUR CLOTHES THANK YOU SO MUCH
ENERGY OVER. THANK YOU SENATOR
R. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. I
WOULD BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO
ADDRESS THE QUESTION AND I
THINK IT'S A VERY GOOD QUESTION
IN IN HELPING TO UNDERSTAND THE
PROCESS IN WHICH THIS WORKS.
I'VE BEEN A REALTOR FOR
EIGHTEEN YEARS IN BROAD REALTOR
HELPING FAMILIES ACHIEVE THE
AMERICAN DREAM WHICH IN MY
OPINION IT IS THE BEDROCK OF
HOMEOWNERSHIP. THE REASON THIS
BILL HELPS. EIGHT GET FIRST
TIME ENTRY LEVEL OR FIRST TIMER
ENTRY LEVEL HOMEOWNERS INTO
HOMES. IS THAT WHEN A SELLER'S
LIST HER HOME. YOU FOR THE MOST
PART ESPECIALLY IN OUR AREA IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE. WE USUALLY
HAVE MULTIPLE. OFFERS AND- THE
MORE OFFERS WHAT WE DO AS
LEASING AGENTS IS THAT WE- SORT
OF PRIORITIZED OF COURSE
SELLERS ALWAYS WHEN MAXIMIZE
THEIR THEIR GAMES THEY'RE
LOOKING AT DATE OFFERS THAT
WILL NET THEM THE MOST MONEY.
SO WHAT HAPPENS IS CASH BUYERS
ALWAYS HAVE AN ADVANTAGE
BECAUSE THEY'RE QUICK AND
THEY'RE USUALLY NOT THAT THE
SELLER THE MOST MONEY. AND THEN
YOU HAVE SECONDARY TO THAT YOU
HAVE FINANCED BUYERS WHICH ARE
NORMALLY ARE FIRST TIME HOME
BUYERS WHO ARE USUALLY THE ONES
ARE HAVING TO FINANCE OUR HOME.
SO WHEN THEY'RE LOOKING AT
MULTILE OFFERS IF THE SELLER
HAS THE OPTION TO SAY OKAY WE
HAVE A CASH BUYER WHICH USUALLY
SOMETIMES EITHER OFFER AT. I'M
I'M GIVING YOU THE PRACTICAL
REAL LIFE SCENARIO HERE. THEY
WILL USUALLY GIVE FULL PRICE
OFFERS ON THESE HOMES. FINANCE
OFFERS FIRST TIME BUYERS
USUALLY WILL OFFER A LITTLE BIT
MORE OR ASK PRICE IF THEY WANT
TO COMPETE AT ALL. SO WHAT
HAPPENS IS WHEN YOU HAVE A CASH
BUYER AND HAVE A FINANCED
BUYER. WITH FINE AS BUYERS
SELLERS HAVE MORE COST ON THEIR
END TO USUALLY. END WILL NET A
LITTLE LESS SO WHAT THE
DISPOSITION IS THAT IF WE HAD A
PROGRAM SUCH AS THIS WHERE IT
ACTUALLY- GIVES THE ABILITY FOR
SELLERS TO NET MORE MONEY. BY
HAVING A HIGHER EXCLUSION FROM
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY TO THREE
HUNDRED FROM FIVE HUNDRED TO
SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
ACTION NULLIFIES SOME OF THAT
COST THAT COMES FROM ACCEPTING
A FINANCED BUYER. SO IT
ACTUALLY INCENTIVIZES THEM TO
SAY FIRST TIME HOME BUYER I
WANT THIS FAMILY SPECIALLY
SOMEONE WHO'S LIVED IN THE HOME
FOR A VERY LONG TIME. LOOKS AT
A YOUNG FAMILY COMING IN FOR
HALF AND YOU TEACHER COMING
INTO THE CITY AND SAYS OKAY WE
HAVE A- A FINANCED BUYER. BUT
YOU HAVE THIS IN PLACE. IN THEN
YOU HAVE A BUYER. IT USUALLY
WILL WILL INCENTIVIZE THE
SELLER TO CHOOSE A FIRST TIME
BUYER FIRST A CASH BUYER TO
GIVE THEM A LITTLE BIT OF AN
INCENTIVE TO SAY OKAY EVEN
THOUGH THIS WHOLE LEVEL US OUT
FINANCIALLY SO THAT THE FIRST
TIME BUYER CAN ACTUALLY HAVE A
CHANCE AT GETTING THAT OFFER
ACCEPTED. VERSES THAT ALL CASH
BUYERS SO THAT'S WHY IN THIS
INSTANCE OF ICE THE FIRST TIME
BUYER IT'S ACTUALLY A GREAT
BENEFIT. FOR OUR BUYERS TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE SOMETHING IN PLACE
BECAUSE IT ALLOWS ME TO COMPETE
WITH CASH BUYERS. THAT'S YOUR
QUESTION SENATOR RAWSON. THIRD
RESIDUE TO COMMENT. IF THANK
YOU FOR THE ANSWER THANK YOU SO
MUCH SIR ALL RIGHT I KNOW WE
WERE JUST IN THE CLOTHES THERE-
SO BRIEFLY PLEASE MR VICE CHAIR.
I JUST WANT TO ADD THIS WOULD
BE IN THE- RESPONSE TO MY OWN
MOTION HERE. OVER THE MONTHS
WHAT WE'VE BEEN SEEING IN THIS
REAL ESTATE MARKET. IS I'M
SORRY MR VENTURE DO YOU MIND
IF. THE WHAT WE SEE IN THE REAL
ESTATE MARKET IS. A SELLER WILL
PUT A PRICE. AND THEN THE
DESCENDANTS OF THEIR DESCENDED
UPON BY THOSE WHO WILL PAY WAY
OVER THE PRICE. NOW THAT KIND
OF PERSON THE CASE PERSON IS
NOT GOING TO BE. THE ONE WHO
HAS RESOURCES IT'S NOT GOING TO
BE THE FIRST TIME BUYER. WE
NEED AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
TARGETS THAT FIRST TIME BUYER
WHO'S STRUGGLING A LITTLE BIT.
AND WHO CAN'T KEEP BUILDING IN
THE PRICE UP FILL IT AND IF IT
FITS INTO THE MARKET. NICHE
RIGHT NOW. TO LIGHT A FIRE IN
REAL ESTATE AND DEVELOP
CONFIDENCE. IN THE COMMUNITIES.
ALONG THE OTHER THINGS THAT WE
HAVE GOT TO DO BUT I THINK IT'S
A GOOD BILL I STAND BY MY MOST.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER VICE
CHAIR SO LAZY AND WE DO HAVE
THAT MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY THE
VICE CHAIR. OF WE ARE GONNA
TURN IT OVER TO CHILL BOOK THE
SEARCH- BOOK FOR THE CLOTHES. I
JUST I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT.
WE CAN PUT THIS ON THE SELLERS
AT SELLERS ADVANTAGE BUT IT
TRULY IS A WAY TO BENEFIT AND
HELP AND ASSIST UP FIRST TIME
BUYER GET INTO AND HAVE. A
CHANCE. AT HAVING AT THEIR
OFFERS ACCEPTED. THE NICE XP
SPEAKS TO THAT FACT AS A
REALTOR FOR EIGHTEEN YEARS
HELPING YOUNG FAMILIES AND-
YOUNG. YOUNG PROFESSIONAL DOES
TRYING TO GET INTO THE MARKET
AND I CAN TELL YOU FROM
FIRSTHAND THAT THIS WOULD BE AN
INCREDIBLE PROGRAM. TO HELP OR
FIRST TIME BUYERS GET INTO OUR
HOME. AS MANY OF YOU KNOW I'M A
DAUGHTER OF IMMIGRANT PARENTS
AND FIRST GENERATION HERE AND I
CAN TELL YOU. BUY MY FIRST HOME
WAS THE MOST AMAZING.
EXPERIENCE THAT I'VE HAD AS A
AS A HUMAN BEING AS A AS A AS
SOMEONE WHO LIVES IN THIS
COUNTRY AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT
WHEN I BOUGHT MY FIRST HOME. MY
DAD CAME OVER AND WAS LOOKING
AT THE HOUSE AND WAS DOING
OUTSIDE OF OUR WINDOW AND JUST
LOOKED AT ME WITH TEARS IN HIS
EYES AND SAID. HI YOU ARE RIGHT
YOU MADE HE WAS SO PROUD THAT I
HAVE ACHIEVED THAT DREAM. SO
BEAR WITH ME AS I HAD.
ADDRESSED THE FOLLOWING
STATEMENTS IN SPANISH FOR THOSE
THAT CAN UNDERSTAND AND WHO ARE
SPYING TO BE HOMEOWNERS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND SORT OF THE
NIGHTLIFE OPERATE US BETTER
PERSONS WAS KIND OF SAD WHEN
USE THE GAS HE'S I DON'T KNOW
IF I NEED I DON'T ORDERS CABLES
AND COMPRESSIBLE IN MADAGASCAR.
OKAY SO LOW IS SIMPLY MET
BASSAM. APRIL YET THOUGH THE
LATEST ANOTHER C. SETTLE NO.
BEING THAT HE YEAH I LOVE
COMPETITIVE ENOUGH FOR PUTTING
THAT ON THIS. ARE YOU THE
BETTER LOOK AT A SWING IN THE
KENNEL. THEY SHOULD ONE USE THE
CASA. OWNING A HOME IN
CALIFORNIA. IS ONE OF THE-
DREAMS THAT EVERY IMMIGRANT.
HAS EVERY CITIZEN EVERY
CALIFORNIAN HAPPENS AND WE HAVE
TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN WITHIN
OUR POWER TO FACILITATE THAT
POSSIBILITY. AND THAT
OPPORTUNITY. IN OUR IN OUR
COUNTRY IN OUR IN OUR NATION.
HE'S JOINING ENSURING THAT THE
AMERICAN DREAM IS AVAILABLE TO
OUR FUTURE GENERATIONS. ON
BEHALF OF ALL THOSE WHO YEARN
TO HAVE THE ABILITY AND
OPPORTUNITY TO. ACHIEVE
HOMEOWNERSHIP I RESPECTFULLY
ASPIRIN I VOTE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH- SENATOR TO ABOVE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THAT PASSIONATE
CLOSE WE'RE GONNA GO TO MR NOW
WITH A FORMAL MOTION AND THE
ROLL CALL VOTE PLEASE. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR MCGUIRE
HI REQUIRE- A SENATOR NIELSEN.
NIELSEN A SENATOR TO ROOSEVELT.
SENATOR HERTZBERG. SENATOR
WIENER. TWO TWO ZERO THEY
CURRENTLY DO IS CHOOSE HERE BUT
WE'RE GONNA KEEP BILL ON CALL
AND WE'LL OF COURSE HAD FOLKS
ON AS THEY COME BACK TO
COMMITTEE THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER TOLD VOGUE WE HAD THIS
FINAL BILL BY MR TOLD VOGUE
WHICH IS S. P. SIX SEVENTY
FIVE- MISS OTOBO GOOD THIS TOO
HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT SO WE'RE
GOING TO ASK FOR A TRUNCATED
STATEMENT THAT YOU DO A
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN THE
COMMITTEE PLEASE PROCEED WE
WELCOME YOU BACK ON SP SIX
SEVENTY FIVE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR. HIS B. SIX ME BYE WITH
SIMPLY GIVE COUNTIES THE
OPTION. TO IMPLEMENT A PROGRAM
THAT TO ALLOW TAXPAYERS FOR
SIXTY TWO YEARS OF AGE OR OLDER
OR WHO RECEIVE SUPPLEMENTAL
SECURITY INCOME. TO PAY THEIR
PROPERTY TAXES IN MONTHLY
INSTALLMENTS. RATHER THAN INTO
LUMP SUMS. THIS WOULD BE A
VOLUNTARY PROGRAM FOR BOTH THE
COUNTY. AND THAT TAXPAYER. ALL
ABOUT OPTIONS AND CHOICES AS
EXISTING LAW STANDS NOW
PROPERTY TAXES ARE PAID INTO
ANNUAL INSTALLMENTS EXCEPT IF
AN ORDER IS IN DEFAULT. THIS
SYSTEM BECOMES PART PARTICULAR
PROBLEM WHEN HOMEOWNERS OWNED
THE PROPERTY OUT RIGHT ARE NO
LONGER PAYMENT MONTHLY
MORTGAGES AND HAVE NO IMPOUND
ACCOUNTS. THEY MUST RELY ON
THEIR OWN CASH MANAGEMENT AND
BUDGETING SKILLS TO AVOID
DEFAULT PENALTIES AND POTENTIAL
BURGLARS ENTERED RESIDENCIES.
THIS IS PARTICULARLY DIFFICULT
FOR TAXPAYERS RELY ON FIXED
INCOMES SUCH AS THOSE OVER THE
AGE OF SIXTY TWO AND TAXPAYERS
WHO RECEIVE SUPPLEMENTAL
SECURITY INCOME FOR DISABILITY.
SB SIX SEVENTY FIVE WILL ALLOW-COUNTIES TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
INDIVIDUALS LIVING ON FIXED
INCOMES TO PAY THE PRINCIPAL.
OF THE TAX DEADLY. THIS BILL IS
A TIMELY GIVEN. THE INCREASED
NUMBER OF OPTIONS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO COUNTIES THANKS TO
RECENT TECHNOLOGICAL ADVANCES
ONE SUCH OPTION IS A PROGRAM
DEVELOPED AT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
FINANCE COMMITTEE CALL THE EASY
SMART PAY. IN COUNTIES THAT
OFFER EASY SMART PASTE A
SOLUTION FACTORS CAN CHOOSE TO
CREATING EASY SMART PAY ACCOUNT
TO PAY PROPERTY TAXES MONTHLY
WITH A CREDIT OR DEBIT CARD OR
DIRECTLY FROM THE CHECKING
ACCOUNT. THERE'S NO COST TO THE
COUNTY ONCE AGAIN NO COST TO
THE COUNTY AND NO NEED TO
DEVELOP A NEW SYSTEM OR
SOFTWARE ONCE AGAIN. NO NEW
SYSTEM OR SOFTWARE AS EASY
SMART BAKING GENERATES
SEAMLESSLY WITH EXISTING
SYSTEMS. EASY SMARTPAY HAS BEEN
A PILOT PHASE FOR THREE YEARS
BUT SEE SACKS FINANCE COMMITTEE
SAY THEY HAVE THIS PROGRAM.
THIS PROGRAM TO. TO HAVE THIS
PROGRAM BE AVAILABLE TO ALL
COUNTIES IN THE NEXT FEW MONTHS.
JOIN ME TO TESTIFY SUPPORTERS
ALLEGRA FOURTEEN RT ON BEHALF
OF THE SPONSOR OF THIS BILL THE
CALIFORNIA SENIOR LEGISLATURE.
AND SCOTT KAUFMAN WITH THE
HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION ADDITIONALLY IN
ORDER TO HELP MEMBERS TO GET A
BETTER IDEA OF SOME OF THE NEW
OPTIONS THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
COUNTIES. ALAN FERNANDES THE
CEO OF CSX FINANCE COMMITTEE
WILL BE AVAILABLE FOR
INFORMATION ONLY WITNESS TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS MEMBERS
MIGHT HAVE A BETTER EASY SMART
PAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH AT
MADAME SENATOR. TO OUR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. WE DO
HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT BUT
WE'RE GONNA GO TO ALLEGRA.
FIRST FROM THE CALIFORNIA
SENIOR LEGISLATURE WE
APPRECIATEALL THE WORK BY THE
CSL. LATER THE FLOOR IS YOURS
WE WELCOME YOU TO COMMITTEE
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU AND
GOOD AFTERNOON I AM A LIQUOR
FORTUNE ARE YOU A MEMBER FROM
SAN FRANCISCO THE CALIFORNIA.
LEGISLATURE SH AND ORGANIZATION
SPONSORING THE BILL I WISH TO
EXPRESS MY VERY STRONG SUPPORT
FOR SB SIX SEVENTY FIVE- WHICH
HAS BEEN DESCRIBED BY- SENATOR-
SHOW ABOUT- AS THIS BILL IS FOR
RESIDENTS OR JUST LOOKING FOR
AN EASIER WAY TO PAY THEIR
TAXES AND WOULD NOT NEED A
PROGRAM LIKE THE CO. PROPERTY
TAXES PHONE MINT PROGRAM
OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS. UNDER
THE EXISTING PAYMENT. SYSTEM BY
ANNUAL PROPERTY TAX BILLS TO BE
A SHOCK TO THOSE HOMEOWNERS WHO
OWN THEIR PROPERTY OUT RIGHT
AND NO LONGER HAD THE IMPOUND
ACCOUNTS THERE IS A NEED NOW
FOR ANOTHER OPTION THAT WILL
HELP HOMEOWNERS SHOULD MORE
EASILY MANAGE THEIR PAYMENTS
NOT ONLY. FOR LOW INCOME OLDER
ADULTS BUT FOR ADULTS WHO ARE
CARING FOR AND HANDLING
FINANCES AND THEIR OLDER FRAIL
OR DISABLED PARENTS. SOME WITH
LIMITED COGNITIVE ABILITY. A
MONTHLY PAYMENT OPTION CAN ALSO
TAKE A HUGE BURDEN OFF
CONSERVATIVES REDUCE AREAS AND
REPRESENTATIVE PAYEES SERVICE
POPULATIONS CREATING A SYSTEM
WITH AUTOMATIC DEDUCTIONS THAT
HELP THEM EASILY MANAGE
PROPERTY TAX PAYMENTS. WE L.
MEMBER TO BE A- OF SUCH SYSTEM
THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS AND
FRIENDS HAVE RUN A SALAD
EXISTING BI ANNUAL. TAX PAYMENT
SYSTEM ON HER SYSTEM THAT CAN
LEAD TO INTEREST PAYMENTS AND
PENALTIES FOR DELINQUENCIES AND
DEFAULTS. AND EVEN PUT THEM IN
JEOPARDY OF LOSING THEIR HOMES
AND EVENTS THAT CAN BE
PARTICULARLY DEVASTATED ORDERED
CALIFORNIA TO KNOW WITH LOWER
INCOME. OTHER MEMBERS WHO HAVE
FINANCIAL POWERS OF ATTORNEY
FOR THEIR TRAIL PARENTS HAVE
TALKED THROUGH THE ADVANTAGES
OF SUCH A SYSTEM SH WHEN
MANAGING TAX PAYMENTS FOR THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS. THIS BILL ALSO
FURTHERS THE GOVERNOR'S MASTER
PLAN FOR AGING WHICH HAS CALLED
FOR AN AGING DISABILITY
FRIENDLY CALIFORNIA. THAT
ENABLES OLDER ADULTS AND ABLE.
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTY TREASURERS AND TAX
COLLECTORS OPPOSED THE BILL
BECAUSE IN THE END THEY'RE
MISTAKEN PERCEPTION THAT IF
ADOPTED THEIR COUNTIES WOULD
HAVE TO COMPLETELY UPGRADE OR
REPLACE THEIR EXISTING TAX
COLLECTION SYSTEM. BUT AT LEAST
SIX SEVENTY FIVE DOES NOT
REQUIRE ANY UPDATES OR
REPLACEMENTS BECAUSE THE BILL
IS SILENT ABOUT THE METHOD OF
IMPLEMENTATION. AS AN EXAMPLE
OF AN INEXPENSIVE ALTERNATIVE
SEATAC- FINANCE CORPORATION IS
CURRENTLY DEVELOPED A PAYMENT
GATEWAY PLATFORM. EASY SMART
PAY THAT ALLOWS HOMEOWNERS TO
SET UP AUTOMATIC MONTHLY
PAYMENTS WHICH THE DEBIT OR
CREDIT CARD OR DIRECT SECOND
THEIR BANK ACCOUNT E. EIGHTY
AGE. INTO A PROPERTY TAX
ACCOUNT THE ONLY EXPENSE
ACCOUNT NEEDS TO BE ADDING THIS
OPTION TO THEIR WEBSITE THAT
ADVERTISED THE AVAILABILITY
EACH TO THEIR RESIDENCE I
RESPECTFULLY AND STRONGLY URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB SIX SEVENTY
FIVE. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY WERE VERY
GRATEFUL WE'RE NOW GONNA TURN
IT OVER TO SCOTT KAUFMAN WHO'S
HERE WITH US IN THE SENATE
CHAMBER. UP IN THE BALCONY ON
BEHALF THE HOWARD JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION MR COP IN
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. AND HOW TO
RESPECT YOUR TIME IN THE
BIPARTISAN PORTABILITY BRIEF-
DESPITE PROP THIRTEEN. WE
CONTINUE TO CALLS EVERY YEAR
FOR ME TIRED SENIORS ON FIXED
INCOMES THAT ARE HAVING TROUBLE
PAYING THEIR PROPERTY TAXES.
WELL THE AMOUNT DUE WOULD
ULTIMATELY BE THE SAME IN
MONTHLY PAYMENTS THE FORMER
MANAGEABLE FOR THOSE. STROKE
FOLKS STRUGGLING TO PAY THE
LUMP SUM. S. B. SIX SEVEN FIVE
SIX. GIVE BOTH ME WILL GO AND
LOOK TAXPAYER I DID. OPTIONS TO
PAY THEIR TAXES IN A TIMELY
MANNER. AT A TIME IN A TIMELY
MANNER AND IT DESERVES YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER KAUFMAN VERY
GRATEFUL WE ARE NOW GOING TO.
CHECK IN WITH ANYONE ELSE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE THE FIRST
AND LAST NAME. POSITION ON THE
BILL AS WELL AS ORGANIZATION
REPRESENT HERE IN THE CHAMBERS
IN SUPPORT OF A SIX SEVENTY
FIVE. SCENE KNOWN RISE HERE IN
THE CHAMBERS WERE NOT GOING TO
GO. TO ROOM ONE TWELVE DC
THERE'S ANYONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. LOOKING LIKE THERE IS
NO ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE I
WOULD LIKE TO BE SPEAKING SIX
SEVENTY FIVE WE'RE NOT GOING TOWARD TELECONFERENCE LINE.
WE'RE GONNA ASK THE MODERATOR
TO PLEASE QUEUE UP PLEASE QUEUE
UP ALL THOSE IN FAVOR OF. SIX
SEVENTY FIVE NOW MR MODERATOR.
AND IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX SEVEN FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR
SUPPORT. DO YOU CURRENTLY HAVE
FOUR IN THE QUEUE. I'LL START
WITH NUMBER FOUR TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
SUSAN LONG AND BEING AN ELDERLY
PERSON I TOTALLY AGREE WITH-
WITH C. AS SHOWN I WOULD LIKE
IT TO PASS AND BE SIX SEVEN
FIVE AND I'M SURE THERE'S MANY
ELDERLY PEOPLE THAT WOULD BE
HERE RIGHT NOW IF THEY KNEW
ABOUT THIS BEING VOTED ON SO I
HOPE. EVERYBODY WILL PASS THIS
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
GOING TO GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
NEXT TO BE NUMBER FOUR THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS SUE O'CONNOR IN MADERA
COUNTY I SUPPORT SB SIX SEVEN
FIVE I APPRECIATE SENATOR JOE
BLOW. AND ALSO THE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN THE REFRESHING THING
TO SEE IN THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. NEXUS FOUR SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
IT'S JENNIFER KENNEDY IN LA
COUNTY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND FOR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT TO NUMBER FOUR
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE
FOUR ONE SIX HEARING COMMITTEE
PLEASE PROCEED. THEY'RE VERY
GOOD THEY'RE COUNTING IN FAVOR
OF. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
CALLING IN FOR MADERA COUNTY
TODAY WERE VERY GRATEFUL LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER. TEXAS
NUMBER FOUR SIXTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS BONNIE
FLOOR FROM THE OTHER SIDE OF
TOWN WE AND I AM A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF SB SIX OH ONE AND
SIX SEVEN FIVE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH STEPHANIE NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER MODERATOR THAT'S GO TO
THOSE WHO MAY BE IN OPCODES MAY
BE OPPOSED. TO SP SIX SEVENTY
FIVE WE DO HAVE ONE LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS THAT'S
CAROLING CAROLING REPRESENTS
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTY TREASURERS AND TAX
COLLECTORS MISSLING THE FLOOR
IS YOURS YOUR THREE MINUTES IT
WILL GIVE YOU THIRTY SECOND
PROBLEM. GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS LINE. THANK YOU
SENATOR I THINK I THINK YOU
MISTER CHAIR CAROLING AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY
TREASURERS AND TAX COLLECTORS.
R. POSE FOR A COUPLE OF REALLY
KEY REASONS I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
TODAY AND WOULD YOU RECOGNIZE
THAT IT IS NOT A MANDATE ON
COUNTY BUT ONLY AN OPTION.
ALTHOUGH IN REALITY IT'S NOT
REALLY AN OPTION BECAUSE
THERE'S NO FUNDING ASSOCIATED
WITH HOW CAN YOU SHED
EMPLOYMENT. ARE PROPOSED
PROGRAM FOR ELIGIBLE TAXPAYERS.
MOST IMPORTANTLY THE PROPERTY
TAX SYSTEM EVEN THOSE COMPANIES
ARE DECADES OLD AND ARE NOT
FLEXIBLE OR EASILY CHANGED. AND
WHEN THEY WERE WHEN THEY WERE
SENT OUT. THEY WERE SET UP TO
FOLLOW THE CURRENT GUIDELINES
WHICH ARE A FULL TIME TEN
DECEMBER TENTH INNING AND
THEY'RE SET UP TO COLLECT
POINTS HERE. AND THE PENALTIES
AND INTEREST THAT APPLY FOR
LATE PAYMENTS ARE SET UP TO
APPLY BASED ON THE TWO TIMES
PER YEAR PAYMENT SYSTEM.
ACCOUNTED THAT HAVE GONE
THROUGH THE PROCESS OF UPDATING
YOUR TALK TAX DOCTOR WHO SPENT
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
DO SO AND IT TAKES SEVERAL
YEARS TO DO IT RIGHT I CANNOT
EMPHASIZE. THE WALLET I NOTICED
THEY ARE YOU KNOW HAVING A VERY
LARGE TECHNOLOGY PROJECTS. THAT
INVOLVE PEOPLE MONEY HAS TO BE
DONE RIGHT AND IT'S VERY VERY
EXPENSIVE TO DO STORY COUNTY
DEPARTMENT SHARE THE PROPERTY.
TAX COLLECTIONS COLLECTIONS OF
FOUND. WE DON'T HAVE A- TO. THE
PROGRAM THAT BEING PROPOSED-
JOHN HUNT COUNTY DEPARTMENT
THAT RELY ON. THE BUDGET AND
BACK JUST LIKE EVERY OTHER. AND
I'VE YOU CAN. RIGHT ABOUT NOW
THEY'RE NOT WINNING AND THEY
HAVE TO GO UP AGAINST THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
PROXIMITY FURTHERMORE MAKING A
CHANGE TO MONTHLY BILLING WOULD
COST A HUGE AMOUNT OF MONEY TO
A VERY. SMALL POTENTIAL GROUP
OF TAXPAYERS GIVEN OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED AND ANALYSES. BEFORE
THE WAR TRYING TO KEEP TRACK OF
THEM MONTHLY BILLING. AND AN
EXCEL CHART- QUICKBOOKS IS NOT
THE SOLUTION THOSE ARE OFFLINE
MANUAL OPTIONS DON'T COMPORT
WITH OUR PLUG INTO THE PROPERTY
TAX SYSTEM. AND ARE MORE
VULNERABLE TO HUMAN ERROR WHICH
CANNOT HAPPEN GIVEN THE
CONSEQUENCE OF THE CAR. AND
SECONDLY THE BILLET RESTRAINT
APPEARS TO REQUIRE MONTHLY.
APPOINTMENTS TO THE TAXING
ENTITIES. ONE UNDERSTAND THE
CONCEPT OF THAT GIVEN THAT
HEATER PERSON'S NOT HERE COUNTY
AND WHAT THAT MEANS FOR THE
TAXING ENTITIES. AS FAR AS
WHETHER OR NOT THE SCHOOL OF
THE CITY AT THE SPECIALISTS ARE
ALL HAVE TO KEEP TRACK. OF WHAT
THEY RECEIVE MONTHLY BURST OF.
FIRE IN THE COMMUNAL
INSTALLMENT APPORTIONMENT. AND
YOU SHOULD TO LEGISLATURE ABOUT
HALF OF WHAT WE COLLECTED
SCHOOL MONEY. AT THE CRITICAL
TO BE DONE CORRECTLY. AND THEN
FINALLY IN THE BILL IN ITS
CURRENT FORM DOES CREATE SOME
QUALITY GAPS IT SHOULD BE
ENACTED ALONG WITH IT. AND
SPEAKING TO THE TEACHER IS
DOING OTHER THINGS. AND I
WASN'T EXPECTING AN EASY SMART
PAINT PROGRAM CAN BE REFERENCED
BUT IT'S WORTH NOTING IN THIS
CASE. IT DIDN'T REQUIRE
LEGISLATION TO BE ESTABLISHED.
THEY DO CHARGE TAX. EVERY MONTH
FOR THE SERVICE. AND BASED
REMAIN ACCOUNT IN THE TWO
ANNUAL INSTALLMENT. WHICH
BRINGS US BACK TO OUR ORIGINAL
CONCERN. WE ARE NOT SET UP FOR
THAT. THE REASON WE REGRETFULLY
OUR CLOSING ASPECTS NEED TO
HOLD THE MEASURE TODAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH AND MISS
FLYING APPRECIATE THE TESTIMONY
IS ALWAYS GOOD TO HEAR YOUR
VOICE HOPE YOU'RE DOING WELL
IT'S FAMILIES WHO WELL LET'S.
ACT NOW WOULD TURN TO WITH IT
BY THE WAY MISSLING IS THE
ONLY. REGISTERED LEAD WITNESS
IN OPPOSITION AND THAT IS WITH
THE COMMITTEE TODAY WE'RE NOT
GONNA LOOK TO THOSE WHO MAY BE
IN OPPOSITION HERE IN THE
SENATE CHAMBERS. HEARING SEEING
NO ONE WRITES WE'RE NOT GOING
TO GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE
CHECKING IN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
NOTHING'S HAPPENED IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WHICH MEANS WE'RE GOING
TO BE GOING TO OUR LIVE
TELECONFERENCE LINE FOR A CHECK
IN WITH THE MODERATOR MR
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE
UP PLEASE QUEUE UP. ALL THOSE
IN OPPOSITION OF S. D. S. BE
SIX SEVENTY FIVE. IF YOU WOULD
TO SPEAK IN UPPER. TO SB SIX
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. IN ONE ZERO
FOR OPPOSITION. AT THIS TIME-%
WE DO HAVE ONE IN OUR QUEUE TO
BE JUST A MOMENT OH GOODNESS
MODERATOR ONE REMIND FOLKS OF
THE PHONE NUMBER TODAY IT'S
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX
EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO COMING UP
HERE AFTER MR CHOI BOGUE WE'RE
GONNA BE GOING TO SENATOR
ALLEN. AT CENTER ALLEN IS
NUMBER. FIFTEEN IN OUR FILE
ORDER TODAY SP SIX ELEVEN THEN
WE'RE GONNA GO TO SENATOR
EDMUND WITH SP SIX FIVE SIX-
BUT WERE CURRENTLY IN
OPPOSITION ON SP SIX SEVENTY
FIVE. MR MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE
UP THOSE IN OPPOSITION. WE'LL
GO TO NUMBER FOUR TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE FOUR TWO
FIVE HEARING COMMITTEE PLEASE
PROCEED. ALL RIGHT GOOD TIMES
IS A MODERATOR ORGANIZED GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AT THIS
TIME THERE ARE NO OTHERS IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOU
SO MUCH AS A MODERATOR ALL
RIGHT PLACE GENERAL COMMITTEE
WE'RE GONNA SEE IF THERE IS A
QUESTION CONVERSATION MOTION IS
ADAM A MOTION MR VICE CHAIR. I
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE IF YOU CAN
GIVE AS MUCH ABOUT YOUR IF YOU
DON'T MIND JUST BRING YOUR MIKE
UP. I'M SORRY. NOT USED TO THIS
I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A DO FAST
MOTION MISTER CHAIRMAN. AND I
WOULD LIKE TO ALSO OBSERVE THIS
IS AN INTERESTING COMBINATION
OF SUPPORT FROM THE RETIRED
CITIZENS. AND FROM HOWARD
JARVIS TAXPAYERS. IN SOME OF
THE WORDS THAT I'VE HEARD HERE
JUST OF LATE. REMIND ME OF
PROPOSITION THIRTEEN DEBATE OF
MANY MANY DECADES AGO. IT
SOUNDS THE SAME NOW THE SAME
OLD SAME OLD WELL IT DIDN'T
WORK THEN IT WILL NOT WORK NOW
AND IT WILL NOT BE HELPFUL NOW.
TO GO BACK TO THOSE BAD OLD
DAYS. THIS IS A NEW TIME. IT'S
AN UNCERTAIN TIME BUT THESE
WERE MEASURES THAT WE'VE HAD
BEFORE US HERE TODAY ARE GOING
TO HELP BRING SOME CERTAINTY
AND CALM AND HOPE. AND THAT'S
WHAT OUR CITIZENS NEED MOST OF
ALL RIGHT NOW IS SOME HOPE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER VICE
CHAIR. OF THAT MOTION ON THE
FLOOR BY THE VICE CHAIR. IT IS
YOUR DISCUSSION OR DEBATE FROM
THE COMMITTEE. KAREN C. NINE I
JUST WANT A BEFORE YOU GO TO
THE GOOD SENATOR FOR THE
CLOTHES LOOK I HAVE GREAT
RESPECT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION ACCOUNT KIND OF
TREASURERS AND TAX COLLECTORS
BUT I JUST WANT TO BE OPEN
ABOUT THIS. NUMBER ONE THIS IS
AN OFTEN DEAL AN OPT IN BELL.
NUMBER TWO. IF A NEW SYSTEM
NEED TO BE PURCHASED IT WOULD
NEED TO BE IN COLLABORATION
WITH THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
TYPICALLY IN MOST FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES. OVERSEES THE BUDGETS
OF ASSESSORS TAX COLLECTORS AND
OTHER AGENCIES AND IF THEY
CAN'T COME TO AN AGREEMENT ON
THAT BUDGET DIDN'T. THEY WON'T
IMPLEMENT THE MONTHLY. TAX
PAYMENT SO I THINK IT'S
INCREDIBLY SAY BILL IT MAKES
SENSE HE GIVES TAXPAYERS AN
OPTION. AND JUST BEING HONEST
ABOUT IT IT'S AN OPT IN BILL
ALL I TURN IT OVER. TO THE GOOD
SENATOR FOR HER CLOSE. I JUST
WANT TO SAY PLEASE JOIN ME IN
GIVING COUNTIES AND SENIORS
OPTIONS TO PROVIDE A PROPERTY
TAX SYSTEM THAT IS MORE
EFFICIENT AND WORKABLE FOR
THOSE TAXPAYERS WERE STRUGGLING
TO MAKE ENDS MEET ON FIXED
INCOMES. I RESPECTFULLY AND
HUMBLY ASK FOR AND I VOTE THANK
YOU SO MUCH SENATOR UNTIL A
BOOK WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR BY THE VICE CHAIR MISTER
NOW IF YOU CAN PLEASE READ THE
FORMAL MOTION. YOU CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS DO YOU PASS
TO THE SENATE FOR SENATOR
MCGUIRE HI REQUIRE- A SENATOR
NIELSEN. NIELSEN ON A SENATOR
DURAZO TORONTO HI SENATOR
HERTZBERG. SENATOR WIENER.
WIENER HI FOUR ZERO FOUR ZERO
VOTE LADIES AND GENTLEMAN
THAT'S A BIPARTISAN GOVERNING
KEEP THAT BILL OPEN AND SEE
WHAT THE MAJORITY LEADER WOULD
LIKE TO DO TO BE ABLE TO
POTENTIALLY ADD ON. WITH THE
JOB OF SAFE TRAVELS HOME WE'LL
SEE YOU NEXT WEEK THANK YOU SO
MUCH. ALL RIGHT. WE KNOW THAT
SENATOR ALAN HAS MEETINGS BACK
IN HIS HOME DISTRICT. THIS
EVENING ANY AS A FLIGHT TO
CATCH SO- WE ARE GOING TO TURN
THE FLOOR OVER. TO SENATOR
ALLEN ON SB SIX ONE ONE. I'D
SIT AROUND AND DO WANT TO LET
YOU KNOW THAT YOU HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON THIS BILL
THE FLOOR IS YOURS IN YOUR OWN.
MARCH MADNESS TO SHARE IT WITH
THAT IN MIND I'D LIKE TO ACCEPT
THE CLARIFYING AMENDMENT IS
ASCRIBED IN COMMENT SIX OF THE
ANALYSIS. I SAY THAT THIS BILL
WOULD ALLOW ADDITIONAL CREDIT
TO THE TECH CONFERENCE VTV IN
FILM TAX CREDIT THREE POINT NO
PROGRAM FOR- BASICALLY TO HELP
WITH TRAINING AND OUTREACH
TARGETING UNDER REPRESENTED
COMMUNITIES. THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA TO HELP OPEN UP OUR
FILM INDUSTRY. A LITTLE BIT
MORE SO WITH THAT IN MIND I
HAVE VICTORY YES FROM MY AUNT'S
SIAN AND RECITED STRUGGLING. ON
THE PHONES AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH CENTER ALLEN ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT WE HAD
TO LEAD WITNESSES AGAIN I WANT
TO LET A LEAD WITNESSES NOW WE
HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
HEARING COMMITTEE FOR THIS BILL
LET'S START WITH VICTOR REYES
FROM CHI FROM- I HAD C.
ACCOUNTS A LOCAL FORTY FOUR MR
RAISE THE FLOOR. IS YOURS YOU
HAVE UP TO THREE MINUTES. HELLO
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
VICTORIA AND I'M A UNION
BUSINESS REPRESENTATIVE FOR I.
OUT TO LOCAL FORTY FOUR.
APPRECIATED PROPERTY CRAP. I AM
ALSO TRAINING AMID YOUR
EDUCATION DIRECTOR FOR MY
LOCAL. WE ARE ONE OF THE
LARGEST BIOPSY LOCALS IN
HOLLYWOOD WITH A BIT OVER SIX
THOUSAND ACTIVE MEMBERS WORKING
IN TELEVISION FEATURE FILM
COMMERCIAL CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS. I AM HERE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX ELEVEN THANK
YOU THANK SENATOR ALLEN FOR
INTRODUCING THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION. TO THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE. MEMBERS FOR ALLOWING
ME TO SPEAK TODAY. FOR ME
DEADLY. RAID HOTEL ALSO
FORTUNATE TO ATTEND WORKSHOP
CLASSES IN HIGH SCHOOL- WINDOW
ART PROGRAMS WERE AVAILABLE. IN
THE ALLEY UST. BEND THEM TO
PURSUE A DEGREE IN BOTH
CARPENTRY CABINET MAKING
PROGRAMS FROM. LA TRADE TECH
COLLEGE RIGHT OUT OF HIGH
SCHOOL. WHEN I BE A ONE. I CAME
INTO THE BUSINESS I HAD NO
CONTACT OR RELATIONSHIP OR
KNOWLEDGE ABOUT HOW TO GET IN
THE BUSINESS BUT I. WOULD BY
CHANCE BE CONSTRUCTION CORPS
LEADERS SAW MY WORK AND
DISCOVERED THAT I HAD TRADE
TECH TRAINING AND THE SKILL SET
AND COLBY SAID JOB WITHIN A
WEEK. FROM THATJOB I HAVE
WORKED ON OVER TWENTY FIVE TV
AND MOTION PICTURE PROJECTS.
BUT BACK THEN I DIDN'T SEE A
LOT OF DIVERSITY. FOR MANY THAT
THAT WOULD GIVE ME IT WAS TOUGH
TO GET THE REQUIRED DUE TO GET
INTO THE UNIT. PEOPLE OFTEN.
ASK ME HOW DO I GET IT. BUT I
WOULD BET. AND DAYS THE LAMPS
COULD DO VERY DIFFERENT. NOW I
LEARNED ISSUES SHOULD I SEE
PEOPLE OF ALL DIVERSE
BACKGROUNDS COULD BE SWORN IN
AS MEMBERS. A FEW STUDIOS
PRODUCTION COMPANIES COMMERCIAL
PRODUCERS. COMING TO US LOOKING
FOR A WORKFORCE THAT REFLECTS
BACK COMMUNITY. TWENTY ONE
REASON FOR THE SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES THAT WE HAVE TRAINING
PROGRAMS LIKE CAREER PATH
HOLLYWOOD DPR. LEAVE AND GROUPS
OF SIMILARLY GROUNDED PROGRAMS
ARE DEDICATED. TO PROVIDING
YOUNG PEOPLE FROM UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE SCREEN.
SKILL SET AND THE MENTORSHIP.
OPEN DOORS AND OPPORTUNITIES
WHAT ARE THESE PROGRAMS SO
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THEY HELP
YOUNG PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND AND
BE READY FOR WHAT IT MEANS. TO
HAVE BEEN THE SCENES CRAFT SHOP.
THIRTY SECONDS WELL THE JOB.
OKAY EIGHTY SIX ELEVEN POINT
BECAUSE IT BUILDS ON THE
SUCCESS OF THE PROGRAM
RECOGNIZES THAT THE LONG TERM
GOAL IS TO INCREASE ADVERSITY
TO CREATE HIGHLY TRAINED AND
SKILLED WRKFORCE FROM FROM
CALIFORNIA MORE MOST
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITY AND
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
BACKGROUNDS TO INCENTIVIZE
MOTION PICTURE PRODUCTION TO
HIRE THOSE WOULD INCLUDE A
COLLECTION EXPANDS STYLING OUR
GOAL NOT ONLY FOR THE FIRE IN
THE STREETS BUT IT WILL ALSO
ENCOURAGE AND PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SURROUNDING
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU FOR
GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE MY STORY. THANK YOU SO
MUCH AS THE RATES WERE REALLY
APPRECIATIVE THAT YOU CALLED IN
YOUR ABILITY TO SHARE THAT
STORY- VERY INSPIRING TRULY AND
REALLY GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AND ADVOCACY TODAY
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE GOING
OVER SHOT STRIBLING WHO'S GONNA
BE OUR FINAL LEAD WITNESS YOU
HAVE UP TO THREE MINUTES THERE
IS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL IN COMMITTEE LET'S TURN T
OVER. TO A SHOT GOOD AFTERNOON
SIR YOU'RE IN COMMITTEE. HELLO
CAN YOU GUYS HEAR ME YEAH
YOU'RE COMING IN LATE AND CLEAR
SIR PLEASE PROCEED. ALL RIGHT-
MY NAME SHOT STRIBLING I'M A
RECENT GRADUATE OF HOLLYWOOD
THE P. R. AN ACTIVE MEMBER. OF
LOCAL AT AND- TO BE HONEST WHO.
THEY HAVE EXCEEDED EXPECTATIONS
AND THAT IT IS SOMEWHAT OF AN
UNDERSTATEMENT- BORN AND RAISED
IN SOUTH CENTRAL LOS ANGELES-
AS A PERSON OF COLOR A LOT OF
EXPECTATIONS ARE PUT ON YOU.
WHAT YOU WANT DON'T BE IN WHICH
YOU WILL AND WHAT YOU WILL BE
ENTERTAINED FELLOW CAME DESPITE
MY GROUNDING. IN SOUTH LA I WAS
ABLE TO ABOVE- TO RISE ABOVE
THOSE THOSE EXPECTATIONS. AND-
HI- I WENT TO GRADUATE MANY ARE
QUITE WHO- WENT FROM THERE TO
EL CAMINO COLLEGE AND GRADUATED
FROM BOISE STATE UNIVERSITY
WITH A DEGREE. AND COMMUNICATE
WHAT INTERPRETED MEDIA AND
HONESTLY AFTER I GRADUATE I
DIDN'T REALLY HAVE A CLEAR
PATH. AND I HAD A FRIEND PRETTY
MUCH TELL ME HEY MAN WE NEED TO
GET IN HOLLYWOOD THE PRD GET
INTO THE MOTION PICTURE
BUSINESS. AND I DID IT YOU KNOW
I HAD I HAD IN I WAS IN AND OUT
OF DIFFERENT JOBS ALONG THE WAY
TRYING TO FIND MY WAY IN I WAS
A CORRECTIONAL OFFICER AT ONE
POINT. AND I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT
TO DO FOR ME SO I END UP
JOINING THE PROGRAM AND IT
CHANGED MY LIFE- TO BE HONEST
THEY GAVE ME A CLEAR PATH ON
WHAT. I CAN DO AND IT AND IT IT
GAVE ME THAT LEAP OF FAITH SO
TO BE HONEST WITH YOU. THE
PROGRAM HAD GIVEN ME- TOOLS
ACCEPTED DON'T PROVIDE A CLEAR
PATH IN THE THING. AND THE
ALLOWED ME TO WORK ALONGSIDE
PROFESSIONALS AND GAIN THE
SKILLS. THAT WILL FOLLOW ME
FOREVER- AND I WANTED THEM BUT
BECAUSE THE MASS INCARCERATION
POPULATED I HAVEN'T BEEN IN THE
JUDICIAL SYSTEM- I'VE BEEN ON
THE OUTSIDE OF IT BUT- FOR THE
FOR MY PEERS. THAT WORK WITH
ME. IT CHANGED THEIR LIVES THE
DAY IS GIVING THEM A SECOND
CHANCE AT LIFE TO TAKE HERE NOT
ONLY THEMSELVES BUT THEIR
FAMILIES IN THAT THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING THREE NOT THE
FAMILY. YEAH YOU'RE RIGHT
SECOND THERE. ALL RIGHT IN.
pPLAQUE TO- I FEEL I FEEL
COMFORTABLE I FEEL EMPOWERED
AND IT IT IT IS VERY DIVERSE
COMMUNITY AND WITH THAT MOST
MOSTLY IMPORTANT IN IN IN IN
OUR UNION IN IN OUR MOTION
PICTURE BUSINESS IF I HAD THAT
OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU GUYS FOR
YOUR TIME I APPRECIATE IT THIS
IS TROUBLING THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR STORY TODAY- IN FOR
ALL YOUR WORK SIR THANK YOU FOR
CALLING IN THE COMMITTEE WERE
REALLY GRATEFUL. ALL RIGHT
THAT'S OUR SHOTS IN THE IN.
GRADUATE OR PROUD TO AS WELL
MAKING THAT THE GOLDEN STATE
PROUD THAT WE ARE NOW GOING TO
LOOK TO THOSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS. WE
HAVE MISS MCKINNY MISS MCANALLY
AT ESSENTIALLY HAS A CHEER UP
IN THE BALCONY HERE TODAY MISS
MCKINLEY THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MR CHAIR AND ON
BEHALF OF THE HOLLYWOOD CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE WE ARE ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL SIX
ELEVEN THANK YOU ALL RIGHT IT'S
GOOD TO SEE MISTER KELLY THANK
YOU SO MUCH SIR RIGHT NOW I SEE
NO NO IT'S RIGHT HERE IN THE
CHAMBER WE'RE NOT GONNA GO TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE. CHECK IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE CRICKETS CRICKETS IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE WERE I SEE NO
ONE RIDES ARE NOT GOING TO GO
TO A TELECONFERENCE LINE SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE WHOSE ACTIVISTS
BEGIN SUPPORT OF SB SIX ELEVEN.
ON OUR TELECONFERENCE LINE MR
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE
UP ANYONE IN SUPPORT. OF SB SIX
ELEVEN NOW. IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
ELEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THE N. ONE ZERO FOR
SUPPORT. WE DO HAVE ABOUT
TWENTY IN OUR QUEUE. HELLO SIR
WHAT NUMBER FOUR FIFTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
JENNIFER MALLEY BUT THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER. NEXUS NUMBER FOUR
SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU AGAIN MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS JAMES THEREAFTER WITH
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL
LABOR'S STRENGTH SUPPORTED OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PHONE CALL HERE TODAY
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
NEXUS FOUR FORTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON SHANE
DAWSON ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS AND SAG AFTRA IN
SUPPORT. WE THINK OF. THANK YOU
SO MUCH AS CURRENT ECONOMIC
PLEASE. NEXT IS THREE EIGHTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I THANK YOU MR
CHAIR- I'LL ADD THAT THE VICE
PRESIDENT TEAMSTERS LOCAL THREE
NINETY NINE AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR PHONE CALL LET'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER. NEXUS FOR
SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MISSY JOHNSON WITH ME
OFF THE MARK MARK CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE DIRECTORS GUILD
OF AMERICA AMERICA IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH. LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. NEXT IS FOUR EIGHTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JUNIOR AND
THE ASSOCIATE NATIONAL
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE ART
DIRECTORS GUILD IATSE LOCAL
EIGHT HUNDRED REPRESENTING FROM
WORKERS UP AND DOWN THE STATE
AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
YOUR PHONE CALL HERE TODAY
THAT'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
NEXUS FOUR SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES TOM DAVIS
BUSINESSMAN DRIED HISTORY LOCAL
EIGHTY STRONG SUPPORT AND I
WANT TO THANK SENATOR ALLEN FOR
BRING IN THE SPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE CALL
TONIGHT. IT'S GOT A NICE CAR.
NEXUS THREE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
TIME PLEASE ANSWER MODERATOR.
ABSOLUTELY NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE FOR SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I THINK CARMODY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA OUT TO COUNCIL
IN THE ENTERTAINMENT UNION
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH KATHY PRE
SHEET THAT THAT'S GOING TO OUR
NEXT CALLER. SIX IS FOUR NINETY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. WITH
YOUR CAREFULLY LAID PLANS WITH
YOU AGAIN ON BEHALF OF THE
MOTION PICTURE ASSOCIATION AND
STRONGSUPPORT. THANK YOU MR
MEMBER VERY GRATEFUL LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER. NEXT TO THE
FOUR NINETY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS GREGORY
IS BUSINESS REPRESENTATIVE
SECRETARY OF IATSE LOCAL SEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT LEADING FROM
HOLLYWOOD IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY THAT'S
GOING TO OUR NEXT CALLER. NEXUS
FOR NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN- LESLIE
SIMMONS FIELD REP FOR IATSE
LOCAL EIGHT THIRTY NINE
ANIMATION GUILD AND STRONG
SUPPORT AT THE SIX ELEVEN THANK
YOU SO MUCH LESS DEPRECIATE
THAT NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXUS
FOUR EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THE SCOP IN OUR
BUSINESS REPRESENTATIVE FOR
IATSE LOCAL SIX NINE FIVE. IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SIX ELEVEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
SCOTT NEXT CALLER PLEASE. SIX
OF THE FOUR NINETY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON JOANNE
DESMOND I HE IS THE LOCAL
SIXTEEN THEATRICAL STAGE
EMPLOYEES THE CHANCE TO GO
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
JOANNE NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT
TO THE FOUR NINETY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MISTER CHAIRMAN
ALEXANDER OUR BUSINESS MANAGER
FOR LABORERS LOCAL SEVEN TWENTY
FOUR IN A HOLLYWOOD MOVIE
SUPPORTERS FROM THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE CALL NEXT
CALLER. WHEN I GO TO NUMBER
THREE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THAT AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR MADISON DOLLY ON BEHALF
OF THE ASSOCIATION OF TALENT
AGENTS IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
ELEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH YOUR PHONE CALL NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT WILL BE
FIVE OH ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MODERATOR MR CHAIRMAN
OF THE COMMITTEE JEREMY APATHY
STATE BUILDING TRADES COUNCIL
REPORT. THANK YOU SMITH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. AT THIS TIME
THERE ARE NO OTHERS IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOU
SO MUCH AS A MODERATOR ALRIGHT
WE'RE GOING TO NOW GO TO THOSE
WHO MAY BE OPPOSED TO THE BILL-
S. P. SIX ONE ONE. WE DO NOT
HAVE AN OFFICIAL LEAD WITNESS
RECORDED IN COMMITTEE TODAY WE
WILL START WITH OPPOSITION HERE
IN THE CHAMBERS SEE NO ONE
WRITES WE'RE NOT GONNA GO TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE NO ONE IS
RISING ROOM TWELVE IN
OPPOSITION OF SIX ELEVEN WE'RE
NOT GOING TO BE GOING TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE CHECKING IN
WITH- ONE BUSY INDIVIDUAL TODAY
THAT'S OUR MODERATOR MR
MODERATOR. CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE
UP FOLKS WHO ARE IN OPPOSITION
OF SB SIX ELEVEN NOW. AND IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE SP SIX
ELEVEN. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
DO HAVE ONE IN THE QUEUE. WE'LL
GO TO NUMBER FOUR THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS SUE
O'CONNOR FROM ADERA COUNTY AND
I AM OPPOSED TO THIS BECAUSE OF
THE SPECIAL INTERESTS I'D LIKE
TO SEE THIS BEING GIVEN TO
OTHER INDUSTRIES BESIDES THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY. THANKS
SO MUCH TO APPRECIATE THAT NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. AT THIS TIME OR
NO OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE. ALL
RIGHT BASINGER THE COMMITTEE
WERE GONNA BE BRINGING IT BACK
I DO SEE IF THERE'S A MOTION ON
THE FLOOR I SEE A MOTION BY
SENATOR WIENER THANK YOU SO
MUCH- SO MOVED- SCENE NO ONE
ELSE RISE WE'RE GONNA TURN IT
OVER TO CENTER EIGHT MEN ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR ALLEN AS WE
SAID EARLIER. HE HAS A VERY
IMPORTANT MEETING BACK IN THE
HOME DISTRICT HAS TO CATCH A
FLIGHT TO BE BACK FOR THAT
MEETING CENTER AGAIN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS IT'S
ESSENTIAL THAT CALIFORNIA'S
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY LEAD BY
EXAMPLE SP SIX ELEVEN BUILDS
UPON HAT SINCERE COMMITMENT TO
TRAIN AND EMPLOY MORE
CALIFORNIANS FROM
UNDERREPRESENTED COMMUNITIES.
FOR THE SKILLED JOBS THAT COME
COMPRISED MOTION PICTURE AND
TELEVISION PROTECT PROTECT
PRODUCTION AND DOES THIS
WITHOUT SPENDING ADDITIONAL
TAXPAYER DOLLARS I ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS THANK YOU SO MUCH
SOONER A GOING TO HAVE TO SIT
AROUND WITH THE MOTION ON THE
FLOOR BY CENTER WE NEVER
INSURED OVER MR NOW TO BE TO
READ THE FULL. MOTION. END ARE
RECOVERED. THE MOST IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED BUT BUT FIRST
AMANDA. AND WE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR MCGUIRE HI REQUIRE- A
SENATOR NIELSEN. SENATOR DRAWS
SO. SENATOR HERTZBERG. SENATOR
WIENER WINNER HI TWO ZERO TWO
ZERO VOTE LAZY I'M GOING TO
KEEP THAT BILL ON CALL ALLOW
FOLKS TO BE ABLE TO ADD ON FOR
THOSE WHO ARE OUT WATCHING IF
YOU SAID THAT YOU WANTED TO
HEAR MORE FROM CENTER ADMIN
TODAY'S YOUR DAY SO WE HAVE
CENTER AGAIN BACK WITH US TO BE
ABLE TO TALK ABOUT THE STOCKTON
EAST WATER DISTRICT AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE IN HER DISTRICT
AND THAT SHE'S BEEN WORKING
INCREDIBLY DILIGENTLY ON
THREATENING THE FLOOR IS YOURS
IN CENTER AND WHEN I DO WANNA
LET YOU KNOW THAT YOU HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON THE BILL.
SO WE'LL ASK FOR A TRUNCATED
VERSION OF YOUR STATEMENT FOR
SOURCE VERY GOOD SIR- SP SIX
FIFTY SIX OF THE DISTRICT BILL
THAT WILL ALLOW STOCKTON EAST
WATER DISTRICT TO ADJUST ITS
AGRICULTURAL WATER RATES TO
REDUCE RELIANCE ON THE EASTERN
SAN JOAQUIN GROUNDWATER BASINS
DWINDLING GROUNDWATER SUPPLY
INSTEAD INCENTIVIZE SURFACE
WATER PURCHASES. OUR LEAD
WITNESS TODAY IS SCOTT MOODY
GENERAL MANAGER OF THE STOCKTON
EAST WATER DISTRICT FOR HIS
BRIEF REMARKS AND ALSO
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS IS GINNY
SLEAZY COUNSEL FOR STOCKTON
EAST WATER DISTRICT THANK YOU
SO MUCH SOONER A MAN NOW WE'RE
GOING TO TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO
MR MOODY MISTER MOODY YOU ARE
NOW IN COMMITTEE YOU DO HAVE UP
TO THREE MINUTES TO BE ABLE TO
SPEAK HERE TODAY WE DO WANT TO
LET YOU KNOW YOU HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT TO MR MOODY
WITH ALL RESPECT WE'RE GOING TO
ASK FOR A TRUNCATED VERSION. OF
YOUR COMMENTS MR MOVIE THANK
YOU SO. MUCH FOR BEING IN
COMMITTEE THE FLOOR'S YOURS SIR.
THANK YOU VERY JEREMY VERY
BRIEF. IN MY SEVENTY NINE THE
LEGISLATORS THAT LEGISLATURE
ESTABLISHED A GROUNDWATER
EXTRACTION CHARGE. REFLECTED
HEAT WATER DISTRICT OF ONE
DOLLAR AND SIXTEEN CENTS PER
ACRE BUT- THE DESTRUCTION
GOVERNING LEGISLATION ALSO
PROVIDED GENERALLY THAT THAT
RATE COULD NOT BE DECREASED IN
ANY ONE YEAR. MORE THAN THE
CONSUMER PRICE INDEX. BECAUSE
OF THESE ARTIFICIALLY IMPOSE
RATE CAPS THE DISTRICT
AGRICULTURAL GROUNDWATER
ASSESSMENT IN PARTICULAR. HAS
REMAINED ARTIFICIALLY LOW. THE
CURRENT MAXIMUM RATE AS OF
TODAY IS FIVE DOLLARS AND
THIRTY SIX CENTS PER ACRE FOOT.
SOMEONE WITHIN FORTY TWO YEARS
THAT RATE HAS ONLY GONE UP FOUR
DOLLARS AND TWENTY CENTS. WHILE
THE NEIGHBORING DISTRICTS THAT
ARE SURROUND US CHARGE ANYWHERE
FROM TEN TO THIRTY DOLLARS PER
ACRE FOOT. THAT'S WONDERFUL
THAT THIS RATE CAP BE REMOVED
SO THAT OUR AGRICULTURE.
AGRICULTURAL CHARGES TO KEEP
PACE. IN THE END YOU'RE MOVED
ORDER TO ALLOW DISTRICT MEET
THE LETTERS WORK. OF MEETING
GROUND WATER SINCE. BUT I WAS
CALLING TO ELIMINATE THIS RATE
CAP AND I WOULD CLOSE WITH THE
IDEA THAT PROBLEM THAT THE
DISTRICT IS ONLY ASKING FOR
PERMISSION. BUT TO REMOVE THE
RATE CAP SO THAT WE CAN COMPLY
WITH PROPOSITION TWO EIGHTEEN
AND TWENTY SIX IN THE FUTURE
SHOULD OUR BOARD DECIDE THEY
NEED TO RAISE THESE RATES THANK
YOU. MANY THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR WORK THANK YOU FOR THAT
TRUNCATED VERSION OF THE
STATEMENT- IN FOR ALL OF YOUR
EFFORT WORKING WITH SENATOR-EDMUND. WE ARE GRATEFUL TO HAVE
CENTER ANYTHING HERE IN THE
SENATE- IT'S JUST AN AMAZING
ADVOCATE. FOR HOME SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER MOODY. WE ARE
NOW GOING TO CHECK IN WITH
THOSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL HERE IN
THE SENATE CHAMBERS WERE
LOOKING UP ABOVE TO. THE
BALCONY SCENE NO ONE RIDES WERE
NOT GOING TO GO TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE ROOM ONE TWELVE NO ONE
IS RISING IN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE
WERE NOW GOING TO BE GOING TO
ROOM. WILL EXCUSE ME WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GOING TO A
TELECONFERENCE LINE IF YOU'D
LIKE TO JOIN US PLEASE CALL
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX
EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO WITH THE
CODE ONE ONE SEVEN. FORTY
SEVEN. SEVENTY ONE ALL RIGHT MR
MODERATOR THAT'S QUEUE UP ALL
THOSE FOLKS WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK INSUPPORT OF. SENATE
BILL SIX FIFTY SIX NOW. IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB SIX FIVE SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN
ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT. I DO HAVE
ONE IN OUR QUEUE WE'LL GO TO
LINE FOR EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS KAREN LAYING ON BEHALF
OF THE FAMILY CAN COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT THE
FACTOR YOU THINKING KAREN LANG
IS BACK THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
SLAYING VERYGRATEFUL FOR THE
COMMENTS. THAT LETS YOU CHECK
IN WITH THE MODERATOR AND OUR
NEXT CALLER. AT THIS TIME THERE
ARE NO OTHERS IN THE QUEUE.
PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR WILL BE BACK WITH YOU
MOMENTARILY THAT'S CHECKING TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION OF SIX FIFTY SIX.
CENA IF ANYONE RISES HERE IN
THE CHAMBER KNOWN AS RISING
WE'RE NOT GONNA GO TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE. THERE'S A GENTLEMAN I
GOT A HUNCH NOTHING IS
HAPPENING IN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
THERE'S NOTHING HAPPENING IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE. SO WE'RE NOW
GOING TO BE GOING TOWARD
TELECONFERENCE LINE. MR
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE
UP ALL THOSE WHO ARE OPPOSED TO
SIX FIFTY SIX NOW. HE'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB SIX
FIFTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. AT THIS TIME WE DO
NOT HAVE ANYONE IN OUR QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR WE'RE GONNA BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS EMOTION. ALL RIGHT WE
GOT A MOTION BY CENTER DRAWS A
LAZY GENTLEMAN THERE WE GO IT'S
ON THE FLOOR- ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. HEARING C. NINE
CENTER ADMIN BRINGING HOME
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE WE WANT
A CHANCE TO MEET- SIGMA GOALS
ESPECIALLY AS WE'RE ENDING YET
ANOTHER DAY OUT. OF THAT WE USE
EVERY TOOL AVAILABLE AT S. B.
SIX FIFTY SIX IS ONE SUCH TOOL
I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE IN A GREEN
THANK YOU YOU ARE TENACIOUS IN
YOUR FIGHT FOR THAT COMMUNITIES
THAT YOU REPRESENT VERY
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR WORK. MR
GREEN NOW WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THE FLOOR FROM CENTER DRIVE SO
CAN YOU PLEASE PROVIDE THE FOUR
MOTION AND CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FOR SENATOR MCGUIRE RIGHT
MCGUIRE HI SENATOR NIELSEN.
NIELSEN HI SENATOR ALSO.
THEY'RE ALSO- A SENATOR
HERTZBERG. SENATOR WIENER
WEINER HI FOUR ZERO FOUR ZERO
VOTE BIPARTISAN THANK YOU SO
MUCH SOONER AND WE HAVE A
WONDERFUL EEKEND SAFE TRAVELS
HOME- WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GONNA KEEP THAT
BILL ON CALL SO LAZY JENNA
COMMITTEE WE ARE OFFICIALLY IN
THE HOME STRETCH I HAVE
RECEIVED A NOTE FROM CENTER WE
ARE ASKING IF WE COULD GO UNTIL
SIX PM TONIGHT SO I SAID-
WINNERS- SO MUCH MONEY INTO MY
RIGHT THAT'S RIGHT DRAWS SO
DESIRE DRUGS WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT THAT. ALL RIGHT. EXACTLY
SO- WE RIGHT NOW WE ARE WAITING
FOR SENATOR BATES- THE
SERGEANTS ARE WORKING ON HAVING
SENATOR BATES. ARRIVED OR THAT
SHE HAS ITEM SEVENTEEN AN ITEM
EIGHTEEN SO WE ARE- HEIGHTENED
CENTER BATES DOWN AT THE
MOMENT. WE DIDN'T HAVE TWO
ITEMS FROM BECKER. CENTER
BECKER IN ONE FINAL FROM
SENATOR RAZA. SO IS SEEN THAT
SENATOR BATES IS NOT- ARRIVING
ON OR TURN IT OVER TO SENATOR
DRAWS OVER IRAQ FIRELIGHT AND-
TWENTY ONE THIS IS S. B. FOR
TWENTY FOUR. CENTER DRAWS A ONE
MOMENT YOU HAVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. CENTER DRAWS SO-
PLEASE PROCEED WE WELCOME YOU
TO COMMITTEE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES. IT'S B. FOR TWENTY
FOUR IS THE CALIFORNIA HOPELESS
HOMELESS HIRING TAX CREDIT AND
I WANNA THANK YOU AND THE STAFF
FOR WORKING SO CLOSELY I ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ADDING
ADDITIONAL COOP IS IN MAKING A
SERIES OF TECHNICAL EVENTS TO-
THE LANGUAGE THIS IS A REALLY
ALL ABOUT ADDING ANOTHER TOOL
FOR OUR STATE TO ADDRESS THE
HOMELESSNESS THE CRISIS OF
HOMELESSNESS- THROUGHOUT THE
STATE I KNOW IN. LOS ANGELES MY
HOME COUNTY THE POPULATION OF
HOMELESS- INDIVIDUALS HAS
GROWN- I STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT
OUR RESOURCES SHOULD GO INTO
PROGRAMS THAT OFFER INDIVIDUALS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS A
CHANCE TO REALLY TAKE CHARGE IN
THEIR LIVES THAT MEANS A JOB A
DECENT PAYING JOB AND I THINK
THAT'S WHERE WE OUGHT TO. PUT
SOME FOCUS IN RIGHT NOW THIS-
THIS BILL COMES FROM OF GREAT
SUPPORT FROM THROUGHOUT THE R.
SECTORS IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
MMHM IT IS US BUSINESSES WERE
SURVEYED AND 85% OF THEM AGREED
WITH THIS- AND BASICALLY JUST
ALLOCATES 250-021-0000 DOLLARS
PER INDIVIDUAL HIRED. TO
ELEVATE THE WORK FORCE SYSTEM
AND GIVE THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY
TOGETHER A JOINT RESPONSE-
CREDIT GET THROUGH THIS FAST
MISTER YOU'RE DOING GOOD MISTER
CHAIR- JUST TO GIVE ME FILING
WITH AN EXAMPLE. LOS ANGELES IS
SERVING ALMOST THIRTY FIVE
HUNDRED PEOPLE THROUGH PROJECT
ROOM KEY- AND WE NEED A
TRANSITION PLAN FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE NOW
SOMEWHAT STABILIZED WITH ACCESS
TO SHELTER AND FOOD THEY WANT
TO MOVE ON. IN THEIR LIVES AS
WELL THIS IS A SOUND INVESTMENT
TO MAKE SUPPORT OF THE- GIVING
PEOPLE JOBS AND GIVING THEM A
REAL OPPORTUNITY A BUSINESS
WILL DO THAT AND THE BEST NEWS
IS THAT. OF THEM OF MONEY THAT
WILL BE SET ASIDE- ALLOCATED
FOR THIS. OF A IT WILL ONLY BE
USED ONCE SOMEBODY'S ACTUALLY
WORKING. OKAY THIS IS NOT A
PROBLEM IS THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT COULD COME BACK
AND WE PAID IT PREMATURELY THIS
WILL ONLY GO TO THOSE
BUSINESSES THAT ACTUALLY
HIGHER. AND THAT'S OUR MY OUR
TAX DOLLARS WILL BE USED I. ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS AND I HAVE
MICHAEL STAFFED ON BEHALF
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
ASSOCIATION. AND TONY JOLLY
OWNER OF HOT AND COOL CAFES TO
SATISFY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND I AND I
GOTTA SAY SENT DRUGS AREYOU OF
WORK THIS- ISSUE IT IS SO
CRITICAL WITH THE NUMBER OF
HOMELESS. ACROSS THE STATE IN
OFFERING OPPORTUNITIES THIS IS
A GREAT BILL YOU JUST WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH. SENATOR
EYES OF FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK ON
THIS ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GONNA
TURN IT OVER TO MICHAEL DASH TO
MR DAFT WE DO WANT TO LET YOU
KNOW. THAT SENATOR ALSO HAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON THIS
BILL. SO WE'RE GOING TO ASK FOR
A TRUNCATED VERSION OF YOUR
STATEMENT MR DAFT MR DAFT YOU
HAVE UP TO THREE MINUTES. THE
FLOOR IS YOURS SIR YOU ARE NOW
IN COMMITTEE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I WILL TAKE
THAT INTO CONSIDERATION TRY TO
GIVE YOU THE ABRIDGED VERSION-
MY NAME IS MICHAEL DOCTOR WITH
THE PREY AND MCKINLEY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
ASSOCIATION. A NONPROFIT
ASSOCIATION MADE UP OF
CALIFORNIA'S WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD. THIS DATA IS
THEN WORKING TIRELESSLY TO
ADDRESS THE DEEP SEATED
ECONOMIC DISPARITIES ARE MOST
VULNERABLE AND WHILE WE
RECOGNIZE THERE'S STILL MUCH TO
BE DONE. SENATE BILL FOUR
TWENTY FOUR BEFORE YOU TODAY IS
AN IMPORTANT STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. FOUR TWENTY FOUR
OFFERS A DIRECT OPPORTUNITY FOR
OUR BUSINESS COMMUNITIES TO BE
A PART OF THE SOLUTION AS WE
ALL LOOK TO BUILD BACK FOR.
CALIFORNIA'S FORTY FIVE LOCAL
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARDS UP
AND DOWN THE STATE WILL BE AN
ESSENTIAL COMPONENT OF THIS
PROCESS. SERVING AS A LINK FOR
EMPLOYERS AND NEW EMPLOYEES.
THE BUSINESS SERVICE
REPRESENTATIVES ALREADY HAVE
RELATIONSHIPS AND KNOWLEDGE OF
MAINSTREAM LABOR MARKET DATA
AND CAN HELP BUSINESSES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES.
CONNECTED THIS OPPORTUNITY WELL
THE CASE MANAGERS WILL SUPPORT
THOSE INDIVIDUALS BEING HIRED.
WITH THEIR SPECIAL SUPPORT THAT
HOUSING AGENCIES ARE HEALTHCARE
SITE THAT NEEDED. THE CULTURAL
COMPETENCIES WITHIN HIS LOCAL
BOARDS THAT. ARE CENTRAL TO
SUPPORTING BOTH THE EMPLOYER
AND THE EMPLOYEE AND ENSURING
THAT RETENTION. AND LONG TERM
SUCCESS CAN COME FROM HIRING
THROUGH THIS TAX CREDIT. THAT
YOU FOR CALLING FOUR WILL HELP
ADDRESS THE GAP BETWEEN
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS LOOKING
FOR EMPLOYMENT. AND BUSINESSES
WITH JOB OPENINGS TO CONSIDER
THESE INDIVIDUALS OVERCOME
HOMELESSNESS. IT STILL OFFERS
ANOTHER TOOL TO HELP SOLVE THE
STATE'S HOUSING CRISIS BY
MATCHING HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS.
BUT JOBS THAT MUST PAY FAMILY
SUPPORTING WAGES AFTER
EXCEEDING THE JURISDICTIONS
PREVAILING WAGE. IN ORDER TO
QUALIFY FOR THIS TAX CREDIT.
ADDITIONALLY THERE ARE MANY
SMALL BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA
RIGHT NOW THAT ARE. LOOKING TO
GET A NATIONAL STAFF TO ASSIST
WITH THE RE OPENING ARE
STRUGGLING WITH THE PORTING ITS
CLASS. THIS TAX CREDIT CAN MAKE
A WORLD OF DIFFERENCE FOR BOTH
THE BUSINESS OWNERS AND UP TO
THREE THOUSAND HOMELESS
CALIFORNIANS BUT THEY HOPE TO
HELP GET BACK ON THEIR FEET. WE
THINK THEY'RE DURABLE
PROFFERING A SUPPORT MEASURE
RESPECTFULLY ASPIRIN I ABOUT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
IT'S A DAFT APPRECIATE THOSE
WORDS- CENTER DRAWS WE DO WANT
TO YOU KNOW TONY JOLLY WAS ON
THE LINE. IS KNOWN. NOT TONY
JOLLY JUST US BY ALL RIGHT.
JUST IN THE NICK OF TIME. WE
WANT TO WELCOME MR JOLLY ADDED
TO THE LINE TONY THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR JOINING US THE OWNER
OF HOT AND COOL CAFE. YOU HAVE
UP TO THREE MINUTES SIR THE
FLOOR IS YOURS AND I'LL GIVE
YOU THIRTY SECOND PROBLEM SO
JOLLY. READING FIVE- GOOD
AFTERNOON THE GYM ACQUIRE
NUMBER MY NAME IS BONNIE JOLLY
AND I'M HONORED TO TALK ABOUT
THE WHOLE. DAY HOW TO DEAL WITH
PEOPLE GET OUT OF. THOSE THAT
ARE EXPERIENCING A PROBLEM WITH
THAT. THANK AT THE NOT TODAY I
WOULD BE ON THE HUNT F. A. Y.
FIRED. INDIVIDUAL IN CALIFORNIA.
APART PEOPLE WHO. AND I THINK
THAT THAT SOME HAVE APPARENTLY
ONE THAT IS COMES OUT BECAUSE
OF I WILL TO THOSE NOT
OTHERWISE THE QUARTER. THE
OPPORTUNITY THE DOG WERE ABLE
TO OBTAIN EMPLOYMENT APART ON
THAT WHAT FINANCIAL
INDEPENDENCE. BILL I BELIEVE
WILL PROVIDE OTHER BUSINESSES
UNABLE TO PROVIDE THE
OPPORTUNITY THE EXTRA. THE
STUFF I'M AT THE BOTTOM HALF OF
THOSE THAT CAN GIVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GET BACK ON
TRACK. THE RATING. THE THING
GIVEN THEM AFTER THEY NEEDED TO
START THE DEBATE BACK ON AFTER
THE FACT ONE OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS I DON'T THAT
HELPING HIM OUT THAT DAY
WELCOME BACK AND IT SHOULD BE
THE PACKAGE FOR. AN EIGHT THAT.
CAME BEFORE US. THE OTHER TWO
AND- WOMEN WHO BEHIND THE CAFE.
AND TO PROTECT THEIR PRIVACY WE
HAVE THEM COME IN TO WORK AT
NIGHT AFTER HOURS TO BRING THE
BABY TO HELP PREPARE FOR THE
NEXT DAY. DECEMBER FIFTH AT THE
PROTECT INTEGRITY I HAVEN'T
BEEN WITH THE GOOD PEOPLE AND
THEY NEED IT. ATPEOPLE FOR
PROVIDING BUSINESSES AND THEN
THE- BANK. WILL BE INVALUABLE
TO ALL THOSE. THANK READ IT ALL
THE WAY. ONE OF THING WE WANT
TO WANT ONE OF THE THINGS THEY
NEED MOST OPPORTUNITY AT PEOPLE
KEEP ONE OUT THE BIKE NIGHT
THAT TAKE WHAT THEY HAVE
RECEIVED AT THE RISK AND SEVEN
IN OPPORTUNITY FOR BOTH THE
BUSINESS. AND THE ARTS. AND HOW
AND I'M PROBABLY THE BEST.
PRESIDENT RIGHT NOW WITH THE
BOOK TO RETIRE. BACK IN THEIR
THE PEOPLE FOR THE RECENTLY ON
POPULAR. THE PROBLEM OF THE
PAST YEAR BUT IT WAS HELP
EVERYONE OUT BACK AT THE HIGH
PRICE ALTHOUGH THE COUNTRY
RIGHT WE NEED PEOPLE TO WORK
THANK YOU SENATOR OUT THOUGH
RIDING A WAVE THAT HELP THE
HOMELESS POPULATION AND ICONIC
BUT- HOWEVER. THANK YOU. BUT
YOUR TIME AT THE BETTER. AS
THAT YOU PLEASE VOTE HI. YEAH
AT WOULD ONE ACCORD THANK YOU
SO MUCH. NICE JOB IT'S A JOLLY
WERE REALLY GREAT AND EVEN ABLE
TO JOIN US TODAY FOR ALL YOUR
WORK THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTNERSHIP WITH SENATOR REID
SO AMAZING ADVOCATE ON BEHALF
OF HER HOME COMMUNITIES. IT'S A
JOLLY THANK YOU AGAIN ALL RIGHT
DAYS IN GENERAL WE'RE NOW GOING
TO TURN IT OVER TO THOSE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO BE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF FOUR TWENTY FOUR
HERE IN THE CHAMBERS IT SEEMS
NO ONE WRITES WE'RE NOT GOING
TO GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE.
LOOKING AT THE BIG BOARD NO ONE
IS IN A ROOM ONE TWELVE WE'RE
NOT GOING TO BE GOING TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE IF YOU'D
LIKE TO GET A PARTICIPATE IN
GIVE US A CALL TODAY. YEAH IT'S
ALWAYS TOLL FREE. 877-226-8152
WE LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING FROM
YOU MR MODERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE QUEUE UP ALL THOSE IN
SUPPORT OF. SB FOUR TWENTY FOUR
NOW. IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN ONE
ZERO FOR SUPPORT. WE CURRENTLY
DO NOT HAVE ANYONE IN OUR QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH AMS A MODERATOR AND VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THAT WE'RE NOT
GOING TO LOOK TO THOSE WHO ARE
IN OPPOSITION WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYONE OFFICIALLY REGISTERED AS
A LEAD WITNESS IN OPPOSITION OF
FOUR TWENTY FOUR WE'RE NOT
GOING TO LOOK TO THOSE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO OPPOSE
THE BILL IN THE SENATE
CHAMBERS. SEE NO ONE RIDES WERE
NOT GOING TO GO TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE NO ONE IS RISING IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE WE'RE NOT GOING TO
GO TO OUR TOLL FREE
TELECONFERENCE LINE. AND CHECK
IN WITH THE MODERATOR MR
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE
UP ALL THOSE FOLKS WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF FOUR TWENTY FOUR.
NOW NOW IF YOU LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FOUR TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR OPPOSITION.
WE DO HAVE ONE IN THE QUEUE.
WE'LL GO TO NUMBER FIVE TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR CARE
MEMBERS SMALL THE COLUMN OF THE
CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION WE REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL THE AUTHORS HARD
WORK ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH HER INTO THE
FUTURE TO FURTHER REFINE THE
BELT- SUPPORT HER AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISS CORBIN VERY GRATEFUL
FOR THAT. IT'S A MODERATOR
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
ABSOLUTELY NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE FOR FORTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS BOB FIRMAN
I'D LIKE TO EXPRESS MY
UNHAPPINESS WITH THE WHOLE-
OPPOSITION- THE DEPARTED I
GUESS IT GETS TO ME IS THE
WHOLE PROVISION FOR SOME
PREVAILING WAGE- I'M NOT QUITE
SURE WHAT THAT MEANS. I KNOW
WHAT IT MEANS AS FAR AS ALL
RIGHT BOB UNNECESSARY WE'RE
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR IS A
FIRST AND LAST NAME POSITION ON
THE BILL AS WELL AS- YOUR
ORGANIZATION IF YOU'D LIKE TO
PROVIDE ONE BUT THANK YOU SO WE
HEAR YOUR CONCERNS AND REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU CALLING IN HERE
TODAY. ALL RIGHT MR MODERATOR
LET'S GO TO LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT WILL
BE NUMBER FIVE THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE THREE
THREE YOU ARE CURRENTLY IN
COMMITTEE PLEASE PROCEED. ALL
RIGHT LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOU SO
MUCH HAVE MISTER MODERATOR ALL
RIGHT THAT WE'RE GONNA BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE TO BE HERE TO
SEE IF WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OR EMOTION. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR WIENER THANK
YOU SO MUCH. NO ADDITIONAL
pCOMMITTEE AGAIN SENATOR ALSO.
REALLY WONDERFUL BILL- IT IS
PROVEN HI AND IT ONLY GOES-
THAT THOSE DOLLARS ARE SPENT
ONCE I HIRE IS MADE. WE NEED IT
WE NEED IT NOW VERY GRATEFUL
FOR YOUR HARD WORK THE FLOOR IS
YOURS FOR CLOSE. I URGE A NO
VOTE THANK YOU BYE AS CHAIR
SENATOR ALL RIGHT WE DO HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY SENATOR
WIENER MR CANAL IS GOING TO
GIVE THE FORMAL MOTION. AS WELL
AS CALL THE ROOM. MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
DEMAND IN RE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR MCGUIRE HI REQUIRE. A
SENATOR NIELSEN. NIELSEN A
SENATOR TO ROSEAU ROSEAU- A
SENATOR HERTZBERG HERZBERG
SENATOR WIENER WIENER- A FIVE
ZERO HELLO FIVE ZERO VOTE AT
FIRST FIVE ZERO VOTE WE'VE HAD
ALL DAY TO DAY EVERYBODY THERE
WE GO PEOPLE ARE HERE READY TO
ROLL ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO
MUCH AIR DRIES IT THANK YOU THE
COMMITTEE THAT DEAL IS THAT
WE'RE CLOSE IN THE ROLE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT SO
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE'RE NOW
GOING TO BE MOVING TO SENATOR
BATES HI THIS IS A DOUBLE
HEADER BY SENATOR BATES WE GOT
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN IN THE
END ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN AND
THEN YOU SAY YOU WANT ANOTHER
DOUBLE HEADER FROM A BILL WELL
WE GOT SENATOR BECKER WITH TWO
BILLS. RIGHT TO BE ABLE TO
BRING IT HOME HERE TODAY SO I
WOULD LIKE TO BE TO START WITH
FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN AND THIS
IS- SP SIX SIX EIGHT I WANNA
FIRST IT IS WITH THAT SOME
TAKING CARE TAKING A BIT OF A
PRIVILEGE HERE I WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
SENATOR BATES. FOR HER WORK ON
THIS CRITICAL ISSUE- CENTER
BATES AND I HAVE HAD SOME
DISCUSSIONS IN TODAY WE'RE
GONNA LOOK AT A PRISON TATIAN
ONLY OF SB SIX SIX EIGHT. FOR
THIS AFTERNOON'S HEARING.
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN AFTER
THE HEARING. CENTER BAY TONIGHT
WE ARE GOING TO BE DOING A
SERIES OF MEETINGS- WITH-
SENATOR HERTZBERG WHO'S BEEN.
WORKING HERE IN THE SENATE. ON
ISSUE OF PROP NINETEEN CLEANER.
SO SENATOR BATES CENTERS FOR
AND I WILL BE. HAVING THAT
MEETING AS WE MOVE FORWARD AND
I. KNOW THAT THERE ARE SOME
CHALLENGES THAT NEED TO BE
RESOLVED IN REGARDS TO
PROPOSITION NINETEEN. CENTER
BATES HAS STEPPED UP ALONG WITH
SENATOR HERTZBERG TO BE ABLE
TO- HELP. MAKE SOME OF THESE
NECESSARY CHANGES AS WE MOVE
FORWARD IN CANDIDLY THAT ARE
GOING TO HELP TAXPAYERS IN
COMMUNITIES BIG AND SMALL. UP
AND DOWN THIS GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SO WITH THAT THIS
IS GOING TO BE A PRESENTATION
ONLY. COLLABORATIVE DISCUSSIONS
ARE GOING TO CONTINUE- AND WE'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO UPDATE THE
COMMITTEE HERE IN THE WEEKS TO
COME. SENATOR BATES I NEVER
WANT TO PUT WORDS IN YOUR MOUTH
SO I'LL TURN IT OVER TO YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION AND I WANT
YOU TO CONFIRM WHAT I JUST SAID
AND AGAIN CENTER BATES. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PARTNERSHIP. IN ALSO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE. WELL THANK YOU
I MISTER CHAIR ON SENATOR
MCGUIRE- FOR THAT INTRODUCTION
ON THE ON. THE IT'S B- NO
PROPOSITION NINETEEN IT WAS
CANCER S. B. NINETEEN. F. B.
SIX SIXTY EIGHT- IT IS A VERY
VERY SERIOUS- ISSUE THAT
DEVELOPED AFTER THE- VOTE OF
FOUR EIGHT GMT ON NOVEMBER
ELECTIONS SO I'M VERY PLEASED
TO PRESENT IT TODAY ON AND WE
WILL HAVE THAT ONGOING
DISCUSSION BECAUSE IT NEEDS
FIXES AS WE ALL KNOW. OF THE
OUTCRY CAME AFTER ON I THINK
THE VOTE- ON PAST IT. I MEAN IT
PASSED WITH A VOTE. THAT
ACTUALLY BROUGHT IT TO MY
ATTENTION ALL AS I GOT MANY
MANY CALLS FROM TRUST ATTORNEYS
IN RESIDENCE ON. THE FACT THAT
THEY WERE UNABLE TO DO ANYTHING
MANY BUILDINGS WERE CLOSED AT
THAT TIME SO IT IS A VERY VERY
TIMELY ISSUE AS FAMILIES LOOK
AT THESE INTERGENERATIONAL
PROPERTY TRANSFERS AND THE
IMPACT PROBLEM NINETEEN IS
HAVING ON THEM. RETROACTIVELY
ACTUALLY SO. LET ME GIVE YOU
THE- FULL OF THE BILL AND THEN
YES I DO HAVE PEOPLE ON THE
LINE WHO WISH TO SUPPORT IT. IT
WILL DELAY THE IMPLEMENTATION
DATE OF PROPOSITION NINETEEN
SPECIFICALLY THE PROPERTY TAX
FAIRNESS FOR FAMILY HOME
SECTION. BY CHANGING THE
FEBRUARY SIXTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IMPLEMENTATION DATE
TO FEBRUARY SIXTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. THAT GIVES A TWO
YEAR OB TIME. IN WHICH TO WORK
THROUGH SOME OF THESE VERY
SIGNIFICANT ISSUES ARE THAT
CURRENTLY EXIST WITH THAT. IN
THE NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
ELECTION- PROP NINETEEN REPEAL
PROPOSITION FIFTY EIGHT. AND
PROPOSITION NOT ONE NINETY
THREE CHANGING THE RULES FOR
TAX ASSESSMENTS ON PROPERTY
TRANSFERRED WITHIN FAMILIES.
PRIOR TO PROP PROPOSITION
NINETEEN PARENTS OR
GRANDPARENTS COULD TRANSFER
PRIMARY RESIDENTIAL PROPERTIES
TO THEIR CHILDREN OR
GRANDCHILDREN WITHOUT THE
PROPERTY'S TAX ASSESSMENT.
RESETTING TO MARKET VALUE OTHER
TYPES OF PROPERTY SUCH AS
VACATION HOMES FAMILY FARMS AND
BUSINESS PROPERTIES COULD BE
TRANSFERRED WITH THE FIRST TWO
MILLION DOLLARS OF ASSESSED
REASSESSMENT WHEN TRANSFERRED.
PROPOSITION NINETEEN ELIMINATED
THE PARENT TO CHILD AND
GRANDPARENT TO GRANDCHILD
EXEMPTION IN CASES WHERE THE
CHILD OR GRANDCHILD DOES NOT
USE THE INHERITED HOME AS THEIR
PRINCIPAL RESIDENCE. THE
MEASURE ALSO ELIMINATED THE
MILLION DOLLAR EXEMPTION FOR
OTHER PROPERTIES. PROPOSITION
NINETEEN DID MAKE AN EXCEPTION
ONLY FOR HOMES THAT THE
CHILDREN MOVE INTO WITHIN ONE
YEAR AND USES THEIR PRINCIPAL
RESIDENCE HOWEVER AS WE ALL
KNOW IT'S NOT ALWAYS POSSIBLE
FOR FAMILY MEMBERS TO
IMMEDIATELY RELOCATE. UNDER
THIS NEW LAW CHILDREN COULD NOW
BE FORCED BY HIGHER TAXES TO
SELL THEIR FAMILY'S PROPERTY
SUCH AS A SMALL BUSINESS THAT
HAS PROVIDED THE FAMILY WITH
FINANCIAL SECURITY. IN THEIR
LONG TIME HOME IF THEY CAN'T
MOVE IN FAST ENOUGH SINCE THE
PROPOSITION WAS APPROVED A 51%
OF THE VOTERS THERE HAVE BEEN
CONCERNS FROM ASSESSORS. BOARD
OF EQUALIZATION LAWYERS AND
TAXPAYERS ON HOW BEST TO
IMPLEMENT THE LARGEST CHAIN TO
CALIFORNIA'S PROPERTY TAX
SYSTEM SINCE PROP THIRTEEN IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT. A MAJOR
OBSTACLE THAT TAXPAYERS HAVE
FEES PRIOR TO AND SINCE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF PROPOSITION
NINETEEN AS TRANSFERRING THEIR
PROPERTY DURING THE CALL THE
NINETEEN. LITTLE PANDEMIC
PARENTS AND GRANDPARENTS HAVE
BEEN HANDICAPPED IN THEIR
ABILITY TO TRANSFER. THE
GOVERNMENT BUILDINGS BEING
CLOSED TO THE PUBLIC. TO
PROVIDE MORE TIME FOR OUR
TAXING. AGENCIES AND ARE
AFFECTED TAXPAYERS HOMEOWNERS
TO DEAL WITH THIS MAJOR CHANGE
IN INTERGENERATIONAL PROPERTY
TRANSFERS SB SIX SIXTY EIGHT
WELL THE WAY THE IMPLEMENTATION
FROM FEBRUARY SIXTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TO FEBRUARY
SIXTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY THREE
THIS DELAY. MAKES FOR AN
APPROPRIATE EXTENSION LIKE HE
MANY EXTENSIONS ARE STATE HAS
ISSUED FOR STRUGGLING
CALIFORNIANS ESPECIALLY DURING
THIS GLOBAL PANDEMIC I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK MEMBER TED GAINES
WITH THE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION
AND SCOTT KAUFMAN AND HIM BE
ABLE WITH HOWARD JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION WHO ARE
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SUGAR BEET
CIVIL WAR FIRST HERE FROM THE
HONORABLE TAKE GAINS- FORMER
SENATOR WANT TO SENATOR ALWAYS
A SENATOR HARDWORKING NEIGHBOR
THE STATE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION
NOW. THEN SCOTT KAUFMAN IS
BROUGHT HIS SLEEPING BAG AND
TENT HERE TONIGHT. BECAUSE HE'S
BEEN HERE THE ENTIRE DAY SO
SCOTT IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU I
KNOW THAT YOU'RE GOING TO BE
GOING AFTER THAT FORMER SENATOR
TED GAINES NOW BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION MEMBER OF COURSE
MR BIDDLE WILL BE HERE FOR ANY
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THAT WE
MAY NEED. SO WE'RE FIRST GOING
TO GO TO OUR TELECONFERENCE
LINE IN WELCOME THE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION MEMBER MISTER TED
GAINES TO COMMITTEE MR GAINS
IT'S GOOD TOO IT'S GONNA BE
GOOD TO HEAR YOUR VOICE YOU
HAVE THREE MINUTES. AND I'LL
GIVE YOU THIRTY SECOND PROMPT.
FANTASTIC THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SURE WHAT WERE PRECEDED THIS.
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK AS A-
FORMER STATE SENATOR AND I
CORPS CURRENT MEMBER OF THE
BOARD OF EQUALIZATION- THAT'S
OF MANY RESPONSIBILITIES AT THE
PORT I'M ONE OF THOSE IS
PROVIDING GUIDANCE TO ASSESSORS.
UNIFORMITY IN PROPERTY
ASSESSMENTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THAT WE SEEK TO ENSURE
FAIRNESS CLARITY IN PROPERTY
TAX ADMINISTRATION THAT IS WHY
I'M PLEASED TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SENATE BILL SIX SIXTY EIGHT
THE BUILDING THIS TAXPAYERS
MORE REASONABLE TIMELINE TO
UNDERSTAND THE CHANGES BROUGHT
FORTH BY PROP NINETEEN AT TO
USE THAT KNOWLEDGE IN THE
PROPERTY. TAX TRANSFERS. AS IT
STANDS. BUT THE CHILD IN GRAND
TO CREATE EXCLUSION- THOSE
CHANGES ARE POORLY UNDERSTOOD
AND LEAVE MANY QUESTIONS
UNANSWERED MY OFFICE IN THE
BOARD RECEIVED COUNCIL'S
CATALYST ENQUIRING REGARDING
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS SURROUNDING
HOW THE NEW RICH BENEFACTORS
PROPERTIES IN TRUCKS MY
RESIDENCE REQUIREMENTS FINDING
A FRACTIONAL OWNERSHIP AND MANY
OTHER QUESTIONS TOO MANY OF
THESE QUESTIONS. THAT REMAIN
UNRESOLVED. SINCE THE-
NINETEEN. OR WE CAN OVER A
HUNDRED TWENTY TWENTY THOUSAND
ON OUR WEBSITE SPECIFICALLY
RELATED TO CURRENT NINETEEN HI
WE ARE WORKING TO CLARIFY AS
MUCH AS WE CAN AND DO SO AS
QUICKLY AS WE CAN BUT THERE ARE
SO MANY FAMILIES WHO DID NOT
GET HACKED BEFORE THE. GREAT
SIX NEEDS THE DEADLINE. IT'S
NOT EVEN BEEN AWAY OF THESE
CHANGES. HOUSES ALSO THE
FAMILY'S BIGGEST ASSET WE NEED
TO PROVIDE A LONGER LEAD TIME.
FOR EVERYONE TO COMPLY WITH THE
MANDATE OF THE NEW LAW. NOT
JUST THOSE WEALTHIEST
SOPHISTICATED MAPS HAVE A TAX
ATTORNEY OR FINANCIAL PLANNER
ON SPEED DIAL. NUMBER AND THAT
IS SOMETHING ELSE THAT WE WANT
TO KNOW ABOUT PROP NINETEEN WAS
SOLD. AS A WAY OF CLOSING
LOOPHOLES ON CROSS FRONT ERRORS
EAST COAST INVESTORS AND HOLY
BUT FOR WHATEVER NEDS. BUT
THAT IS NOT WHAT WHAT HAS BEEN
HAPPENING AT THE KIA WE THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE REACHING OUT TO
US- WORRIED AND CONFUSED AND
THEY'RE JUST MIDDLE CLASS
FOLKS. ARE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT. WHAT HAPPENED TO THEM. SO
YOU KNOW WE'VE BEEN WE WITH-
WHAT CHAMBLEE SAP. INDIVIDUALS
WHO THANKS THAT THE IT WORKED
ALL THEIR LIVES THE FILM STAR
HOME. TO LEAVE AT FOR THEIR
CHILDREN- SISTER DISABLED
ADULTS WHO WANT TO USE RENTAL
INCOME TO HELP COVER THEIR
CHILD'S LIVING EXPENSES AFTER
THEY PASS AWAY. THEY'VE BEEN
BLINDSIDED BY PROP NINETEEN
SIMPLY NEED MORE TIME TO MAKE
PLANS THIRTY SECONDS IS BILL IS
NOT ABOUT I'M DOING THE WILL OF
THE PEOPLE. BUT IMPLEMENTED
DRAMATIC CHANGES IN A WAY THAT
RESPECTS THE COMPLEXITY. AND
IMPORTANCE. MUST MAKE ABOUT THE-
FUTURE. THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY SPEECH YET TODAY I
WANT TO THANK SENATOR BATES.
ACTING QUICKLY TO HELP
TAXPAYERS STRUGGLING TO COMPILE
TO COMPLY WITH THE EFFECTS OF
PROP NINETEEN. AND PLEASE NOTE
THE BOARD HAS NOT TAKEN A
POSITION. ON THIS LEGISLATION
I'M SPEAKING ON MY OWN BEHALF.
AND I ENCOURAGE YOU TO SUPPORT
SENATE BILL SIX SIXTY EIGHT.
CHOIR THANK YOU MUCH. SHARING
THESE DISCUSSIONS- WITH SENATOR
HERTZBERG YOURSELF. TO SEE IF
WE CAN COME TO A REMEDY THAT
PROVIDES SOME RELIEF AFTER
THOSE TWO- ARE STRUGGLING I
NEED IT. IF WE- LOOK. AT THE
WHOLE. IT WOULD APPEAR THAT
OBAMA THE MORE YOU ARE
SPREADSHEET FOR RETIREMENT OR
PASSING ON. FILE OPEN SOME SOME
JUST GOT CAUGHT IN THE SHOPS.
THAT NOBODY OF THE PROPOSITION
THAT. I PROCEEDED CENTER ITSELF
AND YOUR HELP AND- MOVING THIS
FORWARD THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU MR SENATOR VERY GRATEFUL-
THAT BOARD OF EQUALIZATION.
MEMBER MISTER TED GAINES ALSO A
FORMER ENATOR HERE IN THE
STATE SNATE THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR SENATOR IN ALWAYS WONDERFUL
TO HEAR YOUR VOICE AND PLEASE
GIVE OUR BEST THE BEST AS WELL
ALL RIGHT BUT WE ARE NOW GOING
TO TURN IT OVER TO MISTER
KAUFMAN REPRESENTING THE HOWARD
DRIVERS JERVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION. BUT MR COPPING YOU
KNOW THREE MINUTES AND I'LL
GIVE YOU THIRTY SECOND PROBLEM
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU I
BELIEVE MR GAINS ELOQUENTLY
EXPRESSED THE NEED FOR THIS
BILL SO IF THE CHAIR WOULD
ALLOW I WOULD LIKE TO YIELD MY
TIME TO MY ASSOCIATE HERE TEN
BATTLE BECAUSE I THINK HE'S
BETTER TO SPEAK TO THE
TECHNICAL ASPECTS OF THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE CONCERNS
WITH THAT'S OKAY WITH YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH YES THE TURN
IT OVER TO MR BIDDLE
MISCIBILITY OF THREE MINUTES.
AND I'LL GIVE YOU THIRTY SECOND
PROMPT GOOD. AFTERNOON THIS
CHAIR- THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
FOR A P. SIX SIX. RAISED THE
CALL. POSED BY THE BILL'S
OPPONENTS. WHETHER S. P. SIX
SIX EIGHT CONFLICTS WITH
PROPOSITION NINETEEN. IT DOES
NOT. PROPOSITION NINETEEN DID
NOTHING MORE THAN SCALE DOWN
THE INHERITANCE EXCLUSION THAT
IS CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED
HE DID NOT SAY THAT EVERYONE
ELSE MUST BE TAXED. IF A
SPECIFIED CONSTITUTIONAL
EXCLUSION WERE INTERPRETED AS A
REQUIREMENT THAT EVERYONE ELSE
MUST BE TAXED. IN THE SPECIFIED
EXCLUSION FOR TRANSFERS BETWEEN
SPOUSES WOULD MAN THE DOMESTIC
PARTNERS MUST BE TAXED. BUT
THAT'S NOT WHAT THE COURTRULED
IN STRONG VERSUS BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION THE COURT RULED
THAT A VOTER APPROVED
CONSTITUTIONAL PROTECTION FOR
ONE GROUP DOES NOT PROHIBIT THE
LEGISLATURE FROM STATUTORILY
PROTECTING OTHER GROUPS OR
SITUATIONS SUCH AS DOMESTIC
PARTNERS. EXAMPLES OF THE
LEGISLATURE DOING JUST THAT
ABOUND. ARTICLE THIRTEEN
SECTIONS THREE FOUR SEVEN AND
EIGHT LIST ALL OF THE
CATEGORIES OF PROPERTY THAT ARE
EXEMPT FROM TAXATION UNDER THE
CONSTITUTION FOR EXAMPLE PUBLIC
PROPERTY CHURCHES HOSPITALS
SCHOOLS ET CETERA BUT THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE REVENUE AND
TAXATION CODE. HAS ADDED
SEVERAL EXEMPTIONS NOT
MENTIONED IN THE CONSTITUTION
INCLUDING VETERANS
ORGANIZATIONS VOLUNTEER FIRE
DEPARTMENTS NONPROFIT SCIENCE
LABS AND NONPROFIT BOOKSTORES.
CHANGE IN OWNERSHIP IS A TERM
DEFINED BY THE LEGISLATURE IN
STATUTE IT ALWAYS HAS BEEN.
OPPOSITION NINETEEN DID NOT
TAKE THAT AWAY OR PROHIBIT THE
LEGISLATURE FROM CREATING
ADDITIONAL EXCLUSIONS FROM ITS
DEFINITION. AND IT'S NOT
SURPRISING THAT PROP NINETEEN
PUT NO LIMITS ON THE
LEGISLATURE SINCE PROP NINETEEN
WAS A PRODUCT OF THE
LEGISLATURE. IT WAS YOUR OWN
ACA ELEVEN YOU DID NOT TIE YOUR
OWN HANDS ANYTHING TO THE
CONTRARY SUGGESTED BY THE
BILL'S OPPONENTS IS SIMPLY
MISTAKEN. HOWEVER IF THE CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE STAFF PREFER
AMENDMENTS OR A DIFFERENT
APPROACH WE ARE HAPPY TO
COOPERATE. I CAN MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND FOR WHAT
WE WERE GOING TO COME IN ON
THAT HERE IN JUST A MOMENT
REALLY GRATEFUL FOR THAT THE
PRESENTATION TODAY THANK YOU
FOR BEING WITH US SIR. RIGHT
TODAY'S IN GERMAN BUT WITH
ACTIVATED DO SEE THERE'S ANYONE
ELSE WHO IS IN SUPPORT OF THIS.
BILL SIX SIX EIGHT. HERE IN THE
SENATE CHAMBERS OF YOU PLEASE
STEP FORWARD NOW. HERRING SCENE
NO ONE WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE. HERE YOU SEE
NO ONE STANDING ROOM ONE TWELVE
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE. THAT WE'RE
GONNA CHECK IN WITH THE
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE
UP ALL THOSE IN SPPORT OF SB
SIX SIX EIGHT NOW. IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIX SIX EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME AGAIN ONE
ZERO FOR SUPPORT. IN A SURE WE
DO HAVE IT LOOKS LIKE ABOUT
FORTY IN Q. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER MODERATOR THAT PLEASE
PROCEED. WE'LL SART WITH
NUMBER FORTY NINE HE'S GOOD AT.
HI THIS IS GENETIC AND FOUND OF
SOUTH CALIFORNIA AND I'M IN
FULL SUPPORT OF SB SIX SIX
EIGHT I HAD NO IDEA THE
TIMELINE ON PROPOSITION
NINETEEN AND THANK YOU SENATOR
GREAT. THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
WE'RE GONNA REMIND FOLKS THAT
WERE TAKING- PUBLIC COMING HERE
IN WE'RE GONNA ASK FIRST AND
LAST NAME YOUR POSITION ON THE
BILL WE'RE CURRENTLY IN THE
SUPPORT- IN THE ORGANIZATION IF
YOU ARE REPRESENTING. THAT'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER. NEXT TO BE
FIVE FIVE TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS TAKE ORDERS ON BEHALF
OF THE FAMILY BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
JOHN ARE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
THERE'S COLOR PLEASE. NEXT B.
FIVE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS EILEEN C. I'M A
NATIVE TEXAN FRANCISCAN I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB SIX SIX
EIGHT BECAUSE THE FEBRUARY
SIXTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
DEADLINE BUT NOT ENOUGH TIME A
LOT F WORKING AND MIDDLE CLASS
I AM SO SORRY ON A REMINDER
CALLERS THAT WERE ONLY TAKING
COMMENTS AND I APOLOGIZE MA'AM
I DON'T MEAN TO CUT YOU OFF BUT
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE- FORTY
CALLERS IN THE QUEUE. SO WE'RE
GONNA REMIND FOLKS IF YOU COULD
PLEASE GIVE YOUR FIRST AND LAST
NAME ALONG WITH YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL- AND THAT'S ALL
OVER ACCEPTING AT THIS TIME
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
COOPERATION IN YOUR PATIENCE
WITH US. LET'S GO TO THE NEXT
CALLER. NEXT B. FIVE THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS SO COMMON THAT AIR
QUALITY AND I'M IN THANK THE
FOUR OF THE FIFTY STATES. THANK
YOU ALL FOR BRINGING THIS UP
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL TODAY NEXT CALLER.
NEXUS FIVE FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS GINA C. LOUIS
AND I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
S. B. SIX SIX EIGHT THANK OU
SO MUCH THANK YOU SO MUCH SIS
GOT OUR NEXT CALLER. NEXT TO
THE FIVE TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS MARK HALL I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL- I
DON'T THINK FAMILY FARMS HAVE
BEEN DEFINED AND- I ACTUALLY
THE SIBLINGS WOULD FORWARD
WITHOUT KNOWING THE IMPACT THAT
IT WOULD HAPPEN THANK YOU OKAY
THANKS. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PHONE CALL SIR THAT'S GOT
OUR NEXT CALLER. NEXT TO BE
NUMBER FOUR SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON IT'S
JENNIFER KENNEDY I'M AN
ATTORNEY IN LA COUNTY ON BEHALF
OF WORKING FAMILIES AGAINST
PROP NINETEEN I'VE BEEN WAITING
ALL DAY TO SAY I'M IN SUCH
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
VERY GRATEFUL NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT TO BE FIVE FORTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
YOUR SOLO- IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB TWO VICTORY THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT
IS FIVE OH FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BUT YOUR SURVEY I. THANK YOU
DOCTOR HOWARD GARRETT BACK.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
NEXT IS FIVE THIRTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS KIND OF
SOLOMON ATTORNEYS ARE GONNA
HILLS CALIFORNIA I AM STRONG
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL SIX SIX
EIGHT AND I HOPE THE COMMITTEE
RECEIVED MY LETTER OF APRIL
TWENTY EIGHTH. THANK YOU WE DID
MRS SOLOMON THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE CORRESPONDENCE LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER. NEXT IS ONE
EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS MICHELLE O'BRIEN FROM
ORANGE COUNTY AND I SUPPORT
SENATE BILL SIX SIX EIGHT AND
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES FOR ALL
OF YOUR HARD WORK I THINK THE
MACHINE THANKS SO MUCH FOR SHOW
IT'S GOT A NICE COLOR. NEXUS
FOUR SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FOR PRESIDENT YOUNG THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
HERE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANKS FOR STAYING NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXUS FOUR SIXTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CALIO REBELO
AND STRONG SUPPORT FOR ITSELF.
THANK YOU KELLY NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXUS FIVE FORTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS ROBERT AND ROLAND IN SONOMA
COUNTY AND AS A RETIRED PERSON
ON A FIXED INCOME HI- STRONGLY
SUPPORT SENATE BILL SIX SIXTY
EIGHT AND I THINK BECAUSE
SENATOR DATES FOR BRIDGES
ENDING IT AND HARD JOB
ASSOCIATION FOR MAKING ME
AWARE- I'VE JUST. BUILT WE YOUR
PHONE CALL TODAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH NEXT CALLER. NEXT TO
NUMBER NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS EARL
BRADSHAW I LIVE IN. CALIFORNIA
AND I'M STRONGLY SUPPORTING SB.
SIX SIX EIGHT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PHONE CALL NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THE NEXUS FIVE THIRTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS A LEASE YOUR COMPOST
MISSING FROM SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY AND SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF REPEAL PROP NINETEEN A
GRASSROOTS ORGANIZATION OF OVER
ONE THOUSAND FAMILIES WHO WERE
DENIED THE ABILITY TO EXERCISE
THEIR PROP FIFTY EIGHT RIGHT
BEFORE FEBRUARY THE SIXTEENTH
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT AND S. B.
SIX SIX EIGHT THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
NEXUS FIVE FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS KATHY
LANGE AND I'M CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT
EIGHTY SIX SORRY- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU SO MUCH
KATHY. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT
TO BE NUMBER FIVE OH FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MY
NAME IS LYNN HUGHES I'M A
RETIRED RESIDENT OF SAN DIEGO
COUNTY AND I WOULD STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX SIX EIGHT
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PHONE CALL NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. TEXAS FIVE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE FORTY
FIVE YOU'RE KNOWN COMMITTEE
PLEASE PROCEED. LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER. NEXT TO BE FOUR
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FINE FOR TWENTY FIVE YEAR IN
COMMITTEE PLEASE PROCEED. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THE NEXT TO BE
FOUR SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS STEPHANIE SAW AND
I SUPPORT STILL. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR CALLING NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. SIX OF THE FOUR SEVENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS MALCOLM BANK AND- I
WANT TO THANK THE HARD HOWARD
JARVIS ASSOCIATION SENATOR
BREAK NOW GOING TO THE
CREMATORIUM TO PICK UP MY DAD'S
ACTUALLY. FIX THIS YET- A
MALCOLM. APOLOGIZE LET'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER. NEXT IS NUMBER
ONE FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI JACKIE CODA ALAMEDA COUNTY
AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF THE
SENATE BILL SIX SIXTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH JACKIE NEXT
CALLER. MIXES FOR ELEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS TIM KENNEDY IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE SIX SIX EIGHT THANK YOU
THANKS FOR CALLING TEN NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXUS FOUR
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS KAREN DUNDEE I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SIX SIX
EIGHT I MET HOWARD JARVIS- TAX
ASSOCIATION MEMBER. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR CALLING NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT WILL BE FOUR FORTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
JACKIE'S THEM AN ESTATE PLANNER
FOR FORTY YEARS AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AS THE SIX SIXTY EIGHT.
BILLION THE PROPER ENGINE WAS
DEVASTATING. THANK YOU JACK
PAPER FOR YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY
THAT'S GOOD OR NOT OUR NEXT
CALLER. SIX TO BE FIVE THIRTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. IF YOU'RE
A LIFELONG RESIDENT OF LOCKING
YADA AND CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
SB SIX EXCHANGE AND ALSO TO
THANK SENATOR BEACH RECEIVE
YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE THAT'S
CORRECT CALLER. NEXUS FIVE
THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FIVE EIGHT I AM ELEVEN AM ON
DRAG OPRAH LORENA OTHER BRAKE
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU- I'M GOING
FOR. COULD CREATE APPRECIATE
SOMEONE. TO WORK IN DRIVING
WHILE. THANK YOU IT HAPPENED I
DID KNOW ANYTHING THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH LET'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER. NEXT IS BY
THOSE SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS SANDRA KAREN. AND
I'M A PROPERTY OWNER IN ORANGE
COUNTY CALIFORNIA. AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SENATE BILL
SIX SIXTY EIGHT AND I WANNA
THINK SENATOR BAYH. AND HOWARD
JARVIS THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR PHONE CALL. LET'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER. WILL NOW GO TO
THE FIVE FORTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS PATRICK
O'ROURKE PRESIDENT ELECT AND
JEWEL- I THINK UNDERPAID AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SIX SIX
EIGHT. THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT IS FOR
NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH THIS IS GORDON PATTERSON
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SIX
SIXTY EIGHT THANK YOU SENATOR
BATES SCORED WORK. THANK YOU
GORDON. LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
LINE. NEXT IS NUMBER FORTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I'M THIRTY
FIRST HI MISS STRONG SUPPORTER
OF SIX SIX EIGHT THANK YOU KATE
AND HOWARD JOBLESS THANK YOU SO
MUCH LET'S CHECK IN WITH OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT IS
FIVE FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS COUNCIL LEADERS FROM
GRANADA HILLS AND I'M A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF SB SIX SIX SIX
THANK YOU THANK YOU JOHN. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT IS FOUR
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS IN LINE CAN YOU HEAR%
ME YES SEARING COMMITTEE PLEASE
PROCEED. OKAY SO I'M A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF THE AT SIX SIX
EIGHT THANK YOU NO THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR CALLING IN PRESHEAF
THAT THAT'S GOT OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT IS FIVE FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BOOK
BOOK BOOK. NINE FIVE FIVE FOUR
SEVEN YOUR PLEASE PROCEED. WHAT
MAKES THE- BETWEEN THE
OPPOSITION HERE SIR ABOUT THAT.
YOU'RE ALL GOOD THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE'LL PUT YOU BACK ON HOLD
SIR HANG ON AND THEN WE'LL BE
BACK WITH YOU HERE IN JUST A
BIT. THANK YOU SO MUCH. SORRY
ABOUT THAT LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXUS FIVE
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS CHUCK CALLED CENTER
COUNTY I HAVE BEEN STRONG
SUPPORTERS BELIEVE SUCCINCTLY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL. NEXUS FOR SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CALLER HEARING
COMMITTEE PLEASE PROCEED. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT IS FIVE
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CARLA
PICCOLO WOULD WORK AND I'M A
RESIDENT OF SAN MATTEO COUNTY I
MEAN VERY STRONG SUPPORT AT AT
THE SIX SIXTY EIGHT AND THANK
YOU TO SENATOR BAYH. THANK YOU
SO MUCH CARLA LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT LINE MISTER MODERATOR.
NEXT IS FOR SEVENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS TRICIA CRANE I'D
SHARE A NEIGHBORHOOD
ASSOCIATION NORTHEAST NEIGHBORS
WE ARE RECOGNIZED BY THE CITY
OF SANTA MONICA AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SIX SIXTY
EIGHT AND THANK THE SENATE FOR
YOUR- CONSIDERATION. WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PHONE CALL AND
FOR YOUR WORK IT'S GOT OUR NEXT
CALLER. NEXT IS FIVE SIXTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS CLEAR OF ALL SAND
AND I'M A CIVIL RIGHTS PUBLIC
INTEREST ATTORNEY FROM LONG
BEACH IN LA COUNTY AND I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL SHOULD BE AND I
ALSO SUBMITTED A LETTER IN
SUPPORT TWENTY THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE
TIME TO WRITE AS WELL. LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CAR. NEXT IS FIVE
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS JOANNA BACK ON THE
PRESIDENT OF LOS ANGELES I AM
STRONG SUPPORT AT THE SIXTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH SIS GOT OUR NEXT CALLER.
WILL NOW GO TO FIVE SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
DRAKEHAD TO TELL ON BEHALF OF
THE PATEL FAMILY IN ORANGE
COUNTY I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB SIX SIX EIGHT. WHICH WE
WERE SHOCKED AND SURPRISED BY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. IT IS FIVE FIFTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME'S TIMOTHY HOLIDAY OF SANTA
CLARA COUNTY AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SIX SIX EIGHT
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE
CALL. LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. NEXUS FIVE FIFTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS SIMPLY
A GAVEL DOWN FROM LA COUNTY AND
ON BEHALF OF FAMILIES WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS KIDS I AM IN HUGE
SUPPORT ON THIS ON THIS SCALE
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR PHONE CALL
TODAY THAT'S GOOD OUR NEXT
CALLER. NEXT UP IS FIVE SIXTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS SERENA NG AND I AM ON A
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SIX SIX
EIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU SO MUCH READING NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT IS FIVE SEVENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH HI
MY NAME IS BRADFORD LINE AND I
AM A SENIOR CITIZEN HAS LIVED
IN PALO ALTO FOR OVER FIFTY
YEARS. AND I'M IN PALO ALTO AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT SENATE BILL
SIX SIXTY EIGHT BEAUTIFUL CITY
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR FOR
CALLING IN. LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER. AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU SO MUCH AS A MODERATOR. WE
ARE NOW GOING TO GO TO THOSE
WHO ARE OPPOSED TO SIX SIX
EIGHT. WE HEARD FROM THOSE WHO
WERE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT. WE'RE
GONNA START WE WON THAT LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS. WHO IS
REGISTERED WITH THE COMMITTEE
TODAY THAT'S VANESSA CHAVEZ
CHAVEZ WE'RE GOING TO WELCOME
YOU. BACK TO COMMITTEE YEAH
SHE'S WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION REALTORS YOU HAVE
THREE MINUTES WE'LL GIVE YOU A
THIRTY SECOND PROMPT. GOOD
AFTERNOON YOU'RE IN COMMITTEE.
HELLO CHEERING MEMBERS BUT I
CAN LOOK AT A CHILD INTO THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS. REGRETFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. I SEE
SIX SIX EIGHT. SIX DEFECTIVE WE
DELAY THE INTERGENERATIONAL
PROVISIONS N PROPOSITION
NINETEEN BY REDEFINING THE
CHANGE IN OWNERSHIP EXCLUSION.
I THINK SIX SIX EIGHT PICKS AND
CHOOSES WHICH PROVISION SHOULD
ADHERE TO THE EFFECTIVE.
DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION OF
PROPOSITION NINETEEN. BUT
DELAYED EFFECTIVE DATE HOWEVER
IT'S INCONSISTENT WITH THE
EXPRESS LANGUAGE OF PROPOSITION
NINETEEN WHICH IS INCLUDED IN
THE STATE CONSTITUTION.
CALIFORNIA COURTS HAVE HELD
THAT THE VOTERS SHOULD GET WHAT
THEY ENACTED NOT MORE AND NOT
LESS. IN DECIDING WHETHER A
PARTICULAR STATUTORY PROVISION
AMENDING AN INITIATIVE CAN GO
FORWARD. THE COURTS HAVE HELD
THE QUESTION WHETHER IT
PROHIBITS WHAT THE INITIATIVE
AUTHORIZES. OR AUTHOR I DID
WITH THE INITIATIVE PROHIBIT IN
THIS CASE WE FIND. THAT AT
LEAST SIX SIX EIGHT. DIRECTLY
ACROSS. THE BUT THE VOTERS ARE.
IN SOME THIRTY SIX SIX EIGHT
SIX THE CIRCUMVENT THE WILL OF
THE VOTERS AND ANY SUCH
AMENDMENT TO PROPOSITION
NINETEEN MUST BE SUBMITTED TO
THE VOTERS FOR APPROVAL EXACTLY
A CALIFORNIA BEGINS TO BRIEF
ITSELF FOR WHAT HAD RECENTLY
BEEN COINED A TRIPLE THREAT BOB
FIRES WITHIN THE RESOURCES
PROVIDED UNDER PROPOSITION
NINETEEN WILL BE OF GREAT
ASSISTANCE IN DEFENDING THE
MUCH NEEDED HOUSING INVENTORY
FROM RESIDENTS MOST VULNERABLE
IN THE BONFIRE EVENT. EVER SO
MORE IMPORTANT AT A TIME WHERE
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO FACE
THE HOUSING CRISIS AND ANY LOSS
TO EXISTING HOUSING SUPPLY WILL
DRAMATICALLY AFFECT THE
RESIDENTS IN THE AREA WHO ARE
ALMOST CERTAINLY. FACED WITH
DIFFICULT PEOPLE REBUILDING
FROM THE DISASTER CALIFORNIA
VOTERS RECOGNIZE THE MUCH
NEEDED CONTINUED FUNDING FOR
FIRE PREVENTION AND AT B. SIX
SIX EIGHT I THINK THAT THE
VOTERS WERE NOT JUDICIOUS IN
THEIR DECISION MAKING PROCESS
AT THE BALLOT IF FOR ANY REASON
WE RESPECTFULLY. REQUEST YOUR
NO VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR. WE'LL HAVE ONE. OF
OPPONENT LEADER- I'M GOOD AT IT
JUST ASK IF IT'S UNDER LOOK TO
SENATOR BATES HAVE A QUESTION
FOR YOU SENATOR BATES- SENATOR
HERTZBERG. HAS TO CATCH A
FLIGHT FOR AN EVENING MEETING.
I'M IN WHAT WE LIKE TO BE ADDED
TO SENATOR BATES BUT- I I'M NOT
AT ALL TEMPERATURES PART WOULD
YOU BE COMFORTABLE IF WE OPEN
UP THE ROLE. WE HIT THE PAUSE
BUTTON ON DISCUSSION ON THIS
ISSUE AND THEN ALLOW THE
COMMITTEE TO OPEN UP THE ROLE
TO ENSURE THAT WE GET SOME
HERBS FOR ON SOME MISSING VOTES
IT WILL IMMEDIATELY GO BACK TO
THIS DISCUSSION SIX SIX EIGHT.
IS THAT RIGHT AT MADAM SENATOR
CERTAINLY I REALLY APOLOGIZE
THANK YOU SO MUCH ALL RIGHT SO
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE
WHAT WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO DO
IS OPEN UP THE ROLE- SO THAT A
SINNER HERTZBERG IS ABLE TO ADD
ON. CENTER WE KNOW YOU'RE GOING
TO BE- ON SOME OF THESE AS WELL
ALONG WITH AS THE VICE CHAIR IS
WELL. IT IS SO- HERE WE GO SO
LET'S START WITH ITEM NUMBER
ONE AT S. B. THREE FORTY TWO-
IT CURRENTLY EIGHT TO ONE VOTE
MR CANAL PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT.
MEMBERS SENATOR ALSO. SUBMIT HI
GUESS WHAT I'M SORRY WHAT WAS
THAT THIS IS ITEM NUMBER ONE SP
THREE FORTY TWO. THEY'RE ALSO-
A SENATOR HERTZBERG. ALL RIGHT
THAT WE ARE GOING TO SHIFT
CLOSER ROLE THAT DALE IS OUT ON
EIGHT THREE ONE VOTE ALRIGHT
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE ARE NOW
GOING TO MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER
THREE SENATOR DODD- AS- ITEM
NUMBER TWO TO SEVENTY ONE- WE
ARE NOT TAKING ACTION ON TODAY
CENTER WINNER AND I'M GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON
COLLABORATIVELY ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB THIRTEEN CURRENT VOTE
IS THREE ZERO MR CONNEL.
SENATOR ALSO DRAWS- A SENATOR
HERTZBERG HIGH BIRDS BERG RA
FIVE TWO ZERO FIVE ZERO VOTE
NATION JAN FIVE ZERO VOTE THAT
BILL IS EVER CLOSE THE ROLLING
HIS B. THIRTEEN- ITEM NUMBER
NUMBER THREE THIS IS S. B. SIX
TEN AGAIN THIS WAS ITEM
FOURTEEN NOW ITEM THREE SENATOR
GROVE THE CURRENT VOTE IS THREE
ZERO MR NOW SENATOR DRUGS
THOUGH HI TORONTO HI SENATOR
HERTZBERG HIGH PERCH BIRD HI
FIVE ZERO AT THE FIVE ZERO VOTE
THAT DEAL IS THAT WE'RE CLOSE
IN THE ROLE- ITEM NUMBER FOUR
IS P. FORTY NINE. CENTER I'M
BURKE CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FOUR
EIGHT ZERO VOTE MR CANAL
SENATOR DURAZO TERRAZZO FIVE
FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO THAT DEAL
IS THAT WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN CURRENT VOTE
IS THREE'S INNER IS THREE ZERO
THIS IS A CENTER I. CASKEY BILL
ITEM NUBER SEVEN IS THE. FOUR
SIX SIX MR NOW. SENATOR NIELSEN.
SENATOR DRAWS. DRAWS A HI FOUR
DOES. FOUR EIGHT ZERO VOTE BILL.
SENATOR NIELSEN HI. FIVE ZERO
ALL RIGHT FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO
VOTE THAT DEAL IS OUT IT'S A
FIVE ZERO VOTE ON ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN SP FOUR SIX SIX THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER VICE CHAIR WE'RE
NOT GOING TO BE MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER NINE SPD FIVE FORTY
TWO CURRENT VOTE IS THREE ONE
MR NOW SENATOR ALSO. DRAWS FIVE
FORTY ONE FOR ONE VOTE THAT
BILL IS OUR CLOTHES IN THE ROLE
I DON'T NUMBER TEN- SP FIVE
FIVE THREE CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR
ZERO MR NOW SENATOR ALSO DRAWS-
FIVE FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO VOTE
AT THAT BILL IS OUT. ONE MOMENT
MEMBERS. WELCOME BACK. ALL
RIGHT- ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SP
FOUR EIGHTY FIVE CURRENTLY
ENJOYS A FOUR ZERO VOTE MR NOW
SENATOR ALSO TWO HOURS AGO HI
FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO VOTE THAT
BILL IS OUR CLOTHES IN THE ROLE
ALL RIGHT SO NOW WE'RE GONNA
JUMP BACK YOU ALL THE ITEMS
FIVE IN SIX. SO WE'RE NOW GOING
TO DO FIVE. ITEM FIVE ITEM SIX
AND THEN GO TO- OUR CONSENT
CALENDAR WHICH IS ITEM ELEVEN
SO LET'S JUMP BACK TO ITEM
NUMBER FIVE. CURRENTLY ENJOYS A
THREE ZERO VOTE THIS IS S. V.
TWO FIVE SEVEN MISTER NOW
SENATOR HERTZBERG. HURTS BERG
EYES SENATOR WIENER. WINNER HI
FI ZERO FIVE ZERO VOTE THAT
BILL IS OUR CLOTHES IN THE ROLE
I DON'T NEVER SIX SP FOUR OH
EIGHT CURRENTLY ENJOYS A THREE
ZERO VOTE MR NOW SENATOR
HERTZBERG. HURTS BERG RA
SENATOR WIENER WIENER FIVE FIVE
ZERO FIVE ZERO VOTE THAT DALE
IS THAT WE'RE CLOSE THE ROLE
WE'RE NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN THIS IS OUR
CONSENT CALENDAR WE HAVE ONE
DONOR CONSENT COUNTER. THIS IS
THE S. P. FIVE E. NINETY FOUR
MR NOW SENATOR ALSO. TORONTO HI
SENATOR HERTZBERG. PURGE BERG
RA FIVE TWO ZERO FIVE ZERO VOTE
THAT DEALS THAT WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE. THAT WE'RE NOW MOVING ON
TO ITEM NUMBER TWELVE SP SIX
ZERO ONE OR TWO ABOVE. CURRENT
VOTE IS TWO ZERO. MR NOW
SENATOR ALSO. SENATOR HERTZBERG
HERZBERG SENATOR WIENER WINNER
HI FORTY ZERO FOUR ZERO VOTE
THAT BILL IS OUR CLOTHES THE
ROLE ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN SP
SIX SEVENTY FIVE CURRENT VOTE
IS FOR EIGHT ZERO MR NOW
SENATOR HERTZBERG HERZBERG II
FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO VOTE THAT
BILL IS OUR CLOTHES IN THE ROLE
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN SP SIX
ELEVEN CURRENT VOTE IS TWO ZERO
MR NOW. SENATOR NIELSEN.
SENATOR DO ALSO. TORONTO A
SENATOR HERTZBERG PERCH BERG HI
FORD IS. YOUR SINS AND I WILL
SEND HI THAT IS A FIVE ZERO VIE
VITE. FIVE ZERO VOTE IT IS TIME
FOR SOME COFFEE FIVE ZERO VOTE
LAYSIN GERMAN THAT BILLS THAT
WERE CLOSE IN THE ROLE NOW I
NINE TWO ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN S.
V. SIX FIVE SIX CURRENT VOTE IS
FOUR ZERO THE SERVER NOW
SENATOR HERTZBERG. HERZBERG HI
FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO VOTE THAT
BILL IS OUT WE'RE CLOSE THE
ROLE IN ITEM NUMBER TWENTY ONE
SP FOUR TO FOUR IS ALREADY A
FIVE ZERO VOTE AND WE ARE READY
DISPENSE WITH THAT DEAL AND
THAT BILL IS OUT OKAY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MEMBERS CENTER
BATES THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH
INDEED TO ALL THOSE WHO ARE ON
THE LINE GIVE US AT THIRTY
SECONDS PLEASE.
AGAIN CENTER
BATES THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
INDULGENCE THEY'RE VERY
GRATEFUL. FOR THAT AS SENATOR
HERTZBERG IS LITERALLY JUMPING
ON A PLANE HERE IN THE NEXT.
HALF HOUR HE'S GOTTEN FEAT- TO
THE AIRPORT ALL RIGHT. SO NOW
WE'RE GONNA BE MOVING ON TO-
OPPOSITION THAT FOR THOSE WHO
ARE HERE IN THE CHAMBERS IF
ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO PLEASE
RISE HERE IN THE CHAMBERS.
KAREN SCENE NINE WERE IN
OPPOSITION OF SIX SIX EIGHT
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO ROOM
ONE TWELVE ROOM ONE TWELVE. SEE
NO ONE ROOM ONE TWELVE WE'RE
NOT GONNA GO TO A
TELECONFERENCE LINE- IF YOU'D
LIKE TO DIAL. 877-226-8152
YOU'LL TALK TO THE MODERATOR TO
GET YOU TO UP. IT'S ALWAYS TOLL
FREE LET'S GO TO OUR OPPOSITION.
PHONE LINES ON ITEM. SEVENTEEN
SP SIX SIX EIGHT MR MODERATOR
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. JOHN IF YOU
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
SB SIX SIX EIGHT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME AGAIN ONE
ZERO FOR OPPOSITION. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT TEN IN OUR
QUEUE. THE NUMBER FIVE EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MAKE INTO
WORDS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND OPPOSITION TO
SB. SIX SIX EIGHT THANK YOU SO
MUCH MEGAN LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. NEXT IS FIVE FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HEY
THERE THIS IS ACTUALLY FROM
SANTA CRUZ CALIFORNIA ARE
CALLING IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE CALL. LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER. NEXUS
FIVE TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LINE FIVE TWENTY YEAR IN
COMMITTEE PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU MR CHAIR MEMBERS MET THE
CORPORATE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TAX AUTHORITIES AND ALSO IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL AND
CREDIT FOR TIME WORKING
TOGETHER THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE CALL.
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. MIXES FOR SIXTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CALLER HEARING
COMMITTEE PLEASE PROCEED. LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT LINE PLEASE.
OKAY ANG ON ONE SECOND CALLER
PLEASE PROCEED. ALL RIGHT
MISTER MODERATOR MAYBE WE CAN
GET THAT COLOR BACK AT PLEASE
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT LINE.
ABSOLUTELY WE'LL GO TO LINE
FIVE SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS JENNIFER ALSO
FROM SAN FRANCISCO CALLING IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE CALL
TODAY LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE ANSWER MODERATOR.
SO GO BACK TO LINE FOR SIXTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
RYAN COUNTED FROM LONG BEACH
PERSON HOME BUYER IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU SO MUCH
YOU MAY HEAR OPPOSITION- VERY
GRATEFUL WE'RE TAKING A
POSITION RIGHT NOW IS P. SIX
SIX EIGHT THAT'S GOT OUR NEXT
CALLER. NEXT IS NUMBER FIVE
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS A BIG REBOUND FROM
LIVERMORE- YOU BE OPTION NUMBER
AND CALLING IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. WE APPRECIATE YOU
CALLING IN TODAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH THAT'S GOT OUR NEXT CALLER.
NEXUS FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THREE MAJOR RANCHO
CUCAMONGA SUPPORT SB SIX SIX
EIGHT. ALL RGHT THANK YOU SO
MUCH TERRY YOU'RE HERE SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION IN OPPOSITION
SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE WE JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE YOU'RE HEARD AND SAID
THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER IN
OPPOSITION OF. SIX SIX EIGHT.
NEXT TO NUMBER FIVE SIXTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
CHARLES WHITFIELD FROM SAN
FRANCISCO. CALLING IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO A SIX SIX SIX
THANK YOU FOR THE PRECIADO
THANK YOU SO MUCH THAT'S GOT
OUR NEXT CALLER. THE NEXT WE
HAVE NUMBER FIVE SEVENTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS KATHY
BOWERS FROM SAN DIEGO COUNTY
AND I SUPPORT. SENATE BILL SIX
SIX EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH YOU'RE VERY GRATEFUL
FOR YOUR PHONE CALL LET'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER. NEXT WE HAVE
NUMBER FIVE SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI I AM KAREN
ANDERSON FROM DANA POINT I'M A
THIRD GENERATION CALIFORNIAN
AND I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
THE SIX SIXTY EIGHT. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL TODAY LET'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER. AT THIS TIME
WE HAVE NO OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR SO WE'VE HEARD
FROM. THOSE WHO SUPPORT THOSE
WHO DO NOT. BUT THIS IS THE
PRESENTATION ONLY- INDEED THERE
IS A 100% COMMITMENT TO. MEET
WITH SENATOR BATES HER TEAM-
AND OF COURSE THE COALITION TO
START WORKING ON THIS. ISSUE AS
WE MOVE FORWARD AND GET JUST
WANNA TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND- BAITS
FOR YOUR- YOUR FOCUS ON THIS.
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO SEE IF
THERE ARE QUESTIONS CONCERNS
FROM COMMITTEE. PLEASE MISTER
VICE CHAIR AND THIS IS A
PRESENTATION ONLY TODAY MISTER
VICE CHAIR. YEAH MR CHAIRMAN
I'D LIKE TO- INQUIRE OF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE COUNTY IF
ONE OF OUR WITNESSES COULD
EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
THIS OWNERSHIP TRANSFER ISSUE
AND IF THE PROPERTY I'M SORRY
MR VICE CHAIR WHERE TO START
THE NEW POP IT DOESN'T TRANSFER
WITHIN THREE YEARS- WHAT DOES
THAT MEAN EIGHTY NINE POINT 9%
AND THEN IT GOES NOT WITHIN
THREE YEARS AS IT DID THERE
SEEMS TO BE THERE'S SOME
CONFUSION THERE AT LEAST THERE
WAS ON MY PART. GOOD MAYBE. ONE
OF OUR WITNESSES TALK WITH US
ABOUT THAT A BIT. WITH THE
WONDER THAT DESERVE. TRAN I
BELIEVE. THIS REPRESENTS A BIG
IMPORTANT ISSUE IN THIS IN THIS
WHOLE ISSUE. E. III I BELIEVE
THAT MAYBE OUR NEXT. BILL THE
NEXT BILL YES OKAY YEAH I JUST
DON'T WANT THAT TO SLIP BY NO
NO YOU'RE ACTUALLY RIGHT MR
MAJOR COULDN'T REACH YOU MORE
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
SO LOOK I. I THINK THAT- A
COUPLE OF ITEMS. BUT WE WILL TO
AVOID IS HAVE. I DON'T WHERE
YOU POINT ME ALL YOU'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO WORK FOR POINT. OKAY
SIR WINNER. THE REDDIT. I YOU
KNOW WHATEVER IT IS DUE TO WANT
TO CALM AND THE CONCERN- THAT
THAT THE PLAN OF THE BILL OR
EXPRESSING BUT I DO WANT TO SAY
THAT IN TERMS OF PUTTING ASIDE
WHETHER WE CAN CONSTITUTIONALLY
DO THIS I KNOW THAT IS A REAL
REAL ISSUE I KNOW THIS DEBATE
OVER THAT JUST IN TERMS OF ON
THE POLICY WITH THE VOTERS WERE
VOTING ON THERE WERE A LOT OF
PEOPLE MYSELF INCLUDED. WHO DID
NOT SUPPORT THE ORIGINAL
VERSION OF PROP NINETEEN FROM A
COUPLE YEARS BEFORE BECAUSE IT
WAS ALL IT DID WAS ALLOW PEOPLE
TO BUY AND SELL AND TRANSFER
THEIR BASES TO ANOTHER COUNTY
EVEN THOUGH THE ACCOUNT WAS
IMPETUS. WHITE BALANCE THAT AL
IMPROV NINETEEN WHY SOME OF US
WERE ABLE TO SUPPORT IT- WAS
BECAUSE IT ADDRESSED THE ISSUE
OF SOMEONE IN HER READING.
BASICALLY UP HOME FROM THEIR
PARENTS AND NOT LIVING AT
RENTING IT OUT USING IT AS AN
INCOME PROPERTY AND STILL BEING
ABLE TO HAVE THE FULL PROP
THIRTEEN PROTECTION WHICH WAS
NEVER THE INTENT FOR PEOPLE TO
GET PROP THIRTEEN PROTECTION
EVEN THOUGH THAT ALL LIVING IN
A HOME. AND SO PUTTING ASIDE
THE CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES THIS
RAISES REAL ISSUES OF THE
VOTERS VOTED ON THIS I THINK
WITH A CERTAIN UNDERSTANDING
ANNA AND I THINK WE SHOULD BE
VERY HESITANT TO CHANGE OUT
WITH US SAID I KNOW THE CHAIR
AND CENTER HERTZBERG SAID.
WE'LL BE WORKING ON THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH- SIR WE ARE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THOSE
COMMENTS ANYONE ELSE FROM
COMMITTEE. ALL RIGHT I'M GONNA
TURN IT OVER TO SENATOR BATES
FOR CLOSE TO THE ONE ITEM IS.
THIS CAN BE VERY SIMILAR TO
WHAT CENTER WE KNEW WAS GOING
TO SAY THAT ONE- I THINK THAT
THERE IS AREAS THAT WE NEED TO
BE ABLE TO. LOOK AT CLEANING UP
I KNOW THAT THERE ARE SOME
OTHER AREAS IT CENTER BATES
WILL WANT TO BE ABLE TO
EXPLORE- I THINK THE CHALLENGE
WITH WHAT WAS CURRENTLY IN
FRONT OF US TODAY WAS THAT THE
CONCERNED ABOUT HAVING TWO SETS
OF LAWS ON THE BOOKS ONE THAT
IS A CONSTITUTIONAL. MANDATE
THE OTHER IS A STATUTE PASSED
BY THE LEGISLATURE- IN THE
CONFUSION THAT THAT THAT THAT
WOULD BRING IN REGARDS TO
ASSESSORS ABORTED EQUALIZATION
AND THAT THERE IS A COMMITMENT
TO BE ABLE TO WORK WITH SENATOR
BATES MY EXACT WORDS THE CENTER
BASED IN PLACE FOR TRACKING
USER BASES- WE'LL SEND IN. A
REQUEST HERE STARTING NEXT WEEK
TO BE ABLE TO START GETTING THE
DATE ON THE CALENDAR TO BE ABLE
TO BEGIN TO TALK ABOUT THIS AND
THE REASON WHY WE HAVE
ADVANCED- THE INVITATION TO
SENATOR HERTZBERG CENTERS FOR
IS ALSO BEEN VERY INTERESTED IN
LOOKING AT- AREAS WITHIN PROP
NINETEEN HE WAS VERY FOCUSED ON
IT LAST YEAR AS WELL- AND THINK
IT WOULD BE FRUITFUL
DISCUSSION. I AM VERY GRATEFUL
TO THE- GOOD CENTER CENTER
BAITS FOR THE WILLINGNESS TO BE
ABLE TO ENGAGE IN THAT AND
OBVIOUSLY WE'LL BE ENGAGING IN
THE COALITION THAT SHE'S
BRINGING FORWARD AS WELL SO
THIS IS A PATIENT AT
PRESENTATION ONLY BUT I'D LIKE
TO BE TO. GIVE THE LAST WORD TO
SENATOR BATES FOR CLOSING AGAIN
SIR BATES THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR ON GOING WILLINGNESS TO
WORK ON THIS ISSUE CELEBRATES
AFTER THE CLOSE. I THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN CHOIR AND CERTAINLY I
THANK YOU FOR THOSE WHO SPOKE
ENOUGH SUPPORT IN THOSE WHO
SPOKE IN OPPOSITION I THINK THE
MOST UP FUNDAMENTAL DISCUSSION
THAT HAS TO GO FORWARD WITH-
YOUR COMMITMENT THAT WE WILL.
CONVENE A WORKING GROUP A
STAKEHOLDER GROUP- IF YOU WILL-
TO EXPLORE. THE ISSUES
REGARDING I THINK WHAT MR
BIDDLE BROUGHT TO THE
DISCUSSION THE QUESTION OF
CONSTITUTIONAL CONFLICTS ARE.
THAT THE BILL IN ITS CURRENT
FORMED- PRESENT HE CITED LEGAL
AUTHORITY THAT CHANNEL. THE
NOTION. DELAYING AND- RUNS
AFOUL. THE CONSTITUTIONAL
PROTECTION OF. PROP NINETEEN
AND- I'M NOT GOING TO GET INTO
THE DEBATE OF WHY I DON'T AGREE
WITH THAT BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
REPEALING IT. WE'RE GIVING AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE ON. ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE ISSUE ARE TAX
AGENCIES THAT ARE PEOPLE WHO
ARE AFFECTED AND THAT'S ACROSS
THE BOARD. HOW TO. FIND A
RESOLUTION ABOUT SO- WE GOTTA
ROLL UP OUR SLEEVES TAKE A-
HARD SHOT AT IT AND- HOPEFULLY.
WE WILL GET TO THAT IN A
PERFECT SPOT TO REBALANCE SAID
DAN AND TO. REFLECT WHAT THE
VOTERS VOTED ON- WITH PROP
NINETEEN POUNDS HOPEFULLY I'LL-
THAT'LL RESOLVE IT ON ALL
FRONTS I WILL MENTION THAT A
CONSTITUENT OF MINE SPENT.
TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS. A
VERY- SINGLE MOM. SHE IS A
REALTOR AND SHE- WAS SO QUITE
FRIGHTENED WITH WHAT WAS
HAPPENING BECAUSE THAT
PARTICULAR PROPERTY THAT SHE
ALWAYS HAS BEEN A MAINSTAY. HI
IN HER LIFE FOUR. AS A RENTAL
AND CERTAINLY PASSING TO OUR
CHILDREN. WHO ARE IN A SIMILAR
SITUATION SO. THAT THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT ISSUES AND I THINK
WE CAN ADDRESS THOSE WITH OUR
GROUP. SO WITH THAT. THANK YOU
AND- WE CAN. WE ON TO MY- IF WE
HAVE TO BUILD IF BASED YOU HAVE
A WAY YOU WOULD LIKE TO DO TO
MASSAGES- YES MA'AM THANK YOU
MUCH WE'RE NOT GONNA BE MOVING
ON ITEM EIGHTEEN SP SEVEN OH
SIX OF FLORES YOUR CENTER BATES
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU-
FIND ME. TALKING POINTS HERE.
SO MY SECOND BILL IS AND IT
STARTED WITH GOOD MORNING BUT I
THINK- WE'VE KIND OF PASS THERE
HAVEN'T WE- THANK YOU GUYS FOR
HANGING IN THERE. R. S. B.
SEVEN OH SIX CLARIFIES THAT A
CHANGE OF CONTROL IN A
CORPORATE ENTITY OCCURS IF 90%
OF THE OWNERSHIP INTERESTS IN
THAT ENTITY. CHANGES HANDS WITH
THE WITHIN ANY THREE YEAR
PERIOD. EVEN IF NO ONE PERSON
GETS A MAJORITY INTEREST IN THE
LEGAL ENTITY. THIS CHANGING
CONTROL WOULD TRIGGER A CHANGE
OF OWNERSHIP AND REASSESSMENT
OF THE CORPORATIONS REAL
PROPERTY. FOR PROPERTY TAX
PURPOSES. CURRENTLY PROPOSITION
THIRTEEN OF NINETEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT ENSURES THAT PROPERTY
TAXES DO NOT GET OUT OF
CONTROL. FOR ANY CALIFORNIA
HOMEOWNER OR BUSINESS HOWEVER
THERE IS AN ANTI GUY AMBIGUITY
IN. IT THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED A PRIME EXAMPLE IS
THE TWO THOUSAND SIX PURCHASE
OF A HOTEL IN SANTA MONICA.
WHERE THE PURCHASER AND
REALIZED HE COULD STRUCTURE.
THE TRANSACTION WITH THE POWER
TO ANY ONE ENTITY OWNING A 50%
MAJORITY SHARE IN THE PROPERTY.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT 100% OF
THE OWNERSHIP OF THE HOTEL. DID
CHANGE HANDS THE PROPERTY WAS
NOT REASSESS. RESULTING IN A
TAX LOSS TO LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
OF OVER A MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY. YES B. SEVEN OH SIX
WOULD INSTEAD. SAY THAT A
CHANGE IN OWNERSHIP OCCURS WHEN
90% OF A LEGAL ENTITIES
OWNERSHIP INTEREST TRANSFERS IN
A SINGLE. TRANSACTION IN THE
BOARD OF EQUALIZATION ANALYSIS
OF SP THIRTEEN NINETEEN WHICH
WAS MY BILL LAST YEAR. THAT WAS
IDENTICAL TO THIS BILL IT WAS
ESTIMATED THAT THE ANNUAL
REVENUE GAINS. COULD AMOUNT TO
ABOUT. THREE HUNDRED AND FORTY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
STATE. THIS IS SIGNIFICANT A
SIMILAR BILL SB TWO FIFTY NINE.
WHICH I AUTHORED IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN DID PASS OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE- SIX TWO ZERO ZERO.
THAT BILL WOULD HAVE ALSO
TRIGGERED REASSESSMENT WHEN 90%
OF THE DIRECTOR INDIRECT
OWNERSHIP INTERESTS TRANSFER IN
A SINGLE. PLANT TRANSACTION IN
A THREE YEAR PERIOD. YES B.
SEVEN OH SIX DOES NOT FROM
THIRTEEN. SIMPLY JUST HOW IT IS
INTERPRETED IN STATUTE. I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK ERIC MESQUITE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
ROUNDTABLE AND SCOTT KAUFMAN
WITH THE HOWARD JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION. WHO ARE
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH INNERVATES
ALRIGHT SO LAZY GENERAL GONNA
GO TO OUR LIVE TELECONFERENCE
LINE WE'RE GONNA START WITH
THAT ERICA MAY KEEP THE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS ROUNDTABLE.
MR MACKEY YOU ARE THREE MINUTES
I'LL GIVE YOU THIRTY SECOND
PROMPT THE FLOOR IS YOURS SIR
YOU'RE NOW IN COMMITTEE PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS ERIC
MINSKY REPRESENTING THE
BUSINESS ROUNDTABLE SUPPORT AT
THE SEVEN OF THE- AT THE TURN
OF THE WELL THOUGHT OUT
CAREFULLY BALANCED MEASURE TO
ADDRESS THE TAX PLANNING
OPPORTUNITY THAT HAS TURNED
INTO A POTENTIAL FOR ABUSE. OCT
THIRTEEN PROPERTIES ONLY WE GET
THAT UPON A CHANGE OF
OWNERSHIP. UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW
CORPORATION SEPARATE LEGAL
IDENTITIES FROM THEIR
SHAREHOLDERS AND CAN OWN
PROPERTY IN THEIR OWN MINI.
FIRSTLY THE AVERAGE SHAREHOLDER
HAS NO RIGHT TO DEATH OCCUPIED
OR DISPOSE OF PROPERTY. IF YOU
THINK ABOUT IT THEN IT FEEDS
THEM ARGUE PROP THIRTEEN SHOULD
ONLY RESET THE CORPORATE OWNED
PROPERTY WHEN THE CORPORATION
ITSELF SOLD THAT PROPERTY TO AN
UNRELATED PERSON OR ENTITY. AND
NOT WHEN THE OWNERSHIP INTEREST
MY CORPORATION TRANSFERRED AND
YOU KNOW THAT WAS ACTUALLY A
RECOMMENDATION OF THE ORIGINAL
PASSPORT WHO- THAT WAS FORMED
UNDER THE AUSPICES. OF THE
ASSEMBLY REVENUE TAX COMMITTEE
AFTER PROP THIRTEEN PASSED THAT
TEST SCORES. BUT WHEN THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPTED
IMPLEMENTING LEGISLATION NOR
THAT SEPARATE ENTITY
RECOMMENDATION AND BREAK
STRUCTURE WE HAVE TODAY AND
TODAY IS 50% OF THE OWNERSHIP
INTERESTS OF THE BATH IN A
SINGLE PERSON OR ENTITY THE
ULTIMATE CONTROL THAT AND HE IS
BEING TRANSFERRED. AND THAT NEW
MAJORITY INTEREST HOLDER
CONTENT TERMING THE DISPOSITION
OF CORPORATE PROPERTY WAS ALSO-
BEING TO BE A CHANGE OF
OWNERSHIP OF THAT CORPORATE
PROPERTY BUT IT'S WITH THE
LIMITED FICTION THAT WAS
ACTUALLY NOT THE PROP THIRTEEN
FORTY. BUT WITH THE DOCTOR THE
LEGISLATURE BECAUSE THEY
THOUGHT IT WOULD BOUNCE THE
RELATIVE TAX BURDEN TO
BUSINESSES. AND RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTY. BUT IT BECAME- A
OPPORTUNE FOR SURE ATTACKS
PLANNERS WHEN THE REAL THEY
COULD TRANSFER ALL THE- AND-
THREE THREE THREE. ENTITIES
KEEPING EACH OF THE TRANSFEREE
OWNERSHIP INTEREST BELOW FIFTY
PERCENT. AND COULD AFFECT WE
SELL PROPERTY WITHOUT CAUSING
THE CHANGE OF OWNERSHIP. AND
REINVESTMENT OF THE PROPERTY.
OF THE- PLANNING OPPORTUNITY.
BECAME AN ALL CONTEMPT THE
POTENTIAL FOR ABUSE. AND THAT'S
WHAT THE READER- BIG MENTION
THE OCEAN AVENUE LLC CASE
INVOLVING- THE MICHAEL DELL
TRANSACTION. THAT WOULD BE SO
BY- FIFTY SEVEN OF THE- THAT'S
WHAT THE BILL WOULD- I WOULD
LIKE TO RESPOND BRIEFLY TO JUST
ONE OF THE CONCERNS RAISED BY
THE OPPONENT. THE COMPANY THAT
THE GOVERNMENT PICKED LOWERS
THE EXISTING STANDARD FOR
CHANGE OF OWNERSHIP BECAUSE THE
PARTS FROM THE CURRENT 50%
STANDARD IN EXISTING LAW. BUT
THAT THE MISUNDERSTANDING OF
CURRENT LAW. UNDER CURRENT LAW
A CHANGE OF OWNERSHIP OF A
CORPORATE ON PROPERTY OCCURS
WHEN A PERSON THE PAIN CONTROL
OF MORE THAN 50% OF THE VOTING
STOCK OF SELLING AND IT. SO
UNDER LAW THE BILLING ENTITY SO
100% OF THE STOCK. WITHOUT
TRIGGERING A CHANGE OF
OWNERSHIP SO LONG AS NO ONE
PERSON. PHONE TOWARD THE OF THE
BUYER'S PHONE FOR THAN 50% OF
THE STOCK. THAT'S WHAT CREATES
THE PROBLEM IN FACT FIFTY SEVEN
OH SIX RAMAGE. THIRTY SECOND
SEVEN OF THE FIRST. SURE AT OH
SIX THE FIRST. FOCUSES ON WHAT
ITS SOUL AND IT'S NOT WHAT IT'S
UNDER CONTROL FIVE SINGLE
PURCHASER. FOR THE QUOTE. BUT I
THINK THE REASON MEASURED
APPROACH THAT WOULD ELIMINATE
POTENTIAL COULD BE USE. AND
GLADLY RAISE MUCH NEEDED
REVENUE FOR SCHOOLS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AROUND PEOPLE
STRONGLY RECOMMEND THE INDOOR
TWO. THIRTY SEVEN OF IFTY
BANKS IN A DEBATE FOR
SPONSORSHIP AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE SEX WITH
HIM. THANK YOU SO MUCH JUST TO
MAKE A VERY GATEFUL AND THEY
SING GERMAN WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
GOING TO THE MAN WHO HAS BEEN
HERE FROM THE BEGINNING THAT
HIS NAME IS SCOTT KAUFMAN FROM
THE HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION. SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF SB. SEVEN OH SIX
MISTER COFFIN. BEING HERE ALL
DAY SIR PUTS. INTO PERSPECTIVE
THE WORK YOU ALL DO SO THANK
YOU FOR LET ME SPEAK TO YOU
AGAIN- CURRENT LAW ALLOWS FOR
PROPERTY TO BE REASSESSED WHEN
IT IS SOLD HOWEVER IF THE
PROPERTY IS OWNED BY MULTIPLE
PEOPLE OR- INTERPRETATION WHAT
QUALIFIES AS CHANGE OF
OWNERSHIP HAS SOMETIMES BEEN
EXPLOITED. IN A MANNER
INCONSISTENT WITH PROPOSITION
THIRTEEN. THIS OCCURS WHEN
INDIVIDUALS USE COMPLEX REAL
ESTATE TRANSACTIONS TO AVOID
REASSESSMENT EVEN. WHEN FAR
MORE THAN 50% OF OWNERSHIP
INTERESTS HAVE BEEN
TRANSFERRED. IT HAS THE EFFECT
OF CROSSING THE STATE LOCAL
MINUTES MUNICIPALITIES TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN LOST
REVENUE. FOR THE HOWARD JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION HAS
ALWAYS BELIEVED THAT ANYONE.
INDIVIDUAL OR BUSINESS SHOULD
PAY THE PROPERTY TAXES THEY
LEGITIMATELY- IF THE LAW IS
BEING ABUSED IN SUCH A WAY THAT
LEADS TO UNFAIR TAX POLICY IT
SHOULD BE CORRECTED. WILL CURB
OF USEFUL GENERATING MILLIONS
IN NEW REVENUE WITHOUT RAISING
TAXES FOR ALL THREE PROPOSITION
THIRTEEN. INSTEAD OF PLAIN
BALLOT MEASURE POLITICS OF THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE. LET'S PASS
THIS BILL TO PROVIDE TAX
FAIRNESS FOR ALL COMMERCIAL
PROPERTY OWNERS. WE ASK THAT
YOU SUPPORT SB. SEVEN THAT
PLAYS IN GERMAN WE'RE NOT GOING
TO GO TO THOSE WHO ARE ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF SEVEN SIX. HERE IN
THE SENATE CHAMBERS SEE SEE IF
ANYONE RISES THEY'RE NOT WE'RE
NOT GOING TO GO TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE. THING IF ANYONE RISES
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE NO ONE HAS
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO A LIVE
TELECONFERENCING LINE. THAT WE
ARE GOING TO ASK THE MODERATOR
PLEASE QUEUE UP. ALL THOSE IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN OH SIX NOW.
YOU LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB SEVEN OH SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR
SUPPORT. THIS TIME WE DO HAVE
ABOUT SEVEN IN OUR QUEUE. THE
SERVER NUMBER FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
JOEL CONNER I'M IN MADERA
COUNTY AND I SUPPORT SB SEVEN
OF SIX THANK YOU SO MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT LET'S GO TO THE
NEXT CALL. THE NEXT TO BE FOUR
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
COLOR YOUR COMMITTEE PLEASE
PROCEED. LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
LINE MR MODERATOR. ABSOLUTELY
NEXT WOULD BE NUMBER FIVE
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE FIVE THIRTY NINE YEAR
COMMITTEE PLEASE PROCEED.
THAT'S GOOD OR AN EXCELLENT
PLEASE. AN ABSOLUTE GO TO
NUMBER FIVE OH THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS REX W.
HINE ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT AND THAT'S
THE SEVEN OH SIX THANKS REX.
THAT'S GOT OUR NEXT CALLER.
NEXT TO BE FIVE SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE FIVE
SEVEN FIVE HEARING COMMITTEE
PLEASE PROCEED. THAT'S CORRECT.
NINE FIVE SEVENTY FIVE YOU'RE
IN COMMITTEE IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN OH SIX PLEASE PROCEED.
KAREN ANDERSON AND I'M IN THE
COURT OF F. B. SEVEN OH SIX AND
THEN POINT. THANK YOU SO MUCH
KAREN PRECIADO GRATEFUL IF YOUR
CALL TODAY LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. NEGATIVES FOR SIXTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON JENNIFER KENNEDY IN
LA COUNTY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH APPRECIATE THE PHONE
CALL LET'S GO TO NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT TO THE THREE
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CHRIS
WHITE KHAKI WESTERN
MANUFACTURED HOUSING
COMMUNITIES ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN OH
SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR A GRATEFUL FOR THAT LET'S
GO TO THE NEXT CALLER. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE NO OTHERS
INTERVIEW PLEASE CONTINUE. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH VERY
GRATEFUL AND MR MODERATOR WE
ARE NOW GOING TO. CHECK IN WITH
OUR LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS-
OUR LEAD OPPOSITION WHEN THIS
IS LENNY GOLDBERG FROM THE
CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION MR GOLDBERG THREE
MINUTES I'LL GIVE OU A THIRTY
SECOND PROMPT. THE FLOOR IS NOW
YOURS IN OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN
OH SIX. THANK YOU SENATOR
MCGUIRE GOOD HERE IT'LL BE TWO
YEARS. BILL NOT ONLY DOESN'T
CLOSE THE LOOPHOLE AND THE
ABUSES THAT THE PROPONENTS WERE
TALKING ABOUT BUT IT MAKES
THINGS WORSE- THE FIRST THING
IS THAT WE INTRODUCED A BILL
LIKE THIS. MANY YEARS AGO AND
THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY SAID
THIS IS WHAT ROLE WE CAN'T GO
FOR A WEE ASPIRIN CANCER TUMORS
A LOOK AT THE PROBLEMS IN
CHANGE OF OWNERSHIP. AND THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY SAID WE
CAN'T GO FOR THAT THAT'S- THE
FACT IS THAT NOT ONLY IS THIS.
LITTLE CONTINUES BECAUSE WITH
THE THREE YEAR PERIOD YOU CAN
SELL 1989% OF YOUR PROPERTY AND
WHEN THE THREE YEAR AND YOU
BUT IT ADDS A NEW. PIECE OF LAW
WHICH SAYS THAT THE STOCK
TRANSMITTERS DON'T COUNT AS
CHANGE OF OWNERSHIP WE KNOW
THAT LARGE CORPORATIONS ARE
PAYING AMONG THE LOWEST
PROPERTY TAXES THEY CHANGED
OWNERSHIP YEARS AND YEARS. BUT
HAVE NEVER BEEN THE SS NOW THE
HISTORY ON THIS IS THAT SENATOR
CLINTON COP IN THE NINETIES AND
SENATORS KIA MARCUS YES IN THE
ARTS SAID LET'S TAKE THE
STANDARD IN MAMA. 50% SALANDER
AND MAKE IT CLEAR MILITANTS AND
AS SOON AS YOU MAKE IT A
CUMULATIVE SALANDER MUCH OF
THIS ONE CALL IS GONE THAT'S
NOT TO SAY THE CLOSELY HELD
BUSINESSES CAN LAST YOU WILL GO
ON FOREVER. WITHOUT BEING BSS
BUT IF YOU ALLOW FOR A
CUMULATIVE 50% STANDARD AT
LEAST- LOOPHOLE SAYS WHEN
CHANGING OWNERSHIP OCCURS AS
DEFINED IN LAW AT FIFTY PLUS
ONE PERCENT. THAT WOULD BE A
CHANGE OF OWNERSHIP GENERATE
UNION SAYS. BUT WHAT IS WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS PRETEND
BECAUSE THERE'S A CHALLENGE. TO
THE AS YOU KNOW WHEN PROP
FIFTEEN AND WAY. A BIG
CHALLENGE TO REFORM THIS THAT
IS BROKEN INTO WORK IN SOME OF
WHOM PAUL. BUT THE INTENT HERE
IS TO PUT LIPSTICK ON A PIG
BASED. BASICALLY TO SAY- WE'VE
CLOSED THIS. NOW YOU KNOW
MARGIE YOUR GIVE. NOW MARCH OLD
GALA DAYS ALL THESE YEARS MANY
OF THESE ACCOUNT TRANSACTIONS
OCCUR ALL THE TIME AND THE
NOTION THAT THIS BILL WILL PUT
AN END TO THE ABUSES IS ON ITS
FACE THE ABSURD BECAUSE YOU CAN
EASILY SEE. THERE IT CAN BE
AVOIDED BY ANY LAWYER. CAN BE
REALISTIC NUGENT. WHO SAYS ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE TO HAVE BUT- IN
THE CALLED FOR IN THE BILL.
WILL SELL AT NOW PERCENT TAKE
OUR MEN THEN IT USED YEARS IN
THE CENTURY THAT. CHORUSES THE
MIDST NOW WE MAY THE SENATOR
HERTZBERG I THINK PROBABLY
GONNA. THAT SAID LET'S THIS TO.
OF CLOSE THE LOOP. I MEAN I
WOULD. IT IS. COULD A TASK
FORCE TO GROUP OF HEADS WORKING.
AS YOU DO NOT SIX EIGHT THIRTY
A WHAT IS REALLY THE BEST WAY
TO CLOSE. THESE LOOPHOLES I
DON'T. THAT A SOME BUT IT'S-
LOT BETTER YOU CAN DO SOMETHING
BUT THIS BILL DOES NOTHING AND
MAKES IT WORSE BY EXEMPTING
PUBLICLY TRADED CORPORATIONS
AND SHARES IN STOCK JUST YET HE
NOT WITHSTANDING- IT IS WORSE
THAN CURRENT LAW. AND IT DOES
NOTHING TO STOP THE ABUSES. IN
THE CURRENT PROPERTY TAX. MR
GOLDBERG THANK YOU SO THAT'S
GOLD. WITH THE CAL TAX IS. JUST
WANT THE RECORD TO KNOW THAT.
BOTH MRMAKE KEY AS WELL AS MR
GOLDBERG DID GET SOME EXTRA
TIME IS MR MACKEY WHEN. I
ALLOWED HIM TO BE ABLE TO GO
ABOUT THIRTY SECONDS OVER HERE
AND SAME WITH MR GOLDBERG- IT'S
EQUAL TIME. FOR EACH TEAM JUST
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
WAS CLEARED THANK YOU AGAIN MR
GOLDBERG FOR PARTICIPATING
TODAY NO HE'S GONNA HANG ON
WITH US ON THE LINE. ALL RIGHT
SO THIS ENGINE AND WE ARE NOT
GOING TO TAKE A LOOK AT ANYONE
ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SEVEN OH
SIX IF YOU COULD PLEASE STAND
NOW. SEE NO ONE STAND RIGHT NOW
I'M GONNA GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE
CENTER DRAWS- ANY GUESSES ON
ROOM ONE TWELVE. PROBABLY NOT.
YOU ARE ACTUALLY RIGHT NO ONE
IS IN ROOM ONE TWELVE SO IT'S A
IT'S GOOD STUFF. DRESSES LIKE A
HIKE ON THE LOAN SO- WE ARE NOW
GOING TO. GO TO OUR PHONE LINES
THAT WE WELCOME YOUR PHONE
CALLS AT. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO
TWO SIX EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO. WE
ARE GOING TO ASK THE MODERATOR
TO POLICE QUEUE UP ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS. IN
OPPOSITION TO SEVEN OH SIX NOW.
IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN OF SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. N. ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. WE DO HAVE LOOKS
LIKE TWO IN OUR QUEUE. WHO ARE
THE NUMBER FIVE NINETY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AT THE CAPITOL
ENTERED SANTA CRUZ I'M CALLING
IN OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN OR
SIX. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL THIS CURRENT X.
COLOR. NEXT IN THE LINE OF FIVE
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
COLOR HEARING COMMITTEE PLEASE
PROCEED. ALL RIGHT LET'S GO TO
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. I
ABSOLUTELY- LOOKS LIKE FIVE
EIGHTY NINE REJOINED BY MAY I
PLEASE GO AHEAD ABOUT. A YEAR
HI THIS IS JAMES AFTER THE
CALIFORNIA TAX IN OPPOSITION OF
SEVEN ZERO FAX. I DO NOT WANT
TO BATTLE BUSINESSES WITH
ADDITIONAL EXPENSES THEY'RE
ALREADY LEADING THE STATEMENT
AROUND. OUR BUSINESSES HERE AND
NOT THE OTHER ATTACKS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU. LET'S
GO TO A NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE NO OTHERS IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER MODERATOR
HAS BEEN WORKING HARD TODAY SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
MODERATOR WE ARE GOING TO RIGHT
NOW BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
DC POLICE CENTER WINNER. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN I BUT YOU KNOW
I APPRECIATE WHAT THE AUTHOR IS
YOU KNOW TRYING TO DO BUT I- I
DON'T SUPPORT- THIS BILL-
UNITING THE ULTIMATE SOLUTION
WOULD BE- TO NOT HAVE LARGE
COMMERCIAL PROPERTY- INCLUDED
IN PROP THIRTEEN AT ALL I- YOU
KNOW I THINK ONE OF THE OWNERS.
I WAS NOT HERE IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT SO- CENTER NO
THINKING CORRECT ME IF I'M IF
I'M WRONG ALTHOUGH MY
UNDERSTANDING IS- WHEN PEOPLE
IN THE CAMPAIGN FOR. PROP
THIRTEEN WAS ABOUT PEOPLE'S
HOMES- AND PEOPLE NOT LOSING
THEIR HOMES ESPECIALLY PEOPLE
ON FIXED INCOMES. AND THE FACT
THAT LARGE YOU KNOW THESE.
BUILDINGS IN DOWNTOWN SAN
FRANCISCO OUR DOWNTOWN LA IS
HIGH RISES- OR DISNEYLAND'S- OR
ARE OR OR THE GOOGLE CAMPUS OR
INCLUDED A PROP THIRTEEN IS OUR
YOU KNOW HONESTLY IS ABSURD.
AND THE FACT THAT YOU CAN
EFFECTIVELY SELL PROPERTY- AND
COMMERCIAL PROPERTY AND NOT
HAVE A REASSESSMENT OF THE
EXERCISE INSULT TO INJURY
BECAUSE OF COURSE PEOPLE CAN'T
DO THAT WITH OUR HOME- I THINK
THAT THERE. COULD BE A WAY TO
CLOSE A LOOPHOLE OR
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE IT
LEGISLATIVELY- I DON'T THINK
THAT THIS PROPOSAL REALLY DOES
THAT EFFECTIVELY HAS TWO MAIN
EXCLUSIONS THE 90% THRESHOLD IS
TOO HIGH. AND IT DOES THIS IF
WE WERE TO PASS THIS
LEGISLATION IT COULD CREATE AN
ACCURATE PERCEPTION THAT WOULD
SOMEHOW SOLVE THIS PROBLEM. AND
THEN TAKE MOMENTUM AWAY FROM
EFFORTS TO ACTUALLY SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM. SO WHILE I APPRECIATE
WHAT THE AUTHOR IS TRYING TO DO
I DON'T THINK IT CUTS US THERE-
AND SO I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THIS. THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR
WIENER WOULD LIKE TO GO TO SEE
IF WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS COMMENTS MR MEISTER
DID YOU WANT TO CHIME IN ON
THIS. YEAH PLEASE RESERVATION.
D. O. N. THANK YOU SO MUCH- SO
THE VICE CHAIR IS MOVED THE
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO-
BEFORE WE TURN IT OVER TO
SENATOR BATES I JUST WANT TO
SAY FIRST AND FOREMOST-
GRATEFUL TO ALWAYS WORK WITH
SENATOR BATES TRULY- LOOK THIS
IS THE FOURTH TIME THAT THE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE HAS HEARD THIS
MEASURE. ADEN THE CENTRE BATES
AND I. E. A. R. TEAM HAD SOME
CONVERSATION ABOUT POTENTIAL
COMPROMISE. AMENDMENTS
UNFORTUNATELY WE- WEREN'T ABLE
TO GET THERE ON THOSE AND THEN
MENTION THE NAME IS WHAT IT
DELETED THAT. THREE YEAR WINDOW
SET BY THE BILL SO- WHENEVER
90% OF THE OWNERSHIP INTEREST
OF A LEGAL ENTITY CHANGED. IT
WOULD HAVE TRIGGERED THAT
REASSESSMENT OF THE PROPERTY-
THAT SAID- KNEW NO THAT WE
COULDN'T COME TO CONCLUSION ON
THE AMENDMENTS- CAN'T SUPPORT I
CANNOT SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
BUT I'M GRATEFUL. TO SENATOR
BATES FOR HER WORK. IN FOR HER
ENGAGEMENT AND KNOW THAT WE'RE
GONNA BE WORKING TOGETHER ON
OTHER ISSUES HERE IN THE WEEKS
AND MONTHS TO COME. SENATE
RATES WOULD YOU LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO CLOSE WE DO HAVE A MOTION ON
THE FLOOR BY SENATOR NELSON-
THANK YOU- TURMAN REQUIRING.
THANK YOU FOR THOSE COMMENTS. I
AM CERTAINLY OFFER THE
CONVERSATION TODAY ON BOTH THE
SUPPORTERS SAY ON TO THOSE
OPPOSED. I THINK WE DO HAVE TO
FIND A WAY TO TIGHTEN UP ON THE
ASSAULT. OPPORTUNITY FOR ABUSE-
THE- THE DISCUSSION GOES ON I
THINK WE NEED TO. YOU KNOW GET
THEIR HIGH AND NOT TRY TO
BALANCE AGAIN BECAUSE I THINK
WE HEARD LOUD AND CLEAR WITH
PROP FIFTEEN. PEOPLE ARE NOT
READY FOR THAT HAS A LOT TO DO
WITH. WHAT TRICKLES DOWN TO
PEOPLE WHO ARE. LEASING AND
RENTING PROPERTY FROM THOSE WHO
OWNED A LARGE. CORPORATE JOB.
FACILITIES OF CENTER AND ALL
THAT THAT'S- A HUGE ISSUE OUT
THERE YOU KNOW ALL RIGHT-
COMMUNITIES WHERE PEOPLE. ARE
YOU KNOW I HAD BOGGED IN
COMMERCE AND HAVE SOUGHT TO. DO
DURING THE PANDEMIC BASICALLY
STAY ALIVE AND WHEN IT LOOKED
LIKE- THIS WAS GOING TO GO
THROUGH AND THAT THEIR THEIR
TAXES SO WE'RE GONNA GO UP
THERE FOR THEIR CUSTOMERS. YOU
KNOW RAN CHAN LEAF WAS GOING TO
GO UP THE EXPONENTIALLY I THINK
THAT THAT MADE THE DIFFERENCE
SO THERE'S A SOLUTION THERE I
ALWAYS LOOK AT THESE THINGS
THAT WAY. MAYBE WE HAVEN'T
FOUND IT YET BUT WE'RE GETTING
CLOSE I FELT THAT THIS BILL
SIMPLY. REMOVE THE TEMPTATION
FOR TO ABUSE AND IN THE INTERIM
BEFORE WE FIND THE PERFECT
SOLUTION TO CERTAINLY WOULD BE
A WAY THAT YIELD GOING FORWARD
AND NOT IN THE NEAR TERM ON THE
TO. GET ADDITIONAL TAX REVENUE.
FROM THOSE WHO DO SEEK. NINE TO
FIVE FIND A LOOPHOLE ANNEX AND-
ESCAPE. ARE THERE LEGITIMATE-
RESOURCES THAT SHOULD GO TO OUR
STATE SO WITH THAT THANK YOU
AND I WILL RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN I. BOAT. AND WE WILL REVISIT
THE ISSUE. THIRTY THANK YOU SO
MUCH CENTER BATES ALL RIGHT WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR B
SENATOR NIELSEN. MR CANAL IS
GOING TO ST THE FORMER MOTION
AND THEN. CALLED THE VOTE. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR MCGUIRE
NOW. REQUIRE KNOWS SENATOR
NIELSEN. NIELSEN HI SENATOR
DRAWS- TORONTO NO SENATOR
HERTZBERG. SENATOR WIENER
WINNER NO ONE TWO THREE THIS
ENGINE THE COMMITTEE THAT
MEASURE FAILS ON EIGHT ONE
THREE VOTE WE'RE GONNA CLOSE
THE ROLE- IT THANK YOU SO MUCH
AS SENATOR BATES. VERY GRATEFUL
FOR IT I WOULD BE MOVING ON TO
SENATOR BECKER CENTER BECKER WE
WELCOME YOU TO COMMITTEE WE
HAVE TWO ITEMS GIVE US A THIRTY
SECOND CENTER RECORD. BUT WE
ARE GOING TO GRANT
RECONSIDERATION ON A UNANIMOUS.
VOTE IS WELL SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH- SENATOR BATES. SENATOR
BAKER GIVE US THIRTY SECONDS
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK WITH YOU.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE
I WANT TO FIRST SAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU TO THE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE. HAVE BEEN-
PLOWING FORWARD STRONG-
THROUGHOUT THE DAY IT IS BEEN A
LONG ONE JUST WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU CENTER WINNER TO OUR VICE
CHAIR TO CENTER DRAWS THOSE
WELL. FOR ALL THE WORK- HERE
TODAY I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
TO MR CANAL TOUR SERGEANTS TO
THE TECHNICAL TEAM WHO ARE HERE
TODAY THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HANGING WITH US. OVER THESE
PAST MANY HOURS THESE ARE TWO
FINAL BILLS I EVEN THOUGH AGAIN
LIKE I SAID SOONER WEINER HAS
REQUESTED MULTIPLE TIMES TO BE
ABLE TO GO AS LATE AS POSSIBLE
FOR THIS HEARING. I WANNA ALSO
SAY CENTER BECKER YOU HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON BOTH
MEASURES YEAH BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT ON EIGHTEEN BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT ON NINETEEN WE'D
REQUESTED A TRUNCATED VERSION
OF YOUR STATEMENT- FOR BOTH
ITEM NINETEEN- SB SEVEN SEVEN
ONE IN ITEM TWENTY. SP SEVEN
EIGHTY SIX YOU DO HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT CENTER
BECKER THE FLOOR IS YOURS ON SB
SEVEN SEVEN ONE WE WELCOME YOU
TO COMMITTEE SIR. THANK YOU
RESEARCHER MEMBERS- I WANT TO
THANK THE STAFF FOR ALL YOUR
WORK. AND THE MEASURE EXCEPT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. AND
FIELD GOALS MADE LIKE TO VERY
QUICKLY LIST THE FORTY THREE
TOP REASONS WHY YOU SHOULD
SUPPORT. SB SEVEN SEVEN ONE
WELL YOU YOU'VE ACTUALLY PARED
THEM DOWN FROM SEVENTY SIX YES
THAT THAT'S GOOD STUFF AND I
HAVE A POWERPOINT PRESENTATION
A FEW WELL THAT'S GREAT I
THINK- DRAWS SO YOU YOU WANT
THAT POWER POINT MY RIGHT. YET
THAT'S A THUMBS UP. BUT THANK
YOU I WITH ME TO TESTIFY HERE
TODAY TOM KNOX. EXECUTOR ACTOR
VALLEY CLEAN AIR NOW. AND ALLIN
ABS FROM THE BEER QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT THANK YOU
OBVIOUSLY I STRUGGLE YOU WANT
TO GIVE US A QUICK THIRTY
SECOND SUMMARY OF THE BILL
PLEASE SERVICE DEPARTMENT- THIS
IS REALLY A PROACTIVE STEP
TOWARDS ENCOURAGING LOW INCOME
CONSUMERS. JUST WHAT THE OLDER
POLLUTING VEHICLES FOR A
CLEANER ONE AND REALLY EASES
THE FINANCIAL. BARRIERS AS YOU
KNOW WE'RE NOT GONNA HIT OUR
CLIMATE GOALS WERE NOT REALLY
GONNA CHEAP WHAT WE NEED TO- IN
LESS WE START GETTING.
WIDESPREAD ADOPTION B. B. T.
V.'S PARTICULARLY IN LOWER
INCOME IN DISADVANTAGED
NEIGHBORHOODS. AND THIS EFFORT
ENCOURAGING USED DVDS AND HIGH
MAS HYBRIDS. IS A STEP IN THAT
DIRECTION. IT IS GOING TO TAKE
A MOMENT BEFORE WE GO TO OUR
WITNESSES AT CENTRE BECKER IN
HIS TEAM THEY HAD BEEN DEEPLY
INVOLVED IN THIS BILL. REALLY
WE TRY TO MAKE THIS BILL AS
PRACTICAL AS POSSIBLE WHAT I
ALSO REALLY APPRECIATE ABOUT
CENTER BACKERS FOCUSES ON THIS
BILL. IS CREATING DEMAND FOR
USED CAR MARKET FOR THESE EV'S
BUT WE DON'T HAVE ANYTHING LIKE
THAT AT THE MOMENT- IT IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL TO BRING
EQUITY TO COMMUNITIES AND JUST
WANNA. TAKE A MOMENT TO BE ABLE
TO ACKNOWLEDGE SENATOR BAKER
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS- AS
WE MEET THESE. ZERO EMISSION
GOALS- AND HAVE TO PHASE OUT
THAT COMBUSTIBLE ENGINE THIS IS
GOING TO BE A BIG PART OF IT AS
WE MOVE FORWARD. SINCERELY
CENTER BACKER- YOU KNOW GOSH
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR WORK
YOUR TEAMS WORK ON THIS- IN THE
ENGAGEMENT ALL RIGHT. SO WE
HAVE TO LEAD WITNESSES TOM KNOX
FROM VALLEY CLEAN AIR NOW ALAN
ABBAS IN THE BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT. TO
OUR TWO LEAD WITNESSES WE WANT
TO REMIND YOU THAT WE HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. FOR LEAD
WITNESSES WERE GONNA ASK FOR A
TRUNCATED VERSION- THAT YOUR
STATEMENT TO COMMITTEE YOU DO
HAVE- UP TO THREE MINUTES EACH
LET'S START WITH MR KNOX FROM
VALLEY. CLEAN AIR NOW YOU ARE
NOW IN COMMITTEE. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU
YOUR MEMBERS ALL BE. MY IS TOM
KNOX I'M SELL IT. AIR NOW. AND
ON BEHALF OF THE DOLLAR
DISTRICT THE ADMIN. BECAUSE
PROGRAMS IN SEVENTY DOLLARS.
THE REASON THAT GREEN CARDS
ALSO IMPORTANT IS A LOW INCOME
FAMILY STATUS DISPROPORTIONATE
AMOUNT OF THEIR INCOME ON
TRANSPORTATION COSTS. A LACK OF
ACCESS TO TRANSPORTATION MAINLY
DUE TO YOUR EMPLOYMENT AND
EDUCATION OPPORTUNITIES. A
STUDY BY THE UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA DOWN THE
ONE WAY TO WORK OR TO DRIVE A-CAR OR HAVE ACCESS TO MORE THAN
TWO TIMES JOB OPPORTUNITIES
WITH WORKERS WHO DEPEND ON
PUBLIC TRANSIT. ACCESS TO
RELIABLE TRANSPORTATION IS
CRUCIAL TO MAINTAINING STABLE
EMPLOYMENT. REACHING
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES
CARING FOR FAMILY AND STAYING
HEALTHY. BY PROVIDING A SALES
TAX EXEMPTION FOR VEHICLES
PURCHASED THROUGH CLEAN CARS
FOR ALL SB SEVEN SEVEN ONE OR
THE- ECONOMIC MOBILITY BY
LOWERING TRANSPORTATION COSTS
FOR WORKING FAMILIES. WHILE%
HELPING THE STATE REQUIREMENT
AN AIR QUALITY GOALS. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. HEY MR
KNOX THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
WORK ON THIS- AND VERY GRATEFUL
FOR THAT STATEMENT. THANK YOU
FOR HANGING WITH US. NOT SO
LATE HERE INTO THE AFTERNOON.
LAZING GENTLEMAN I WORK IN NOW
GOING TO ALLE ABS FROM THE BAY
AREA AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT. MR ABBAS YOU HAVE
THREE MINUTES WE'RE GONNA ASK
FOR A TRUNCATED VERSION IS YOUR
OF YOUR STATEMENT. AS WE DO
HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
COMMITTEE MR ABBAS. WELCOME SIR
GOOD TO HEAR YOUR VOICE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR CHOIR MEMBERS
OF COMMITTEE I ALAN WITH BAY
AREA QUALITY. DISTRICT I'M
TESTIFYING TO EXPLAIN THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE CLEAN CARS
FOR ALL PROGRAM IN THE BAY AREA
TO SUPPORT EQUITY IN ADVANCING
A CLEAN CAR FUTURE. CLEAN CARDS
FOR ALL OF THE RETIRE AND
REPLACE PROGRAM INCOME
QUALIFIED RESIDENTS IN
COMMUNITIES DISPROPORTIONATELY
BURDENED BY POLLUTION CAN TURN
IN AN OLDER VEHICLE. AND GET AN
INCENTIVE TO PURCHASE OR LEASE
A NEW OR USED TO PLUG IN HYBRID
ELECTRIC VEHICLE OR FUEL CELL
ELECTRIC VEHICLE. IN THE TWO
YEARS THAT THE BEARING HMD HAS
ADMINISTERED THIS PROGRAM WE
HAVE SUPPORTED APPROXIMATELY
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED VEHICLE
PURCHASES. WITH TWO THIRDS OF
THOSE OCCURRING IN OUR MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
CURRENTLY DESPITE THE PANDEMIC
WE AVERAGE ABOUT ONE HUNDRED
FOR. A VEHICLE PURCHASES A
MONTH. THE HOUSEHOLD INCOME IN
THE VEHICLE CHOSEN DETERMINES
THE GRANT AMOUNT YOU CAN
RECEIVE FROM THIS PROGRAM WITH
GRANTS RANGING FROM FIFTY FIVE
HUNDRED TO NINETY FIVE HUNDRED
DEPENDING ON INCOME. AND THE
VEHICLE TYPE. BUT THE AVERAGE
CLEAN CARS FOR ALL VEHICLE
CURRENTLY COSTS TWENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS WELL THE
AVERAGE CLEAN CARS FOR ALL
INCENTIVE IS EIGHTY FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS. WITH THE
AVERAGE LOAN FINANCING BEING
FOURTEEN THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED.
BUT THAT STILL REQUIRES A
SIGNIFICANT OUT OF POCKET
EXPENSE FOR MOST ELIGIBLE
APPLICANTS. PROVIDING AN
ADDITIONAL INCENTIVE OR
LIMITING THE TAX BURDEN ON
INDIVIDUALS PARTICIPATING IN
THIS PROGRAM WILL HELP EXPAND
THE APPLICANT POOL AND SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA'S EQUITY IN ZERO
EMISSION BOWL. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
ANSWERING ANY QUESTIONS THAT
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
AS YOUR ABS PRE SHEET THAT
WE'RE NOT GOING TO LOOK TO- IN
PERSON TESTIMONY HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS. IF ANYBODY WOULD LIKE
TO GO TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN SEVEN ONE. PLEASE STAND
NOW CARRYING SEEN NO ONE IN THE
GALLERY WERE NOT GOING TO GO TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE. TO SEE SOMEONE
LIKE TO SPEAK HERE IN C. NOW
AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO
TOWARD TELECONFERENCE LINE.
THAT MR MODERATOR HAS BEEN BUSY
TODAY A LOT OF CALLS COMING IN.
MR MODERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO HAD TO GO TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB. SEVEN SEVEN ONE
PLEASE DO SO NOW. IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO. AND OF SB SEVEN SEVEN
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT. WE
DO ABOUT FIVE IN OUR QUEUE.
WELL SERVER NUMBER THREE EIGHTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME'S BILL MURPHY AND I
REPRESENT IF YOU SO CAN VALLEY
AND THE SO CAL AND THEY'RE KIND
OF CHAPTERS OF ELDERS CLIMATE
ACTION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR HANGING WITH
US TODAY AND FOR YOUR CALL
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXUS FIVE NINETY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
DEBBIE MY TELLS AND I WAS
POTENTIAL INTERFACE CLIMATE
ACTION WE REPRESENT EIGHTEEN
CONGREGATIONS BETWEEN SAN
MATTEO IN SUNNYVALE SO WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH DEBBIE LET'S
GO TO THE NEXT CALLER. THANKS
TO BE FOR NINETY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU I AM WILL
KRIEGER AND I'M PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THIS ON BEHALF OF THREE
FIFTY SACRAMENTO AND ALSO AS
THE OWNER OF PACIFIC FLEET
CHARGING. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT
UP IS NUMBER FIVE TWENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS JON
SCHAFFER FROM THREE FIFTY DOT
ORG IN HUMBOLDT COUNTY AND
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANKS TO- SENATOR MCGUIRE AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR YOUR HARD
WORK TODAY. WE LOVE HUMBLE
COUNTY THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE PHONE CALL LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT TO THE
FOUR EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SHE HELLO MY NAME'S
DIANE BAILEY I'M WITH MY MOST
PARK AND I REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT
FOR SB SEVEN SEVEN ONE CLEAN
CARTS FOR ALL THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE CALL
LET'S GO TO THE NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
OTHERS N OUR QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE ALL RIGHT MISS
MODERATOR WE'RE NOT GONNA GO TO
THOSE WHO MAY BE IN OPPOSITION
WE'RE GOING TO START OUT WITH
THOSE WHO ARE HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS WE HAVE NO. LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS. REGISTERED
THERE IS NO ONE HERE IN THE
SENATE CHAMBERS TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. LEGEND JIM WE'RE
NOT GONNA BE GOING TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE CHECKING IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. NO ONE IS IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WE'RE NOT GONNA BE GOING
TOWARD TELECONFERENCE LINE
CHECKING IN WITH THE MODERATOR
MR MODERATOR WE'RE GOING TO
QUEUE UP PLEASE. ALL THOSE WHO
ARE IN OPPOSITION I'VE SEEN SB
SEVEN SEVEN ONE NOW. WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB
SEVEN SEVEN ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. N. ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. YOU HAVE ONE IN OUR
QUEUE WE'LL GO TO NUMBER FIVE
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AT THE CLUB
AND ON BEHALF OF THE COMPANY
TAX REFORM REPATRIATION
CURRENTLY IN OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL AS WRITTEN THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN THE COMMITTEE
TODAY. CORBIN US AT IT YET
AGAIN CORBIN MISS CORBIN HAS
BEEN WITH US FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING AND MISS CORBIN WERE
REALLY GRATEFUL. THAT YOU HUNG
WITH US THE ENTIRE TIME THANK
YOU SO MUCH YOUR TESTIMONY
PARTICIPATION TODAY. LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER. THE NEXT WE
HAVE NUMBER FIVE EIGHTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CALLER HEARING
COMMITTEE PLEASE PROCEED.
THAT'S GOOD OR AN EXCELLENT
PLEASE ANSWER MODERATOR. AT
THIS TIME THERE ARE NO OTHERS
IN OUR QUEUE ALL RIGHTY THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISS MODERATOR
THAT'S BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE SO WHAT WE ARE
LOOKING FOR A MOTION. MOTION ON
THE FLOOR CENTER DRIVE SO IT
MOVES THERE WE GO SIR DRAWS
THOSE OUT LOUD AND PROUD WITH
THAT MOTION RIGHT THERE THANK
YOU SO MUCH AS CENTER DRIVE SO
WOULD LIKE YOU TO SEE IF THERE
IS ANY. CONVERSATION BY
COMMITTEE. HERRING XENON CENTER
BECKER AGAIN I MEAN I MEANT
WHAT I SAID IN THE VERY
BEGINNING. THIS IS A GREAT
DEAL. YOU WORKED INCREDIBLY
HARD. THIS IS GOING TO HELP SO
MANY CALIFORNIANS. IN THE YEARS
TO COME THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WONDERFUL WORK. PLEASE BRING IT
HOME WITH A CLOSE. THANK YOU
FOR ALL YOUR COMMENTS AND YOUR
PARTICULAR WORK TO SUPPORT
MISTER CHAIR ARE STRUCK LAST
YEAR I VOTE. ALL RIGHT WE HAVE
A MOTION BY SENATOR I WAS ON
THE FLOOR MR NOW PLEASE GIVE
THE FORM A MOTION IN CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR MCGUIRE
HI MCGUIRE. A SENATOR NIELSEN.
NIELSEN HI SENATOR DURAZO
TERRAZZO- A SENATOR HERTZBERG
SENATOR WIENER. THREE ZERO
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A THREE ZERO
VOTE A DRIVE SO I DON'T KNOW
WHERE WE- WENT BACK DOWN OF
COURSE WE HAD TO LEAVE THAT
LEAVE IT OPEN NOW FOR A SITTER
WE- WE'RE GOING TO GO. HUNT HIM
DOWN. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO
MUCH AS A THREE ZERO VOTES-
WE'RE GONNA HAVE THE SERGEANTS
CALL US HERE WINNERS OFFICE SO
WE CAN. HAVE HIM COME BACK CITY
IT'S BEEN ALL OVER IT THANK YOU
SO MUCH. WE'RE NW MOVING ON TO
ITEM. NUMBER TWENTY. SP SEVEN
EIGHTY SIX THOUSAND GERMANS ARE
LAST. ITEM OF THE DAY MISTER
VICE CHAIR. BY SENATOR BECKER
THIS DOES HAVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. MR SENATOR THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. BUT SHE REMEMBERS
WHEN I THINK AGAIN THAT YOU AND
THE STAFF APPRECIATE WHEN
HANGING IN HERE- FOR THIS WHEN
I PREPARED AN INTERPRETIVE
DANCE WELL FOR YOU THIS IS
GREAT YES DO YOU- TO READ- AND
LIVE IN THE FINAL BILL PRECEDED
BY A PRESENTATION. BUT I DO
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT YOU ACCEPT THE PROPOSED
COMMITTEE MEMON AS DESCRIBED ON
PAGE SIXTY NOW SAYS WE ARE
RESTORING EXISTING SUNSET- TO
THE BOARD COMPENSATION
PROVISION OF THE DISTRICT
ACTING WILL REVISIT THAT AT A
LATER TIME. SO REALLY UP WITH
THE DISOBEY OUT IS ABOUT THE
BINDING CAPACITY AND MR SURE
MEMBERS ARE STRICTLY ASKED FOR
YOUR I. VOTE ON THIS DISTRICT
BILL THAT WILL REDUCE THE
FINANCING COSTS FOR LOCAL WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER SENATOR
AGAIN CENTER BECKER IS A
CHAMPION FOR THE COMMUNITIES
THAT HE REPRESENTS WE REALLY
ARE GRATEFUL. FOR YOUR WORK ON
THIS SIR WE HAVE TO LEAD TO
SUPPORT WITNESSES THAT WE DO
WANT TO LET OUR LEAD WITNESSES
KNOW THAT WE HAVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT HEARING COMMITTEE FOR
THIS BILL WE'RE GOING TO ASK AT
THE LEAD WITNESSES TO PROVIDE
TRUNCATED TESTIMONY HERE TODAY
LET'S START WITH DOUG BROWN
HE'S THE OUTSIDE BOND COUNSEL
FOR VALLEY WATER. MISTER BROWN
YOU HAVE UP TO THREE MINUTES
BUT YOU DO HAVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN COMMITTEE MR BROWN
YOU. ARE NOW IN COMMITTEE
PLEASE PROCEED. IT A MEMBERS OF
THE MY NAME'S BROWN I MEAN.
FINANCE ATTORNEY WITH THE LAW
FIRM STRADDLING OKRA CARLSON
RALPH AND I'M HERE TODAY
REPRESENTING VALLEY WATER. THE
FINANCING PROVISIONS OF THE
SANTA CLARA VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT ACTIVE NOT BEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY. REVISED IN MANY
DECADES. AND VALLEY WATER IS
FOUND THAT THESE PROVISIONS
HAVE NOT KEPT UP WITH THE
GROWTH OF SILICON VALLEY AND
VALLEY WATERS WATER WATERSHED
AND OTHER STATUTORY
RESPONSIBILITIES. VALLEY WATER
BELIEVES THE MOB PROVISIONS OF
SB SEVEN EIGHTY SIX WOULD
UPDATE THE FINANCING ISSUES
CONSISTENT WITH THE CURRENT
BOND MARKET PREFERENCES AS WELL
AS THE STATUTORY POWERS
AVAILABLE TO OTHER LARGE
REGIONAL WATER AGENCIES. VALLEY
WATER WOULD RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AND I VOTE ON SB. SEVEN
EIGHTY SIX. MISTER BROWN THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT THAT WE
ARE NOT GONNA BE GOING TO
RACHEL GIBSON HE IS CHIEF OF
EXTERNAL FFAIRS FOR VALLEY
WATER THIS GIVES IN THE FLOOR
IS YOURS YOU DO HAVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN COMMITTEE- THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS RACHEL GET THEM AND I'M
KEEN THAT CHARACTERS ARE VALLEY
WATER. I MOTION YOU'RE EATING
AT YOUR CARE AND- YOUR IPHONE
TWENTY SEVENTY SIX THANK YOU SO
MUCH. MISS GIBSON THANK YOU
WERE REALLY GREAT PRICE I SAY
THANK YOU MS GIBSON AND MISTER
BROWN FOR HANGING WITH US. FOR
YOUR FLEXIBILITY TODAY KNOW
THAT WE'RE GOING LATE SO THANK
YOU MS GIBSON THANK YOU MISTER
BROWN. FOR YOUR PATIENCE WITH
COMMITTEE TODAY. WERE REALLY
GREAT FUN THANK YOU FOR CALLING
IN. IN GENERAL ARE NOW THE TO
BE LOOKING TO THOSE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BE HAD TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IN THE
SENATE CHAMBERS. WE DON'T HAVE
ANYONE RISING AT THIS TIME
WHICH MEANS MR NOW YOU KNOW
WE'RE GOING TO. ROOM ONE
TWELVE. MR CANAL LOVES ROOM ONE
TWELVE- E. THAT SEE HERE. WELL
I GUESS WE'RE NOT GONNA SEE
ROOM ONE TWELVE BUT I TAKE MY
WORD FOR IT I'M LOOKING RIGHT
NOW. ON THIS MONTH. THERE WE GO
MR NOW. IT'S ROOM ONE TWELVE.
HI AND THERE'S NOTHING
HAPPENING. SO WE ARE NOW GOING
TO BE MOVING TO OUR- WE WENT TO
OUR PHONE LINES AT TO BE ABLE
TO CHECK IN. WE'RE GETTING A
LITTLE PUNCHY HERE. TOWARDS THE
END OF THE DAY- WE'RE GONNA GO
TO OUR PHONE LINES IN CHECK IN.
TO SEE IF FOLKS WOULD LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF
SB SEVEN EIGHTY SIX. MR
MODERATOR IF YOU CAN PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK. SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN EIGHTY SIX
PLEASE DO SO NOW. IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN EIGHTY SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. THE N.
ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT. I
CURRENTLY HAVE TWO IN OUR QUEUE.
WE'LL START WITH NUMBER FIVE
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ANTHONY CAMEL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE. THANK YOU SO MUCHFOR
CALLING IN TODAY THAT'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER. NEXT TO BE
NUMBER FIVE NINETY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE CARD. ALL RIGHT
COLOR YOU ARE IN COMMITTEE
PLEASE PROCEED PEOPLE WOULD
LIKE. ALL THE- THAT'S A GREAT
VOICE HE HAD THAT GONE. ALL
RIGHT LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER- I. NEXT CALLER PLEASE-
MISTER MODERATOR. AT THIS TIME
THERE ARE NO FURTHER IN OUR
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A
MODERATOR I WE'RE NOW GOING TO
GO TO THOSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL WERE FIRST WE
DON'T HAVE ANY REGISTERED LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS IN COMMITTEE
HERE TODAY SO WE'RE GONNA START
HERE IN THE SENATE CHAMBER SEEN
IF ANYBODY WOULD LIKE TO RISE
TO SPEAK. IN OPPOSITION TO SB
SEVEN EIGHTY SIX HEARING SEEING
NINE. LET'S GO TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE WE'RE GONNA LOOK TO ROOM
ONE TWELVE. NO ONE IS PREPARED
TO SPEAK IN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
FOR THE FINAL TIME TODAY THEY
SEE JOHN WE'RE GONNA GO TO OUR
MODERATOR THE BEER TO CHECK IN
WITH MR MODERATOR MR MODERATOR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ALL OF
YOUR WORK TODAY WE ARE TRULY
APPRECIATIVE OF YOUR
PARTNERSHIP. LET'S DO THIS ONE
LAST TIME AND CHECKING TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
OF SB SEVEN EIGHTY SIX. WHO IF
ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN EIGHTY
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR OPPOSITION.
WE DO HAVE ONE IN OUR QUEUE.
HELLO TO NUMBER FOUR TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH MY
OPINION IS THAT I THINK THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE GONNA BE TAXED
ON THEIR PROPERTY TAX BILL
SHOULD BE VOTING ON THIS TO SAY
WHETHER THEY WANT THIS OR NOT I
MEAN BECAUSE THAT'S GOING TO
INCREASE THEIR PROPERTY TAX. IF
I'M RIGHT. SO I WOULD BE
AGAINST IT IF IT'S INCREASING
PEOPLE'S PROPERTY TAX WITHOUT
THEIR. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR CALL TODAY MA'AM VERY
GRATEFUL AND THANK YOU FOR THE
PATIENCE IN HANGING WITH US AS
WELL LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE ME
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
SEVENTY SIX IT'S GOT OUR NEXT
CALLER MISTER MODERATOR. AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO OTHERS IN
OUR QUEUE. PLEASE CONTINUE. ALL
RIGHT LAYS IN GERMAN WE'RE
BRINGING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
IS SEEN IF THERE IS. MR VICE
CHAIR IS- YOU KNOW FOR A
MOTIONS WITH THE MOTION ON THE
FLOOR. I BITE VICE CHAIR NELSON
THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR FOR
YOUR PARTNERSHIP OVER THESE
PAST MANY MONTHS WITH THE
COMMITTEE- ANYONE ELSE FOR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. HERE IN
C. NINE MISTER BECKER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. CHURCHES AND
WINNER MISS MY INTERPRETIVE
DANCE AND LIKE TAKE A FEW
MINUTES AND- THAT. WE DO THAT
BUT- I WILL SAY- THANK THE
CALLER- VOTERS WILL HAVE A
CHANCE TO DECIDE ULTIMATELY
SPONSOR AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE FOR HERE TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH SO
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR
BY THE VICE CHAIR VICE CHAIR
NIELSON MR NOW IT WILL PROVIDE
THE FORMAL A MOTION. AND THEN
CALL THE ROLE MR NOW. THE MORE.
IS DO YOU PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR SENATOR
MCGUIRE. I REQUIRE. A SENATOR
NIELSEN. NIELSEN HIGHS SENATOR
ALSO. DO ALSO- A SENATOR
HERTZBERG. SENATOR WIENER
WEINER HI FOUR ZERO FOUR ZERO
VOTE LAZY OVER THAT BILL IS OUT
WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE THANK
YOU SO MUCH SOONER DURAZO IN
THE VICE CHAIR CAN ROLL ON OUT
AS YOU ARE UP ON ALL THE BILLS
THEIR DRUGS HAVE A WONDERFUL
WEEKEND I HOPE YOU COULD SEE
THE GRANDS THIS WEEKEND- THANK
YOU SO MUCH THINNER BECKER
THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR WORK SIR AND THANK YOU FOR
HANGING WITH US- IT. ALL RIGHT
WE ARE GOING TO JUMP BACK AT MR
CANAL TO ONE ITEM AND THAT'S
ITEM EIGHTEEN SB SEVEN ZERO SIX
CENTER WINNER WE JUST NEED YOUR
VOTE ON IT- NO. HANG ON ONE
SECOND SO WE. ALL RIGHT SORRY
ABOUT THAT THAT'S WE ARE ALL
CAUGHT UP SO ITEM NINETEEN
WERE- LOOKING AT ITEM NINETEEN
THERE'S ONLY ONE ITEM THAT WE
NEED TO GET CENTER WINNER ON
ITS SP SEVEN SEVEN ONE. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE ZERO MR
CANAL PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS SENATOR HERTZBERG.
SENATOR WIENER WINNER HI FOUR
ZERO FOUR ZERO VOTE LAYS DOWN
THAT BILL IS OUT WE ARE CLOSING
THE ROLE A BIG HEARTY THANK YOU
TO CALLING HER NOW TO THE
ENTIRE GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
TEAM FOR THE FANTASTIC WORK OF
THIS. IN DEPTH HEARING TO THE
SERGEANTS THANK YOU VERY VERY
MUCH TO OUR TECHNICAL TEAM-
EVERYONE BEHIND THE SCENES
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
TODAY AND FOR ALL YOUR HARD
WORK. HOPE EVERYBODY HAS A DANG
GOOD WEEKEND. AT THIS HEARING
OF THE GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE IS NOW ADJOURNED.